EVERYONE AT PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED
IN ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING OUT TODAY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU ALL FOR
TAKING TIME IN YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULES TO BE A TO BE WITH US
AT THIS. REALLY GROUNDBREAKING
HEARING THE FIRST TIME THAT.
SENATE HOUSING SITTING HUMAN
SERVICES INNOCENT GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEES HAVE
COME TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO.
FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS HI THIS IS
AN ALL HANDS ON DECK EFFORT. IN
ONE TAKE A MOMENT TO BE ABLE TO
KNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK BY
BOTH. CHAIRWOMAN HURTADO AND-
CHAIRMAN WIENER AND ALL THE
SENATORS WERE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. ON THIS ISSUE. I IN
BIG CITIES AND SMALL. HOMELESS
RESIDENTS BY THE THOUSANDS
SLEEP ON OUR STREETS EVERY
NIGHT. AND I THINK THAT YOU
AGREE WITH THIS IT'S SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE. IT'S DISGRACEFUL
AND IT'S THE FAILURE OF
GOVERNMENT AT ALL LEVELS. AS A
RESULT THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO TAKE BOLD ACTION TO
PROVIDE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE.
HOUSING SHELTER SERVICES AND
PROGRAMMING. IN THIS EFFORT
CAN'T BE ONE TIME. IT MUST BE
ON GOING. AND WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL TO BE A PARTNER WITH
THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE
INCIDENT HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE WORKING TOGETHER NOW AND IN
THE MONTHS TO COME TO BE A TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE
PARTNERSHIP. BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS. CRISIS IN THIS CRISIS
I THINK YOU'LL AGREE- TOUCHES
THE LIVES OF. SO MANY STATE TAX.
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS FIRMER RURAL
COMMUNITIES TO OUR LARGEST
CITIES ARE. SLEEPING OUR
SIDEWALKS EVERY NIGHT. IT
VETERANS INDUSTRY THE RESOURCE
OF OUR HEALTH IN SOCIAL
SERVICES SYSTEM. AND WHILE
THERE IS A THERE MAY NOT BE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
SOLVE THE CRISIS. MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE STEPPED UP AND
THEY'VE CONSTRUCTED HOUSING
UNITS EXPANDED SHELTERS AND
FOUND. NEW WAYS TO PROVIDE
EXPANDED SERVICES TO OUR
NEIGHBORS IN. BUT AS WE ARE. AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK IN
FRONT OF A- THROUGH THE HEARING
THESE COMMITTEES WILL DIG
DEEPLY INTO THE CRISIS THE ROLE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS TO
PLAY AND HOW THE STATE CAN
PARTNER CAN PARTNER TO HELP
TRANSITION INDIVIDUALS OFF THE
STREET. AND INTO HOUSING BUT I
TO BE A FOCUS ON TODAY'S
HEARING FIRST AND FOREMOST THE
COMMITTEES RECIEVE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S RECENT
ACTIONS ON THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. SECOND THE COMMITTEES
ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM EXPERTS
ON THE CAUSES AND EFFECTS OF
HOMELESSNESS AND HOW OTHER
STATES AND COUNTRIES ARE COMBAT
IN THE CRISIS. IN HOW WE CAN
LEARN FROM THEM. THE THIRD
PANEL TODAY IS GONNA HIGHLIGHT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES THAT DAY
OF THE FOR THE BEEN THAT
THEY'VE DEPLOYED TO CONFRONT
HOMELESSNESS. AND TO ADDRESS
THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES WITHIN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS WHILE
ENCOURAGING. REGIONAL
COLLABORATION. FINALLY THE
COMMITTEES WILL HEAR FROM
PRACTITIONERS AND BEST
PRACTICES. ON WHAT HELP THE
LEGISLATURE CAN PROVIDE TO
ADDRESS THE RANGE OF NEEDS THAT
ARE HOMELESS NEIGHBORS NEED TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TODAY IN IN THE MONTHS
TO COME TO WORKING WITH EACH OF
YOU TO CONFRONT THE CHALLENGES
AHEAD. EACH OF THE CHAIRS
AGREED THIS MORNING WHEN WE HAD
OUR PRE MEETING THAT WE THAT TO
BE A TO DO A SECOND HEARING. IN
THE FALL. TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS
ON THE CAR. CAST KNOWN I WANT
TO A- AHEAD OF TIME I'M GONNA
HAVE. STEP AWAY TEMPORARY FOR
TWO MEETINGS ON HOUSING AND I
AGAIN SINCERELY APOLOGIZE BUT I
WILL RETURN AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. I'M NOW GOING TO BE-
AT TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO.
GERMAN WIENER AND- THAT MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP. THAT WE
WORKED A LOT TOGETHER ON ALL
ISSUES OF HOUSING AND NOW IT'S
HOMELESSNESS IN THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR WOMAN SHOWN HER
TITLE. FOR THE HARD WORK AS
WELL. AS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND OF COURSE. THE
MOST AS- IT IS- HOUSING THIS
TOUR AND EXTREMELY LENGTH AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU. ON THIS ISSUE-
BUT LOOKING FOR TODAY TODAY'S
HEARING I THANK ALL THE- FIVE.
BOB PULLED. NEVER THREE TESTIFY
TODAY WH THING THAT I WANT A
ARE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
EMPHASIZE I THINK A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN PEOPLE THINK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS WHAT THEY THINK
ABOUT IS WHAT THEY SEE ON THE
STREET WHICH IS A- FRANKLY A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AND- THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE LIVING IN TENTS
OR PEOPLE WHO- ARE EXPERIENCING
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH. OR THE
ISSUES- AND THEN THEY HAVE
PEOPLE SOMETIMES HAVE A
PERCEPTION THE DODD IS WHAT
HOMELESSNESS. IS ABOUT I THAT
OF COURSE IS. ONLY ONE SEGMENT
OF WHAT HOMELESSNESS IS ABOUT-
WE KNOW THAT MOST- HOMELESS
PEOPLE- ARE NOT MENTALLY ILL-
ARE NOT ADDICTED- DAILY- DON'T
NECESSARILY NEED SUPPORT OF
HOUSING. FIVE DAYS JUST NEED A
PLACE. TO LIVE BUT THEY CAN
AFFORD- SO THEY'RE NOT LIVING
IN A SHELTER LIVING IN A CAR.
WE'RE CAL SURFING OR WHATEVER-
AND SO WE ALWAYS TO KEEP THAT
IN MIND. AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE EXPLOSION OF HOMELESSNESS
AND THE NUMBERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS NOT BECAUSE ALL OF THE
SUDDEN MORE PEOPLE WERE
ADDICTED OR MORE PEOPLE WERE I
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE MORE
PEOPLE WORKING ON STABLE IN
THEIR LAW. IT'S BECAUSE FOR
MORE FORM LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE
BEING PRICED OUT OF HOUSING.
DOT DOT IS THERE NOT ROCK
SCIENCE AND SO THE TRIAGE THAT
WE ARE DOING IN THIS YEAR CAN.
BE A TRIAGE YES. IS IMPORTANT
HELPING PEOPLE GET OFF OF THE
STREETS INTO A STABLE SETTING.
SHELTER NAVIGATION CENTERS- AND
SO FORTH- EXPANDING OUR
APPROACH TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION SO THEY WERE HELPING
PEOPLE ALL OF THIS TRIAGE. IS
IMPORTANT BUT UNTIL WE SOLVE
THE ROOT CAUSE WHICH IS THAT WE
FAILED AROUND HOUSING- WE ARE
NEVER GOING TO SOLVE THIS
CRISIS- AND SO WE CAN'T DO YOU
HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM HOUSE. FROM
THANK HOUSING PROBLEMS. IT IS
ONE AND THE SAME- AND SO WE
NEED THE I ONE OF THE THINGS
KEEP UP AT NIGHT HI SOMEONE THE
BAY AREA. IS THERE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW WAGE WORKERS
IN THE BAY AREA WHO WERE HOUSE
RIGHT NOW. BABY HOME WITHIN A
YEAR OR TWO BECAUSE THERE IS
NOTHING THAT THEY CAN AFFORD.
ANYWAY FOR THE RETURN. SO WE
HAVE A MULTIMILLION. DEFICIT IN
CALIFORNIA RANKS. NINE OUT OF
FIFTY STATES HOMES FOR UPPER.
AND IN THE SIXTY YEAR AS OUR
POPULATION IS ALL PULLED ARE
OUR HOUSING. ON THE BY THREE
QUARTERS. IN THIS ROOM. YEAH WE
ARE SELLING A BROKE RECORD
BECAUSE I IS ICE DOES ALIVE BUT
THE TESTER ARE SO X. AND IT IS
ONE OF THE RE WHY PEOPLE ARE TO
TWO HOURS TO WORK THAT'S ONE OF
THE WHY MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
ARE DOING THINGS LIKE LIVING IN
THEIR CARS SO WE HAVE TO VIEW
HOMELESSNESS IN THE CONTEXT OF
A BROKEN HOUSING SYSTEM NOT
ENOUGH HOUSING. NOT ENOUGH
INVESTMENT HOUSING SUBSIDIES
NOT ENOUGH RENTS ARE
PROTECTIONS ALL OF THESE OTHER
HOUSING ISSUES ARE INEXTRICABLY
LINKED TO HOMELESSNESS THE%
OTHER THING THAT I WANT TO
TOUCH ON IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
THE BIG STRUCTURAL ISSUE FOR
THE SEGMENT OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT IS SUFFERING
FROM ADDICTION AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND THAT'S NOT A
TINY PORTION IS NOT A MAJORITY
BUT SAW TINY PORTION- WE HAVE
TO DO MORE AROUND GETTING TO
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION. JUST BEFORE THEY
BECOME HOMELESS AND RIGHT NOW
OUR SYSTEM IS SET UP SO THAT
YOU GET ADDICTION A MENTAL
HEALTH CARE WHEN YOU ARE
ALREADY IN CRISIS WE WANTED TO
PEOPLE WITH THESE CHALLENGES
WALLY STILL HAVE JOB WHILE
STILL HAVE A HOME I STILL HAVE
A FAMILY AND PREVENT THEM FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS RIGHT RIGHT
GOING TO THAT POINT SO IT'S
ABOUT. HOW IT'S ABOUT SHOULD
BRING UP OUR PROVISION OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
SERVICES IN GETTING THE PEOPLE
EARLY AND THEN HOPEFULLY THREE
ARE NOT BURKE GOES DOWN BECAUSE
THIS JUST BE ABOUT TRIAGE SO
AGAIN I EVERYONE LOOK. FORWARD
TO HEARING. GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE TO THIS JOINT
AND FROM. HEARING I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIRS OF THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. AND THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDING HUMAN
SERVICES IN TWO DAYS HEARING. I
BELIEVE THAT COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THESE VERY DISTINCT
POLICY COMMITTEES SIGNALS A
RECOGNITION THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS. CRISIS IS MULTI
FACETED AND WILL REQUIRE
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS AND
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE
MULTITUDE OF POLICY AREAS. I
BELIEVE THIS IS A HISTORIC
EVENT I DON'T THINK THESE THREE
COMMITTEES HAVE HELD A HEARING
TOGETHER BEFORE TODAY. I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE A QUICK MOMENT TO
WELCOME SENATOR JONES AS A NEW
MEMBER OF THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE. AT WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH. AS
CHAIR OF HUMAN SERVICES I EAT I
AM PLEASED THAT THE PROGRAMS WE
OVERSEE ARE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION AND THAT MY
COLLEAGUES WILL HEAR ABOUT HOW
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE. ARE SERVE TO
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS I LOOK
FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE ABOUT
THE LOCAL PERSPECTIVE AND HOW
LEADERS IN THE HOUSING POLICY-
ARE WORKING TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND TODAY WE ARE
FOCUSED ON ON AN ISSUE THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO ADDRESSED- AND
ON THE TOP OF EVERYONE'S MIND
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE KNOW THAT. CALIFORNIA'S
BECOME INCREASINGLY
UNAFFORDABLE FOR STATES
RESIDENTS IN THAT SEVERE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IS
PUT IS PRETTY MANY AT RISK- OF
HOUSING INSTABILITY IN
HOMELESSNESS. FOR THE STATE'S
LOWEST INCOME HOUSEHOLDS A JOB
BLOCKS WERE EXPECTED EXPENSE
MAY RESULT IN HOMELESSNESS.
OFFERED THOSE PEOPLE TO ACCESS
THE STATE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
THE GAP BETWEEN FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE TO COST OF LIVING. COSTS
DATE. MAY CONTINUE TO FEEL
INSURMOUNTABLE. THAT IS WHY I'M
SO THAT WE ARE HERE TO DATE TO
REVIEW WHAT THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN BETWEEN
WHAT TO COMBAT. PRICES TO OUR
BY OUR EXIT IN US. TO HELP YOU.
GREEN BEAN HOMELESS. I'D AM
FROM THOSE WORKING TO HOME THAT
THE A CITY LAW AND TO LOOK
TOWARDS WE MIGHT DO BETTER
TOGETHER THE FUTURE. WITH AN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE DO
NOT HAVE TIME TO WAIT WE MUST
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THOSE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING-
HOMELESSNESS AND LOOK FORWARD.
TO WAYS TO PREVENT THOSE AT
RISK OF FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS WITH FROM DON WITHIN OUR
STATE SAFETY NETS. AT THIS
MOMENT I REALLY WANT TO- AT
THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE
TODAY BUT ALSO I LIKE TO CALL
UP OUR FIRST PANEL. SO IF WE
CAN HAVE. ALEX AND KIM JOHNSON.
COME UP PLEASE. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO KNOW THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
MUST BE DONE BY ELEVEN AM
BECAUSE SHE HAS OTHER SENATE-
BUSINESS TO ATTEND TO INCLUDING
HER CONFIRMATION HEARING SENATE
RULES THIS AFTERNOON SO THANK
YOU AT DIRECTOR JOHNSON FOR
JOINING US I KNOW YOU HAVE A
FULL SCHEDULE SO- WE APPRECIATE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PRESIDENT
YOUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY AND-
PLEASE FILL. A PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. A
GOOD MORNING TEARS IN MEMBERS
CAN JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
YOUR AGENDA TODAY OUTLINES A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
IS RESPONSIBLE TO OVERSEEING WE
HAVE FIVE PROGRAMS WITH OUR
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS BRANCH
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. AT EACH
OF THOSE FIVE WERE PROGRAMS
GREW OUT OF THE NEED TO
INTEGRATE IN ADDRESS THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WITHIN THE POPULATIONS THAT
WERE SERVING AND THAT'S HOW
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED OVER TIME.
SO THE FIVE PROGRAMS ASSIST
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OUR HOUSING
INSTABILITY WHO ARE SERVED BY
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCY
THOSE INCLUDE OUR CAO WORKS
PROGRAM CASH ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
FOR FAMILIES EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES CHILD WELFARE COUNTY
GENERAL ASSISTANCE GENERAL
RELIEF. DISABILITY BENEFIT
PROGRAMS AND ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES LL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF EACH OF THOSE
INCLUDING AT THE RECENT NUMBERS
OF THOSE SERVED. OUR CAL WORKS
HOUSING SUPPORTING PROBST
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM IS A
STATE FUNDED PROGRAM IN WHICH
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES PROVIDE
HOUSING RELATED SUPPORTS TO
ELIGIBLE CAO WORKS FAMILIES.
THOUGH SUPPORTS INCLUDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE HOUSING
RELATED WRAPAROUND SERVICES
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
RENTAL ASSISTANCE HOUSING OUT
REACHING NAVIGATE CASE
MANAGEMENT SECURITY DEPOSITS
UTILITY PAYMENTS AND MORE. AT
THE HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM
LIKE ALL OF OUR HOUSING
PROGRAMS USES THE HOUSE HOUSING
FIRST MODEL- IN THAT IS AN
ACQUIREMENT THAT I THINK THE
SENATE WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY'RE HOUSING INCLUDING
COUNCIL IS REQUIRING IN
STATUTES REQUIRING- WE ALSO
INSURE THAT ALL OF OUR COUNTIES
IN THE HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM
COLLABORATE WITH THEIR LOCAL
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE OR THEIR
CEO SEES. THE SUPPORT PROGRAM
INTO WORKS THIS BUT POPPY. I
BEGAN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT AND HAS NOW GROWN TO
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET. WE HAVE
FIFTY THREE OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES PARTICIPATING. AND THE
NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN HOUSE SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO THE HOUSING SUPPORT
CREEK PROGRAM WE HAVE A
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WITHIN OUR CAO WORKS AB- ARRAY
AND THAT'S MORE OF AN EMERGENCY
SHELTER PROGRAM TO BLEND IN
BRAID WITH THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM FOR MORE PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS. HAVE BECOME WORKS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AGAIN SERVES THE SAME
POPULATION BUT FOR HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE YOU MUST ALSO HAVE
LESS THAN A HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
LIQUID RESOURCES OR CASH ON
HAND. THERE ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS
TO THAT- THOSE FAMILIES THAT
ARE IN OUR CAL WORKS PROGRAM
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
A MEDICALLY VERIFIED PHYSICAL
OR MENTAL ILLNESS IN THOSE
EXPERIENCING A FIRE ON THAT OR
NATURAL DISASTER BEYOND THE
FAMILIES CONTROL. OUR EX
HOUSING IS THAT HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE CAN PROVIDE PAYMENTS
FOR TEMPORARY SHELTER FOR UP TO
SIXTEEN DAYS. AS WELL AS
PAYMENTS TO SECURE OR MAINTAIN
HOUSING INCLUDING A SECURITY
DEPOSIT OR LAST MONTH'S RENT OR
UP TO TWO MONTHS OF RENT A REAR
AGES. WE HAVE SEEN IT PRETTY
STEADY OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
COUNTIES AS SERVING AROUND
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
WITH ARE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SPENDING- IN THE LAST
FISCAL YEAR- OVER SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON THAT PARTICULAR
EFFORT. SHIFTING FROM FAMILIES-
IN OUR CAO WORKS PROGRAM TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THOSE
IN OUR CHILD WELFARE AT PROGRAM
AND SO THEY'RE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME. IS A PROGRAM
INTENDED TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF FAMILIES IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS INCREASE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND PREVENT
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENTS.
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME SERVICE
HOMELESS FAMILIES INVOLVED WITH
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED TO OFFER THOSE
SUPPORTS TO HELP FAMILIES
REUNIFY. IT OFFERS FINANCIAL
INSISTENCE ON HOUSING RELATED
WRAPAROUND SERVICES VERY
SIMILAR TO THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED IN
OUR CAO WORKS AT HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM. WE HAVE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN A
RECENT ALLOCATION FOR ANOTHER
THREE YEARS TO CONTINUE THIS
EFFORT AT JULY OF NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND THE
FIRST AT ROUND AS FUNDING FOR
THIS AT AT FOR WE HAVE SERVED
OVER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
FAMILIES. I'D IN EIGHTY EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE OTHER
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN PERMANENTLY
HOUSE- WE ARE- RIGHT IN THE
MIDST OF A EVALUATION OF THIS
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB
IN THOSE INITIAL FINDINGS WILL
BE AVAILABLE LATER THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. THE NEXT I
PROGRAM THAT WE EVER SEE IS THE
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM WHICH IS FOCUSED ON OUT
REACH CASE MANAGEMENT BENEFITS
ADVOCACY AND HOUSING SUPPORTS
TO INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE
DISABLED ARE LIKELY DISABLED
AND WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS EXPERIENCING
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS AND THOSE
WHO RELY MOST HEAVILY ON STATE
AND COUNTY FUNDED SERVICES ARE
GIVEN THE PART HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR THIS PROGRAM- WE REFER TO
THIS PROGRAM IS EIGHT STOP IT
FOLLOWS UP AGAIN THE HOUSING
FOR SMALLER. MODEL WITH
RAPIDITY HOUSING AND PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. COUNTIES OR
TRIBES OPERATING DATE STEP
PROGRAM MUST WORKING
COLLABORATION COORDINATION WITH
THE CEO SEES- IN THIS PROGRAM-
WE HAVE SINCE DECEMBER
200-019-3200 PROGRAM ENROLLEES
ELEVEN HUNDRED OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN PERMANENTLY HOUSED.
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED OF HAVE HAD A
DISABILITY APPLICATION
SUBMITTED IN FIVE HUNDRED OF
THOSE HAVE HAD A DISABILITY
APPLICATION APPROVED- WE AGAIN
HAVE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- AND CURRENT BUDGET FOR
THIS PROGRAM OUR APPLICATIONS
ARE DUE THIS MONTH FROM
COUNTIES WE'VE ALREADY REACHED.
THIRTY THREE- AND WILL WORK
VERY QUICKLY AT THOSE FUNDS OUT.
CAN FINALLY HAVE OUR HOUSING
PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED WITH THE
ADULT PROTECTIVE. SYSTEM THAT'S
OUR HOME SAFE PROGRAM. AND
AGAIN IT IS SERVING THOSE
IMMINENT IMMINENT RISK OF
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
THE ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT
ABUSE NEGLECT SELF NEGLECT OR
FINANCIAL EXPLOITATION. OF THE
GRANTEES OPERATING HOME SAFE
PROGRAMS OFFER A RANGE OF
SRATEGIES TO SUPPORT HOUSING
SENSIBILITY FOR APS CLIENTS
THESE TEND TO BE MORE SHORT
TERM- COULD BE LEGAL SERVICES
THE FICTION AT PREVENTION HEAVY
CLEANING LANDLORD MEDIATION.
AMONG OTHER SERVICES. THIS
AGAIN HAS A STRONG
COLLABORATION BETWEEN EIGHT
EIGHT PS AGENCY AND COUNTY AND
THE REST OF THE SYSTEM. BACK
HOME SAFE HAS BEEN IT HAS A
ALLOCATION- A FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WE HAVE SEEN THIS IS A
NEW ART THE NEWEST PROGRAM OF
THOSE THAT I'VE MENTIONED SO
THROUGH DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. WE'VE BEEN ROLLED
SEVEN HUNDRED AND 50%
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PROGRAM WE
DO EXPECT THIS NUMBER TO
INCREASE AS UNFORTUNATELY ALSO.
ADD THE NUMBER EIGHT PS AT
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE STAVING
ACROSS THE STATE IS ALSO
INCREASING. TWENTY FIVE
COUNTIES ARE FUNDED WITH THIS
EFFORT WE WERE ABLE TO BRING ON
VIEW COUNTY AS A LATE ADDITION
WE GAVE THEM SOME ADDITIONAL
TIME AT TO SUBMIT THEIR
APPLICATION PARTICIPATED ALL
THE EXPERIENCES THEY'VE HAD
WITH DISASTER. THIS IS ALSO ARE
GOING TO BE EVALUATED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO I AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ENGAGING THAT AND THINKING
ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOTH
POLICY ALIGNMENT BUT ALSO DATA
COLLECTION. AND REPORTING
ACROSS ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS
CONNECTED WITH MUCH OF THE WORK
THAT THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES HOUSING IN
COORDINATING COUNCIL ARE DOING
IN THAT SPACE. SO THAT
CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW AND HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS. HELLO ALEX
AND WITH THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY
OVERSEEING THAT- HOMES CAR
NEEDING FINANCING COUNCIL- SO
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF ADDITIONAL
CONTEXT I WANTED TO PROVIDE IN
SOME OF THE WAYS WE'RE
THINKING. ABOUT THE PROBLEM-
BEFORE I DIVE INTO SORT OF IT
THE CONTEXT OF. DOING SO IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT THAT WE HAVE A I
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS AT ANY
GIVEN TIME THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
THE STATE- WE EXPECT THAT
NUMBER- THE GENERAL ASSUMPTION
IS THAT ANY. THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR YOU CAN MULTIPLY THAT BY
TWO OR THREE TIMES TO GET THE
YEARS THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OVER
AN ANNUAL CALENDAR YEAR. THAT
PUTS A LOT OF THIS IN CONTEXT
THOSE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN GOING.
I'M CALIFORNIA. TWELVE THE
NATION'S TOP BUT 7% OF ITS
HOMELESS POPULATION ANARCHIST
IS EXPERIENCING A 16% INCREASE
IN HOMELESSNESS FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AT 21% INCREASE IN A
SHELTER HOMELESSNESS. AS THE
GOVERNOR ALSO NOTED IN HIS HIS
STATE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
FACT THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA. 33% OF THE STATE.
HOW IS BOB. PERCENT OF OUR-
MISSION GENERALLY. I'M SO IN
THAT CONTEXT IS A OF AT HOME IS
CREATING AND FINANCING COUNCIL
IS WORKING ON RIGHT NOW. I
THINK FOLKS ARE MOST FAMILIAR
WITH THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TO
SORT OF POTS OF FUNDING AND
PROGRAMMING BUT I WANT TO TAKE
A MINUTE TO EXPLAIN ALSO THAT.
THE ROLE THAT WE SEE IN TERMS
OF COORDINATING AND FINANCING
WHICH IS IN OUR TITLE- THE
COUNCIL HAS EIGHTEEN STATUTORY
GOALS- WHICH WE ARE
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON A FEW KEY
PRIORITIES ON THIS YEAR. THE
FIRST WHICH CANCER BUT IT TOO-
WE ARE DEVELOPING A STATEWIDE
HOME A STATE INTEGRATION SYSTEM
IT WAS MENTIONED IN THE
GOVERNOR STATE STATE WE ARE
INCREDIBLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
WEEK COULD BEAT THIRD. IN THE
COUNTRY YOU SAID AS- IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO A- BETTER LOOK AT.
THIS HAPPY CROSSED THE STAY IN
TERMS OF TRYING. OF WHO SIR. IN
TERMS OF WHAT OTHERS. AND THE
COMMUNITIES SO THAT IS A REAL
EFFORT WERE TAKING ON THAT TO
HELP- ALL OF THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT THAT. PROVIDE HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING ACROSS THE STATE TO AT
TEN HAVE ACCESS INTO. WE ARE
ALSO IN THE MIDST OF DEVELOPING
AND WORKING TOWARD THAT I WORK
PLAN FOR A DATA DRIVEN EVIDENCE
BASED ACTION ORIENTED STRATEGIC
PLAN- WE ARE VERY AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT THINGS. STATE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE IN
COORDINATION HAVE A FOR THAT-
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO IT
TO. OUR CANNOT HEAR THE
EXCELLENT BUT- WE ALSO HAVE
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT OF THE
HOUSING FIRST ME IN. ALL
DEPARTMENTS ARE EXPECTED TO BE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING FOR
AS OF THE JULY ISSUE. YEAR BUT
WE WILL CONTINUE ENSURE THAT
COMPLAINTS IS AS MATT AND AS
NEW PRO. ONLINE THEY ARE
CALLING. FALLING WITH THAT
MANDATE. ALSO IT. CAN DO AND-
AS YOU SAID TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM CITING
USE FOR A WITH TWO PASS A OF
TALK ABOUT JUST A SECOND BUT
ALSO TRYING TO A BIT MORE
BROADLY ABOUT THAT SPECIFIC
POPULATION AND ANSWERED MOST
CERTAINLY CONTINUED FELT
FACILITATION BETWEEN STATES.
HAVE DOING AND PROGRAMS AT A
TIME ASSIST THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- WE APPRECIATE THAT THERE
ARE MANY DIFFERENT-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN AND
SHOULD BE A PART OF THIS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- MAKING
SURE THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND OUR
EXPERTISE BUT WORKING CORDON
THANK CORDONS AND A GOAL. IN
ADDITION TO OF THE COORDINATING
CAN SORT OF THE- VIEW. OF
ACCOUNTS SO WE ALSO HAVE TO
PROGRAMS THAT WE IMPLEMENT. THE
FIRST IS OUT LOVINGLY REFER TO
AS HE- ARE HOMELESS EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. IT WAS A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AUTHORIZED IN IN THE FY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET WAS
ALLOCATED TO FORTY THREE CAN.
MS OF CARE AND LET LARGE CITY
IS- ALL FIFTY ORDER SECTIONS
EVEN FUNDING WERE REQUIRED TO
ALLOCATE A MINIMUM OF 5% OF
THE- FUNDING. USE HOMELESS.
FUNDS TO BE SPENT BY JUNE OF
TWO TWENTY ONE. SO WE- PART OF
IT WAS REQUIRED AND STATUES
ANNUAL REPORTS FROM ALL OF THE
GRANTEES THOSE ARE DUE TO US IN
JANUARY AND SO WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF DOING SOME EARLY
ANALYSIS ON THAT RIGHT NOW- BUT
IS GENERALLY WERE REFINING THAT
AS OF SEPTEMBER WHICH IS IN THE
ANNUAL REPORT COLLECTED THREE.
ALREADY OUT OF THE SPENDING ON
HAS BEEN SPENT ON CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS. SISTER PRIMARILY
INCREASING SHELTER CAPACITY.
THEIR MARGINS EACH OTHER'S AN
APPLICATION CENTERS. SERVICES
SUCH AS STREET OUT REGION
HOUSING NAVIGATORS- APPEAR TO
BE THE SECOND LARGEST CATEGORY
OF SPENDING RIGHT NOW. FOLLOWED
BY RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUBSIDIES. OVERALL WE ARE
SEEING COMMUNITIES I'M REALLY
THINKING CRITICALLY ABOUT HOW
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS THE
MAJORITY OF NEEDS ARE FUN ARE
USING THEIR FUNDING SORT OF AND
THREE GENERAL CATEGORIES IS HOW
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IT- SORT
OF AN INNOVATION OR CREATION
SORT OF THINKING ABOUT USING
THIS FUNDING IS A NEW WAY TO
TEST ANY THING IN THERE YOUR
THINK ABOUT SOMETHING. I
HAVEN'T ANY DO BEFORE. ONLY
SOME THAT WAS SUCCESS PIE. BUT
NOT ABLE TO REACH THE FULL
POPULATION. FOR REASSESSING AND
REVAMPING THEIR AT THEIR SORT
OF HOMELESS SYSTEM AND HOW
FOLKS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS INTO
IT. WE'RE ALSO SEEING SOME
REALLY EXCITING SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS FOR YOU SORT OF
UNDERSTANDING HOW YOU ACCESS
THE SYSTEM AND THAT THEIR
UNIQUE NEEDS MIGHT REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL FOCUS- AND A REAL
STRONG COMMITMENT TO. TO
HOUSING FIRST FOR THE PER THE
MANDATE. SPECIFICALLY ON USE-
WE'RE SEEING SOME REALLY
INTERESTING INVESTMENTS IN
EMERGENCIES SOLUTIONS AND
COMMUNITY PLACES WHERE YOU
DIDN'T HAVE A SAFE SPACE. TO BE
SHELTERED- ARE HAVE A SAFE
SPACE TO COME INDOORS- REALLY
TRYING TO FOCUS A BIT MORE ON
THAT IN COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
DID THERE WAS NOT ACCESS TO
THAT IN THE PAST. AND REALLY
FOCUSING ON WHERE THE BROADER
HOMELESSNESS AND CAN BETTER
SUPPORT YOU SPECIFIC SERVICES.
WE ARE ALSO PARTNERING WITH CSU
SACRAMENTO- WHO IS IN THE MIDST
OF DRAFTING A FINAL VERSION OF
AN INITIAL ASSESSMENT REPORT ON
HEAT THAT WILL REALLY TALK
ABOUT MORE ABOUT THE PROCESS.
OF WHEN THIS KIND OF FUNDING
GOES OUT INTO A COMMUNITY HOW
DID THEY THINK ABOUT IT HOW DID
THE STAT INTERACT- AND SORT OF
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF HOW TO USE THE FUNDING
THAT SHOULD BE COMING OUT FOR
EARLY. IN ADDITION HE- OUT LAST
YEAR WE WERE ALSO THAT TASKED
WITH ALLOCATING ARE HALF
FUNDING ARE ARE HOMELESS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM- A SIX AND A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED
TO ALL OF OUR CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE ALL. FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND THIRTEEN LARGE CITIES. ALL
HUNDRED FOURTEEN JURISDICTIONS
ARE RECEIVING FUNDING. REQUIRED
ALLOCATE A MINIMUM. 8% SO ABOUT
FROM FROM HEAT- 8% ON YOU
SPENDING. OFTEN THAT MUST BE
SPENT BY JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE- AND WE JUST RECENTLY
PASSED THE DEADLINE FOR
APPLICATIONS INTRODUCED ON
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH SO THE TEAM
IS VERY ACTIVELY REVIEWING- FOR
COMPLETION ALL OF THOSE
APPLICATION AS WE SPEAK- SINCE
SOME DIFFERENCES FROM KEEP TO
THAT TO HAPPEN I WOULD TO SORT
OF LIKE TO CALL OUT BECAUSE I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO SORT
OF UNDERSTAND. THAT THE
TRANSITION SORT OF THAT THE-
MAC PATH WE'VE BEEN ON FOR SOME
OF THIS. APP DOES HAVE MORE
STRICT ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
OF HOW THE FUNDING CAN BE
SPENT. AND TO REALLY CLEAR ODD
BUCKETS AROUND ELIGIBLE USE. IT
ALSO HAS A STRONGER REQUIRE
DEMONSTRATION FOR REGIONAL
COLLABORATION WE REQUIRED
LETTERS OF SUPPORT FROM
OVERLAPPING JURISDICTIONS- SO
IF THERE'S A CONTINUUM OF CARE
THEY NEED A LETTER FROM THEIR
CSE AND THEIR LARGE CITY TO SAY
THAT EVERYBODY WAS THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO SPEND THIS FUNDING
LOCALLY IN THE SAME DIRECTION.
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE WAS
SORT OF ROWING IN IN THE SAME
IN THE SAME. DIRECTION AND THE
REQUIRING CLEAR GOALS ATTACHED
TO THAT FUNDING IS A REALLY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WITH HIS
ADDITIONAL INFUSION OF FUNDING
AT THE END OF THIS PROGRAM WHAT
WHAT THEY EXPECT TO SEE. IN
ADDITION TO THOSE TWO BY THE
FUNDING WE ALSO ARE IN THE
MIDST OF- THE GOVERNOR'S
HUNDRED DAY CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE BROUGHT ON. A REALLY
REMARKABLE TECHNICAL. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER RAPID
RESULTS INSTITUTE WHO HAS DONE
THESE THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY-
THOSE WILL BE LAUNCHING THE
FIRST COHORT HERE JUST IN A
COUPLE WEEKS THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED. THAT THE GROUP OF.
THOSE WITH LAYS BOSS ALAMEDA
AND RIVERSIDE STARTING JUST IN
A COUPLE WEEKS. I'M REALLY THAT
THE INTENT OF THAT IS TO BE A
REALLY INTENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROCESS. AND DAY.
LOOK AT. IN THE SYSTEM SHOULD
BE. ON IT COULD BE CHANGED
WHERE'S ROCKER SEE THAT NEEDS
TO BE BROKEN DOWN. WORK A
STREAMLINE THINGS THAT EVERYONE
IS REALLY. IN THE SAME DRESS
AND THERE. ARE A HUNDRED DAYS
WHAT HAPPENS IN AND WHAT IS
THE- RESORT MISTER. AND FROM
THAT. IS ALSO. SOME WORKS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. SO THERE
WILL BE. A COURT OF THAT
STARTING HERE IN A COUPLE WEEKS
A SECOND COVERT STARTING IN MAY
AND A THIRD COURT STARTING THIS
SUMMER. WE ARE ALSO- AT IT
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING A
LOT OF THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER. SO AS YOU MIGHT HAVE
SEEN IT WE RELEASED TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX STATE OWNED
PROPERTIES SORT OF ACCESS STATE
LAND- JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
THAT IS POSTED ON OUR HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL'S WEBSITE FOR
COMMUNITIES. USE FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERING PURPOSS- SHELTER
SERVICES AN OPERATING COSTS I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO CALL OUT FOR
THOSE CAN BE FUNDED TO KEEP AND
HAPPY SO THERE IS FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE PROPERTIES
TO ACTION. I'M USE THEM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- AN EMPLOYER IN THE
MIDST OF A- YOU CAN MENTION IT.
IS OF PROPERTIES. THE THROUGH
THAT THERE WERE HER TRAVEL
TRAILERS THAT ALL BEEN. TO
THESE OF FOR ALSO FOR
EMERGENCIES ALTERING PURPOSES.
AB FOR BOTH THE TRAILERS AND
THE STATE LANDS WE WILL BE
COLLECTING- PERFORMANCE-
METRICS ON THAT- ON A MONTHLY
BASIS AS SOON AS INDIVIDUALS
ARE. DONE TO THE PROPERTY SO WE
EXPECT IT TO HAVE A ON HIS AND
HAVING THAT UP ON OUR WEBSITE.
AS SOON AS THAT IS AVAILABLE.
HALF I WILL STOP. IT'S THE
GENERAL GIST A BIT WITH THE
TEAM IS WORKING ON. THANK YOU
SO MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OUR FIRST PANEL.
CENTER WHAT CASKEY. THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM WE THE THEORY IS
THAT WE GIVE 20% OF MONEY THAT
FROM THE AUCTION PRICE TO FOR
HOUSING. IS THAT BECAUSE ITS
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL I
DON'T KNOW HOW THEY INTERACT
WITH YOUR PROGRAMS AT ALL- AND
I DID AND THEY WERE SORT OF
BUILDING DENSER HOUSING ON
TRANSIT LINES YET AT THAT ACT
HOW IT IS THERE ANY CONNECTION
COLLABORATION BETWEEN. THE FIVE
PROGRAMS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT-
THEY KEEP KEEP IN ALL THESE
THINGS IS OR ANY COMMUNICATION
WITH THIS SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT WE
SPEND. MUCH I CAN SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO ON THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAMS I WILL SAY WHERE
THERE IS- GENERALLY SPEAKING
AND THIS ISN'T JUST AT THE
STATE DOES AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL TWO THERE IS OFTEN SILENT
BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING- AND SETTLE IT POP WHAT
THE HOMELESS CORNING AND FAXING
COUNCIL IS FOCUSED. ON IS
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SORT OF.
MANAGE THAT THAT DIVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLEARLY THE
STRATEGICAL COUNCILS NOT ON THE
COUNT ON OUR HOME IS CREATING
AN FINANCING COUNCIL AND SO PRO
THE HOUSE. GRANT ARE NOT
INCLUDED ON THE COUNCIL ISJUST
THOMAS PROGRAMS TO WERE WORKING
WITH IN FORMAL WEAR BUT I WOULD
SAY THERE IS NOTHING I'M MORE.
I OUR PROGRAM. YOU KNOW I GET I
WOULD USE THAT FOR THE PRO THAT
WE ADMINISTER AT THE CONCEPTS
AROUND BOTH THE INTEGRATION OF
THE SUPPORTS FOR IT THAT LARGER
AND BROADER PROGRAM EFFORTS OF
ANY OF THESE GIVEN POPULATIONS
BUT ALSO THAT CONNECTION BACK
TO HOW THIS PARTICULAR THIS
PARTICULAR DOLLARS AND
RESOURCES CAN BE LEVERAGED
THROUGHOUT THE STRATEGIES LOCAL
IN THE CASE THAT THERE'S
PLANNING THAT OCCURS. AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL WE ARE. THIS
INSTANCE THE ABOUT HOW THE FOR.
IN THESE POPPY. CAN BE USED IN
MAX THE PLAN IN IN THE GIVEN
CAN. SO WE WOULD JUST BE BY
CHANCE THAT SOME OF THE MONEY
THAT WAS COMING FROM THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL SOME.
COUNTY APPLICANT OR SOMEBODY
HAPPENED TO LOOK FOR SOME OF
THAT MONEY THAT MAY PROVIDE.
HOUSING LOW INCOME HOUSING-
HOUSING FOR- THIS POPPED UP THE
HOMELESS POPULATION OF THE RE
RE HOUSE POEMS POPULATION SHE
SAID WHICH IS A CHRISTMAS
MIRACLE IF IT HAPPENS BUT NOT
GETTING INTO THE CRISPY UNCLE
QUESTION BUT- YOU KNOW I DO
THINK AND THIS IS WHERE AE YOU
SEE PARTNERS PROBABLY COULD
SPEAK MORE CLEARLY TO SOME OF
THESE PIECES. I DON'T KNOW
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE PROGRAM
YOU'RE REFERENCING BUT I DO
KNOW A LOT OF THAT THE EFFORTS
AROUND BUILDING HOUSING AND
THEN THE GRANTS THAT HAVE BEEN
GIVEN FROM HD HAVE REALLY
FOCUSED ON- WHERE THERE IS
PRIORITY GIVEN FOR HOME OF
HOMELESS OR FORMALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS I THINK THAT IS A
PIECE OF THIS THIS PUZZLE THAT-
THE POPULATIONS WERE. SERVING
OBVIOUSLY NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SO WE'RE JUST A PIECE OF THAT
PUZZLE JUST SORT OF LIKE THEIR
PIECE OF OURS SO I WOULD SAY
THAT THERE'S NOT A LOT OF. THAT
MORE THAN A- COULD BE DONE HAS
THE TITLE OF OUR COUNCIL WERE
THREE YEARS OLD BUT- I THINK
THAT PART OF WHAT WE SEE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS HELPING
COMMUNITIES THANKS TO ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAM
FOR STATE IS GIVING OUT. AND
HOW TO BEST USE THOSE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. HAVE SENATOR BELL
AND THEN FOLLOWED BY CENTER
MORE LOCK. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND WORK AND ALL THE GOOD
WORK YOU'RE DOING APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH- I WANTED US ABOUT-
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION IN. MY
DISTRICT- WITH THE LARGE
UNIVERSITY WE HAVE SOME OF THE
STATE. IT ALSO. THE URBAN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LIKE SAN
JOSE'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
THERE'S A LOT OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS OKAY THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE THE SAN JOSE IS A VERY
EXPENSIVE PLACE TO LIVE OF.
STUDENTS SO. I DON'T HAVE ANY
MEANS A LOT OF CASES OF. LIVING
IN SAN JOSE- IT'S NOT ON
AFFORDABLE AREA. THERE'S A LOT
OF AND THE CUTS CURRENTLY
THERE'S A LOT OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS I FOUND OUT THERE'S A
LOT OF HOMELESS STUDENTS ALL
OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
OUR STATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. SO DO YOU HAVE A
SPECIFIC. SEPARATE APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH. WORKING WITH THE
INSTITUTIONS. OF TO SOLVE THE
STUDENT HOMELESS PROBLEM IS TO
ARM. I THINK IT IT BEARS SELECT
OR SOME KIND OF WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE STATE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OF THE
CHANCELLOR THE COLLEGES ALL THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS SO DO YOU
HAVE ANY. OF SEPARATE
APPROACHES ARE STRATEGIES
RELATED TO- STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS. YES OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGES WAS
JUST INCLUDED ON OUR COUNCIL IN
THIS LAST YEAR'S AND A
STATUTORY CHANGE IN LAST YEAR'S
STATUTE SO THEY ARE NOW ON THE
COUNCIL AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
MY CLOSELY THEY ALSO AND I
CAN'T SPEAK FULLY DO THIS BUT
THEY ALSO HAD SOME FUNDING
GIVEN TO THEM LAST YEAR TO HELP
CREEK CALLUSES SPECIFICALLY
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. YEAH SO I
THINK THAT THEY THAT IS A
PROGRAM THAT THEY ARE RUNNING
THAT WERE HELP WITH THE SEARCH
AND I THINK THAT PART OF WHAT
WE'RE HOPING TO DO AS WE THINK
ABOUT THE HEAT AND A HALF
FUNDING WAS NOT SPECIFIC TO
STUDENTS THAT IS SPECIFIC. THAT
NAY PERCENT SEVENTY IT THEY ARE
A LOT WORSE THE BOTTOM YOU
SOUND A LOT ABOUT YOU FUNDING
GOING TOWARDS RENTAL SUBSIDIES
WHICH I THINK IS A REALLY
COMPETE. FOR A CALL. PROTECT SO
IT. THE BROUGHT. IS NOT FUNDING
CAN BE TARGETING WE'VE SEEN ON.
OF CAN YOU THAT FOR THEIR
COMMITTEE CALL THERE'S POP. ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE SERRANO OWNS.
THE THEY- THE DEALS WITH
HOMELESS STUDENTS. OR IS IT
FUNDS THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT HAS.
BEEN SAVES THE QUESTION I MEAN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I
MOVING YOUR YES SHE HAS A
VESSEL FOR SORRY ABOUT THAT.
GOOD AND EVERY WHEN YOU
SERGEANT FOR CLARIFICATION WHEN
YOU SAID THEY ARE YOU SAYING
THAT COMMITTEE CALLING ME TO
COLLEGES THE STATE COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES UNIVERSE CAL I AM.
CONFERENCE THE- UNIVERSITY
THERE IS FUNDING THAT THEY ALL
RECEIVED I BELIEVE JUST LAST
YEAR I HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THE DETAILS ON IT BECAUSE
IT'S NOT ONE OF THE PROGRAMS WE
ADMINISTER. BUT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE
STATE MUST HAVE IN. WELL I'M
WHAT I AM ROWS SUBURBAN I KIND
OF THIS. THAT THEIR SIR GETTING
LOST IN THE SHUFFLE OF THE
DISCUSSION. AND NOBODY. RESPOND
FOR THE STRATEGY WE SHOULD HAVE
LIKE IN OF A STRATEGY. MAYBE ON
STUDENT ALMOST US. OF STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS IS I'VE PERSONALLY
FIND A LOT OF THE STUDENTS
THERE ALMOST HAPPEN TO BE
FOSTER YOU. THEY'RE TRYING TO
GET THROUGH. ARM THE UNIVERSITY
OF SCHOLARS SYSTEM HELLO THE
FOSTER YOU FOR. TYPICALLY NOT
AWARE OF THE OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR. AND
SO THE THEIR UNDER THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE UNDER SUBSCRIBED.
YOU KNOW THE SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS THE OTHER. KINDS OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
YOU KNOW SINCE WE BUILT WE
WROTE AB TWELVE ON THE
LEGISLATION ON FOSTER YOU SOME
KIND OF CONCERNED ABOUT. OF
JUST THE. THE FACT THAT. THIS
ISSUE IS A SEPARATELY ADDRESSED
IT I KIND OF HAVE A I'M SORRY
TO GET A PICTURE THAT THIS
SHOULD BE SEPARATELY MAYBE- A
CATEGORY OF ITSELF THE COULD BE
ADDRESSED SPECIFICALLY WITH A
STRATEGY OFFICE YEAH I WOULD I
WOULD URGE WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT SUBPOPULATIONS AT THE
MOMENT AND SO WHAT WHAT I'M I'M
HOPING OUR STRATEGIC PLAN DOES
IS SORT OF LOOK AT- THE BROAD
POPULATION AND WHERE THERE
NEEDS TO BE SPECIFIC
INTERVENTIONS FOR SUB
POPULATIONS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS A
PART OF A- THING. BUT HOPE
BAKER THIRTY PLAN THAT ALSO
THING THAT FIVE WITH THE THAT I
THE PROPER FROM THE COLLEGE ON
THE COUNT MOTHER THE VOICE TO
IT TO SORT OF CONTINUE ON THE
ROTATION THAT HAD NOT BEEN
THERE THIS YEAR. IN A NEW VOICE
TO THE CAP. IT TO SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU'RE SPEAKING. I'LL
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TOO IN TERMS
OF FOSTER YOU SPECIFICALLY IN
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOU CAN THE
WORK OF AB TWO TWO AB TWELVE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL HOUSING SUPPORTS
THAT WE OFFERED THAT'S AS
SUPERVISE INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAM TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAMS IN TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLUS PROGRAMS. IN THE
LAST BUDGET- WE ALSO SUPPORTED
AD DOLLARS FOR HOUSING
NAVIGATION FOR FOSTER YOUTH-
THAT'S ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT SO THERE THERE IS TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE- WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT ADDITIONAL AS
ART OPTIONAL PROGRAMS IN MANY
COUNTIES. AND SO TO THE WE WANT
TO STAND WITH THE DISH. THE
TWENTY THAT THEY CAN BE OFFERED
THIS IS A- CASES BURKE FOR
CERTAIN AGE GROUPS WOULD BE
REQUIRED IN MANDATED TO
SUPPORT- BUT THOSE ALSO WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF OUT OF OUT
OVER TWENTY ONE AND IN SUPPORT
CENTER NEEDED I THINK IS
ANOTHER PIECE OF THIS NOT FOR
TODAY'S AGENDA BUT ALSO THE
PROPOSED AT HOUSING FIND. AS A
PRIORITY FOR USE IN A INCLUDED
AS WELL SO- ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT WE HAVE TO KIND OF REALLY
ENSURE THAT THAT- TRANSITIONAL
AG POP. GETTING THIS THAT THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL AS THEY
TRANSITION ON. OF THE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH AYE I THINK THE-
ESTIMATED RECENTLY THAT WAS
FIFTY THOUSAND HOMELESS
STUDENTS. AND A CALIFORNIA
STATE COLLEGE SYSTEM- THAT
DOESN'T DRY WITH OUR HOMELESS
SENSES. AND IT IS VERY IT'S
VERY APPARENT. THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE NOT COUNTED A LOT
OF THE USE ARE COUNTED. WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD ACCURATE.
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE SCALE OF
THE PROBLEM IS. AND THEREFORE
WE SHOULD DEVELOP SOME
STRATEGIES SEPARATE TO THAT
PARTICULAR PROBLEM BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD HANDLE ON
WHAT'S GOING ON OUT THERE WITH
JUNE HOMELESSNESS. IS NOT
APPARENT RIGHT NOW THE COUNTS
DON'T PICK UP THESE PEOPLE OF.
AND I'M AFRAID I'M AFRAID THEIR
PHONE AND BETWEEN THE CRACKS IN
THE SYSTEM. AND WERE UNDER
ESTIMATING WHAT THE SCALE OF
THE PROBLEM AS I JUST MENTIONED
TWO THINGS WE ARE ALSO RESPOND
ARE IMPLEMENTING THE HOMELESS
YOUTH ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND JUST RECENTLY GOT STAFF ON
BOARD- TAT TO HELP THE
SPECIFICALLY ON ON USED IN A
LOT OF THE GOALS THAT BOTH IN
THAT ACT AND- IN OUR- CREATE
INSTEAD. OUR TO YOU AROUND
BETTER IDENTIFY PROBLEM AND I
THINK THAT WE WOULD WE FULLY
AGREE- AND WE'RE WE'RE FINALLY
GETTING STEPPED UP TO BE ABLE
TO WORK ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
MORE FULLY. SO EAGER AND
WILLING TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY. WE HAVE SENATOR
MORLOCK NEXT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- TO JUMP ON THE PHRASE
YOU JUST USE SUBPOPULATIONS I'D
LIKE TO- YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE HOMELESS POPULATION I'VE
BEEN IN THE SPACE FOR A LONG
TIME. INCLUDING CHAIRING THE-
COMMISSION IN HOMELESSNESS FOR
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AS A
SUPERVISOR IN OUR COUNTY. SO
THE RECORD'S PRETTY BROAD. FOR
SOME BUT JUST EMERGENCY THAT.
JUST CAN'T FIND A FEW HUNDRED
TO PAY THE RENT. TO THE
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL SO I KIND
F WANT TO DISCUSS THAT A
LITTLE BIT- GOVERNOR NEWSOME
GAVE A RATHER UNIQUE STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS. IN VERY
NARROW VERY FOCUSED- BUT HE
ADDRESSED MENTAL ILLNESS AND-
MAYBE THE FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD
THE LANTERN PATRICK BACK
MENTIONED. TIME MAYBE LOWERS
LAW WITH MENTIONED. IN THE
STATE OF THE STATE'S ARE. THEN
THAT BASED A LONG TIME AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS. WITH HIS AGENDA
ABNAKI THAT'S HIS FOCUS AND
IT'S- REALLY EXCITING TO ME
THAT. THE GOVERNOR WOULD WANT
TO GO INTO THIS AREA AND
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP SO HOW HOW
ARE YOU MISS JOHNSON HOW ARE
YOU COORDINATING. THE GOVERNOR
HOUSE SOCIAL SERVICES- YOU KNOW
OF RAMPING UP. MAYBE A LITTLE
MORE BECAUSE ICE. TOO MANY
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE
AND I DON'T SEE THEM MENTIONED
YOUR FIVE PROGRAMS AND I SEE
THAT THIS IS MAYBE YOU WERE
REALLY NEED TO. BUT EMPHASIS. A
COUPLE THINGS I'D SAY ONE IS
THAT- OUR PART WE HAVE ASH
PARTNERSHIPS HERE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- AND I WOULD SAY THE-
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
RIGHT THOSE ARE THE TWO PLACES
WHERE THOSE. FUNDS ARE ARE
SUPPORTED. OUR IN RESPONSE I
THINK PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS ALSO A THINKING
THROUGH AT THE MEDI CAL
HEALTHIER CAL. ARE THAT OR THE
CAL A MAN SHE DIDN'T THAT'S
LOOKING TO TRANSFORM THE
STATE'S MEDICAL SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE AT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IT'S
REALLY RUN THE CHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT. THE IDEA IN THE
POST FOR THEM THE AIM PROPOSAL
IN THE IN LIEU OF SERVICES THAT
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
INCLUDING. ALL SPORTS. AT OUR
FOR SYSTEM IS IN FIND IT IS
PIECE THAT CAN'T BE COVERED
MEDI CAL THE ACTUAL SAID ACT
RENT PAYMENT TO. TO THESE
INITIATIVES ARE BEING PROPOSED
AS A WAY TO BE INTEGRATED
TOGETHER TO SERVE POPULATIONS
AND I THINK WE'LL CONTINUE TO
THINK THAT I THINK ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT I MENTIONED TO
YOU THAT WE ARE- ADMINISTERING
THERE CERTAINLY WOULD BE
PORTIONS OF THE POPULATION THAT
WOULD BE SUPPORTING MENTAL
HEALTH CONNECTION MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR CERTAINLY WE HAVE.
A DEDICATED DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE
IN OUR CAL WORKS PROGRAM- THAT
IS JUST FOR CONNECTIONS MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE. USE AND
SO FORTH SO IT'S REALLY AROUND
HOW WE ARE IN. HEALTH ARRAY OF
PACKAGE BETWEEN THE MEDI CAL
SERVICES IN IN WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO CHANGE IN THAT
SPACE. AND ALSO WHAT WERE AB
PROPOSING IN TERMS OF NEW
DOLLARS THAT SUPPORT THAT
RENTAL SUBSIDY TO BOTH PREVENT
THOSE FROM BECOMING HOMELESS-
BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT THOSE
COMING OFF OF THE STREET. BY
SPIN LESS YEAR. SING MYSELF
BETTERMENT YOUR SHORT IT DIDN'T.
END IN THE NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
THERE. WE DECIDED THAT. MENTAL
INSTITUTIONS REMAINED SO WE-
CLOSE THEM. ON THE ASSUMPTION
THERE WOULD BECOMMUNITY
SERVICES. BUT THAT WERE NEVER
COMMUNITY SERVICES SO. THEY
WENT TO THE STREET THEY WENT TO
THE JAILS AND SO. THE LARGEST
MENTAL INSTITUTION IN MY COUNTY
IS. THE CENTRAL JAIL IN
DOWNTOWN. SANTA ANNA'S SO. WHAT
INITIATIVE ARE WE DOING BECAUSE
WE METS TAPPED. YOU KNOW HALF
OF THE PROGRAM WHAT WERE OUR
COMMUNITY SERVICES TO HELP THE
MENTALLY ILL ON OUR STREETS YOU
KNOW IN THE TENT CITIES WITH
WHAT IS THE GOVERNOR. I ACT I
MET WITH HIM AFTER THE HE MADE
HIS PRESENTATION THAT AFTERNOON
AND I GAVE THEM OUR STUDY ON
LPS. HIS EYES WENT WIDE OPEN
AND IN THIS THE STAFF MEMBER
SAID YOU KNOW WE HAD A CUT HIS
SPEECH BY AN HOUR BECAUSE YOU
WANTED TO JUST GIVE A LECTURE
ON LPS. SO I AM REALLY EXCITED
THAT HE'S FOCUSED ON IT BUT-
WHERE IS THE PROGRAM WHERE THE
IDEAS WERE THE- WORST THE MEAT
FOR THE BONE SO WE CAN. I THINK
ADDRESS THE MOST CRITICAL.
COMPONENT OF OUR OBVIOUS
HOMELESS PROBLEM. THAT THAT
THE- THAT THE CONSTITUENTS ARE
SAYING EVERY DAY WHEN THEY
DRIVE THEIR CARS THROUGH DOWN.
AL ALL ALL MENTION I AM OUR OUR
SISTER AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT TO
ADD A DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITALS ALSO HAS A PILOT
SPECIFIC TO SUPPORTING THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF THOSE WHO ARE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL SO
I. THOUGHT THAT I WOULD DEFER
TO THEM FOR MORE DETAIL ON THAT
PROPOSAL IN INITIATIVE BUT I
THINK. AS CERTAINLY THERE WILL
BE ADDITIONAL EXPLORATION
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
DOLLARS AND YOU HEARD THE
GOVERNOR IN THE STATE STATE AS
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS. A NEEDING
TO ENSURE DOLLARS ARE SPENT IN
PRIORITIZE AND SO I THINK
THAT'S A CONTINUED CONVERSATION
THAT WOULD ONE EXPLORE EXPLORE
THE LEGISLATURE. TO IDENTIFY
HOW WE NEED TO DO EXACTLY WHAT
YOU WHAT YOU'RE IDENTIFYING SO
ARE WE GIVING THE SYSTEM I'M
WITH THE SAY MAYOR STEINBERG
WHO WROTE. PROPS THE THREE TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT TO
SAVE. HIM THAT JUST WHAT'S OF A
WHICH- SCANNER CARES ARE WE DO
THAT IS A LAWYER WITH BE YOUR
TO. OR WOULD THAT BE. THURMOND
IN. WHERE DO WE GO. YEAH I KNOW
I THINK IT WOULD BE A
COMBINATION ADDS ADDS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND- ARE AT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION THOSE ARE THE TWO
EIGHT. SIXTY THREE THAT'S
RIGHT. THE OVERSIGHT AT CURRENT
FOR THAT. FIVE AND A SO I THINK
THROUGH THE TWO ENTITIES.
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE IT
CERTAINLY THE IDEA IS IN ALL OF
THESE EFFORTS IS AROUND
INTEGRATION SO HOW ARE WE
REALLY TAKING. THE ARRAY OF STE
IS THAT BAD BILL TOOK. THE END
ON THE- AT THAT THAT WERE THAT
WERE. AND THAT'S THE CON. HE
WILL HE'S SAID HE'S THE BECAUSE
OUR- FOR HOMELESS I WE WILL
HELP THEM. BUT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND I JUST
WANNA KNOW HOW I CAN HELP.
THANK YOU MISTER JOHNSON. THANK
YOU PERCENT THANK YOU MANAGER.
SENATE JACKSON THANK YOU YES IN
RESPONSE TO THAT THE LPS
CHECKED OF COURSE IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL- REQUIREMENT
SETTING A STANDARD BECAUSE WE
ARE IN TAKING AWAY PEOPLE'S.
BONTA THAT'S WHAT CREEK THAT
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF CONCERNED-
I AM CONFIDENT THAT THAT ISSUE
IS NOW BEING REVIEWED AND
CONSIDERED- BUT IN SOME OF THE-
INVESTIGATION I'VE DONE A PART
OF THE PROBLEM APPARENTLY HIS
IN THAT OR THE PLUS SERVICES A
BILLABLE BOTH A TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THAT INVOLUNTARY AND CAN
SERVE STATE AND WE'RE NOT AT
THAT STATE SO I'M ASSUMING THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT PARTICULAR
WITH PROP SIX MONEY MONEY. BY
THE OF. RESEARCH SO THAT THE
COURT BORDERS EITHER AN
INVOLUNTARY A CONSERVATORSHIP
OR DOES NOT ORDER IT THAT THAT
THAT MAY BE THROUGH VOLUNTARY
PROGRAMS I GLORIA SLOW WHICH I
KNOW CENTER WIENER HAS SOME
KNOWLEDGE OF WE WORK THAT ISSUE
QUITE EXTENSIVELY. AND I KNOW
YOU WELL CENTER MORE LIKE HAVE
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT IT- THAT
WE HAVE NECESSARY SERVICES FOR
THOSE PEOPLE SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO FIND OURSELVES ARGUING
OVER WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
THEY QUALIFIED TO THE UP A SACK
FOR A- FOR INVOLUNTARY INC A
SENSUAL IN THRACIAN. BUT MY- I
IT FOLD ONE IS I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE OUR USE- BOTH OUR
FOSTER YOUTH THE USED TO HAVE-
FOR WHATEVER REASON LEFT HOME
IN OUR COLLEGE USE- WHO ARE
LIVING OUT OF THEIR CARS AND
EATING ROM AND ALL DAY LONG AND
THINGS THAT ARE CLEARLY NOT IN
THEIR BEST HEALTH INTEREST HI
GOOD ACTORS PROBABLY CONFIRM
THAT IT MAYBE. ONCE A WEEK
TWICE WEEK BUT- NEEDING FOOD
PANTRIES IN LIVING OUT OF THEIR
CARS- LIVING HOMESICK. BUT A
AND I KNOW THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THERE'S ARE. A
SPEAKING WITH A STRONGER VOICE
NOW BUT THE VOICE WE DON'T SEEM
TO CARE AS MUCH OF IS THE VOICE
OF SENIORS. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE NUMBER OF
SENIORS WHO HAVE BECOME
HOMELESS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THEIR LIVES AFTER THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE AND I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THAT THAT THIS FIFTY FIVE
SHOULDN'T QUALIFIED AS A SENIOR
THAT MAKES ME VERY NERVOUS BUT-
BUT ASSUMING THAT IT IS. I I'M
WAY OVER THE HILL THEN IF
THAT'S THE CASE BUT IT USING
THAT CORPUS FIFTY FIVE YEARS OF
AGE AND ALL OR- ENTER. IS THAT
A- WE ARE SEEING THE PEOPLE ARE
AT THAT AGE GROUP IN ABOVE
HOMELESS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THEIR LIVES AND NOT BECAUSE OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES BUT BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO GET
OVER THAT TRANSITION IF THEY
LOSE A ROOMMATE OR- BREADWINNER
I KNOW THERE'S SOME PROGRAM.
THIS IS A- A- AN ISSUE THAT HAS
SOME KIND OF RESOLUTION IT'S
BEING USED ELSEWHERE AND I
WONDERED- JUST LISTENING TO NPR
A FEW WEEKS AGO- THE CITY OF
CHICAGO HAS A PROGRAM WHERE
PEOPLE CALL IN AND THEY GO
THROUGH OF. RELATIVELY GENTLE
SCREENING PROCESS AND ARE GIVEN
THE A STIPEND TO HELP THEM GET
THROUGH THE TIME WE'RE
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD BE
AFFECTED AND THAT- THE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. WHEN
AFTER GIVING UP TO A SEVERAL
MONTHS I THINK IS IN SOME
INSTANCES BUT THAT THEY NEVER
HEAR FROM 75% OF THOSE PEOPLE
AGAIN. IN OTHER WORDS IT
HAVEN'T WE STABILIZE THEIR
LIVES ARE ABLE TO PAY THEIR
OWN- HOUSING EXPENSES AND ARE.
NOT ON THE STREETS AND FRANKLY
HAVING MANAGE IN THE WINTER I
WANT TO BE ON THE STREET THERE.
IN THE WITH. END OF THE- RING
IF THERE ARE ANY PRO HE- IF
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. AND THEN WHEN IT
COMES TO PROVIDING- HOME HOMES
FOR SENIORS WHO MAY OTHERWISE
BE PERMANENTLY HOMELESS AND-
CLEARLY AT THE LEAST ABLE AND
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION.
WHAT KIND OF EFFORT IS BEING
MADE TO PROVIDE PROGRAMS ARE
HOMELESS AND- FACILITIES IN
FACT WRAP WITH WRAPAROUND
SERVICES WHAT HAVE YOU. FOR OUR
SENIOR POPULATION TO THE TO
QUESTION BUT THE- ARE REALLY TO
SENIOR ISSUES AND I APPRECIATE
IF YOU COULD SHARE THAT WITH.
HER I'LL START WITH- THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS HOUSING FIND IT HAS. IS
THE IS TO PROVIDE X. THAT THE
RENTS. EXAM THAT YOU FOR
POPULATIONS THE SECOND IS TO
ACTUALLY BUILD AND DEVELOP
ADDITIONAL FORD WILL HOUSING
AND THE THIRD IS. STABILIZING
ABOARD AND CARE OR ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES AND SO
THAT THE PROPOSAL AS A SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR AT
INVESTMENT IN THIS SPACE AND-
THAT'S EXACTLY CONCEPT THAT
AND- YOU KNOW APPROACH REGIONAL
STRAIGHT. WOULD OPPOSE ON THE
ON. OF THE INCIDENT AT I DIDN'T.
BASED ON THEIR EXISTING NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS AND GAP ANALYSIS
THAT THEY'VE CONDUCTED IN EVEN
ADDITIONAL I RELATED TO THESE
PRIORITIES WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO UTILIZE THOSE SIGNS AND- FOR
pABSOLUTE AGAIN AS I MENTIONED.
YOUTH AT AND TWENTY FIVE OR IN
THE PARTY POPULATION AS OUR
SENIORS WE ARE AT PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE REGIONAL
MINISTERS SYSTEM WE PROPOSED TO
US WHERE THEY WHERE THEY BUT WE
HAVE STATE DID A LOOK. PRIOR IS
WITHIN THAT. I THINK THE OTHER
PIECE OF. TO STABILIZING- THE
ADULT SENIOR CARE FACILITIES IS
REALLY AT AND TO YOUR POINT
SENATOR NEEDING TO HAVE A
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES AT FOUR.
OF OUR SENIORS AS THE AGENTS OR
WHETHER WE CAN SUPPORT THEM
EIGHTEEN IN PLACE IN THEIR
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT THROUGH OUR
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM OR WHETHER THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL CARE AND SUPPORTS
THREE TWENTY FOUR HOUR AND
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM LIKE OUR
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
ARE OUR RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THAT. THE IDEAS
THAT BECKONED I'M IS THERE AND
SO THE DAY THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
TO STABILIZE WOULD HELP
ACTUALLY CREATE RENTAL
AGREEMENTS TO ENSURE
PARTICULARLY WE- HAD THE- IN
YOUR CENTER EXERCISES.
RECIPIENTS THAT HAVE SINCE THE-
IN THOSE CARE SET. IT IS. THIS
SOMETHING THAT SAYS BEING
ADVOCATED. ON BEHALF OF SENIORS
AGAIN WE'VE GOT OUR STUDENTS
THEY'VE GOT GREAT ADVOCACY WITH
OUR- UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS AND
WHAT HAVE YOU- BUT SENIORS TEND
TO BE- YOU KNOW THEY THEY VOTE.
SO THAT'S A VOICE- AND IN GREAT
NUMBERS BUT- IS FOR. WHO TO
LOOK WHO WHO IS GOING TO BE
HELD ACCOUNT. TO MAKE SURE THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW. AND
WHERE. OUR PURSUIT HERE. THAT
WE ACTUALLY HOLD OUR STATE
AGENCIES THAT ARE DOING A LOT
OF THE- YOU KNOW CREATING A
HOUSING AND SO FORTH ARE ALSO.
WORKING TOWARDS THAT COMMITMENT
TO WHO IS GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE WHO IS RESPONSIBLE.
YES THE MAYBE TAKING IT UP A
LITTLE BIT AND THEN GETTING
MORE SPECIFIC TO THE QUESTION
OR OTHER THINGS THAT WERE WERE
WORKING WITH PERFECTLY ON THE
HOUSE I WAS LOOKING AT AND A
HALF HALF FUNDING APPLICATIONS
IS ON WHAT THE COMMUNITY IS SET
IN THEIR GOALS TO BE AND IS THE
COMMUNITY SEE. THEIR NAME WHERE
IS. YOU SEE IT. A GAS AND HELP.
UNDERSTOOD UNDERSTAND IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT AND
WHERE THEY BELIEVE THE FUNDING
SHOULD BE TARGETED BECAUSE I
WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE A VERY
BIG STATE AND IN SOME IN SOME
OF THIS THERE IS MUCH HIGHER UP
MERCY'S SOME PART OF THE STATE
THERE'S A MUCH HIGHER PRICE%
FIRST HOMELESSNESS. TRYING READ
THE FINE LADIES PLEASE CAN.
NEEDS WHERE THAT UP HOLDING
THEM A- IS. DOES YOUR GAP
ANALYSIS MAKES SENSE DOES YOUR
DOES THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT OF
WHERE YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR
FUNDING FIT WITH WHAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED AS WHERE YOU HAVE
GUESTS AND THEY'RE DOING A
LITTLE BIT AT COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY GAPS ANALYSIS I THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. AND TRYING
TO HELP THEM THIS SORT OF GOES
AND WHERE THE HOME IS EIGHT AND
CONSISTS WILL BE VERY HELPFUL
AS ME IS LOOK AT THEIR OWN DATA
AND SEE WHAT. WHERE THINGS ARE
HEADING DOWN HOW THEY STOP THAT
COME. I'M TRYING TO THINK THAT.
BUT THAT SUMMIT IN ALL. JUST
ISN'T THERE. REALLY GOOD DAY.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HELPING
THEM ON WHETHER SEEMS THEN
SHIFT FUNDING AFTER A I WOULD
THEY WERE TRYING TO TAKE UP A
BIT OF A BROADER APPROACH OF.
COMMITTEES ARE ABLE TO SEE WHAT
WEATHER BUT THERE ARE AND THEN
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO
MEETING THOSE NEEDS. SO JUST
WANT TO ADD. GIVE A LITTLE
FRIENDLY REMINDER THAT WE ARE
MAKING SURE THAT. THAT DIRECTOR
HERE DOCTOR JOHNSON MAKES IT IN
TIME FOR HER HEARING- WITH THAT
SAID WE HAVE TWO MORE SPEAKERS
THOSE. PAN AND I. SENATOR THERE
AFTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. COUPLE FOR A FEW
QUESTIONS HERE NAY NO WILL
DELVE MORE INTO SPECIFICS SO
WHEN- YOU PRESENT FOR THE
RESPECTIVE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES- BUT THIS. ONE ONE
QUESTION IS LIKE SO WE HAVE. IN
THE BACKGROUND THE OF FIVE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OVERSEEN BY I THINK- FARMER SO
SERVICES RELATED TO.
HOMELESSNESS I KNOW THAT- BUT
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARD ABOUT- WITH
AGING ABOUT HOME SAFE AT THE
HAVE WE DONE A GAP ANALYSIS
ABOUT OKAY THESE FIVE. BETWEEN
TAX SO FOR THEM TALK ABOUT
SENIOR. APPLIES TO PEOPLE
SUFFERING ABUSE OR OTHER TYPES
OF THINGS BUT I DON'T KNOW IT'S
LIKE HAVING A SPOUSE DIED NOW
HE SUDDENLY YOUR LOSS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF INCOME FALLS UNDER
THAT AND THEN THAT. HELPS RAISE
FUNDS THINKING LIKE. WHERE
THERE'S GAS. I THINK RELATES
SPECIAL TO THE OTHER AND EIGHT
SPECTRUM TERMS TO ITEM ON OF
FACTLY FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COME MEET WITH ME AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT THEIR OWN THE
STUDENT. AND NEARLY SAID WELL
CAN THERE BE A SONG AND I SAID
OH BY THE WAY WHAT'S THE
PRESENCE OF SOCIAL SERVICES ON
CAMPUS. THE WHAT. WENT WELL
BECAUSE I MEAN WITH HAVE.
PROGRAMS FOR HOMELESSNESS
STRAIGHT AND WHAT THEIR DUTY TO
CREATE A SEPARATE POOL FOR THE
STUDENTS OR DO WE MAKE. THE
SERVICE AVAILABLE WHERE THE-
STUDENTS ACTUALLY FAR AND THAT
DILUTES SLICE OF THE POPULATION
SO CAN YOU. CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THIS GREAT. CAN ACCESS THE- NOT
WHERE THE- PROGRAMS. ARE WHERE
THEY'RE AT SO THEY HAVE TO GO
FIND THEM. SO TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION SENATOR RELATED TO
PROJECTIONS I THINK- OTHER
PIECE THAT WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT INTO COMMITTEES IS
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING EFFORT
AND THAT IS WHERE WE'RE HEARING
FROM. MANY SENIORS IN MANY
OTHER COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
NEW WELL OKAY YEAH I GOT I GOT
THAT RIGHT I WAS I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT. WE'RE LOOKING AT
JACK'S DIFFERENT OF MANY. TYPE
AND I THINK THAT KIND OF THE
THAT WE'VE BEEN TAKING TO DATE
HAS BEEN ALLOWING EITHER THE
COUNTY OR THEIR OR THEY'RE AND
CASE THAT HERE WE'RE GONNA BE
ASKING THE REGION TO IDENTIFY
WITH THEIR GAPS WHETHER YES
ENTERS AN OVERALL NEED AT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE USED FOR MANY TYPES OF. YEAH
AND. PROGRAMS FOOD TO PEOPLE
WHO DON'T FIT IN ANY OF THOSE
FIVE TO HALF OF THIS PRODUCT IS
WE'VE CREATED. FIVE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS. RATE AND ARE WE
LOOKING AT WELL. WHICH
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH DIDN'T FIT
IN NOW THE FIVE THEY HAVE LIKE
FIVE CIRCLE SOME MAY OVERLAP
SOME MAY NOT AND FOUR LEVELS IN
BETWEEN. YES SOMEWHERE. IN
BETWEEN I THINK THAT IS WHAT
DAY THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
AND KEEP AND THE SIX ARE FIFTY
MILLION SHARES IN HALF- WHICH
ARE BROUGHT PROGRAMS. THAT CAN
BE USED IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
FOR MANY DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
I THINK THAT THE UNIQUE PIECE
AND I SPEAK FOR CAN BUT THE-
EIGHT PIECE FOR C. S. OF
PROGRAMS IS THAT THEY'RE- IN.
BUT IT'S POPULATION. NINE TEST.
WORK KEEP IN THE HOT FIVE. IS
REALLY INTO. BE FOR THE FOR
COMMITTEE WHERE. THE THESE SORT
OF INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS ARE ARE
NOT ADDRESSING THE REST OF THE
POPULATION TO SIMILAR TO WHAT.
HIDE IS GIVING OUT TO CONTINUE.
THROUGH SG AND OTHER SORT OF
HAD FUNDING I THINK THOSE ARE
WHERE THEY'RE- BE USE THAT FOR
ANY POPULATION THAT EXPERIENCE.
HOMELESSNESS AND BEING ABLE TO
BE USED AS A- NEED THEM. WHERE
THEY IT AND WHICH CASE. THAT
LEAVES. QUESTION BE SURE TO.
PEOPLE THE FIRE PROGRAM. THAT
FROM. EIGHT OUR OUR- WHERE THEY
RESIDE USING A PLACE TO RESIDE
BUT WHERE THEY AT LEAST SEND A
TIE I THERE'S YOU KNOW IT.
AFTER AND REESE WE WANT TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THIS CONNECTS ARE
MADE HOW IN. ARE ENGAGING
ACCOUNT IN PER THE SEARCH
BERRIES ACROSS STATE INCOME OF
THE RESTORE AVAILABLE TO DO
THAT AT REACH I WILL SAY
SPECIFIC. ENTER FOOD AND CAL
STAR FOCUS OF OURS AND LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT THE STUDENT
HUNGRY SHE'S NOT A BAD STICKLE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
DEVELOPING SOME PRIORITIES AND
THAT AT THAT THAT WILL BE
FORTHCOMING BUT- ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE YOUR
KEEP. YOUR CONNECT THE SERVICE
AND MAKE THE OUT POSTED TO SO
WE START THAT TO ENTER. WHAT
CAN. FOR SORT. I THINK THAT
DOUBLE WE WANT IS FOR OUT HOW.
THE ELIGIBILITY WORKERS TO THE
FEEL NOT JUST SITTING ONE OFF
AND OUT AND SO THAT THEY CAN
HELP THE YOUR THE EVERYONE HAVE
TO FIND A WAY AND THEY ACTUALLY
CAN PROVIDE THE BROAD ARRAY OF
SOCIAL SERVICE. NOT JUST LIKE A
WELL ON JUST HOW FRESH SO.
PACKED TO THE US FIND SOMEONE
ELSE IN THE OFFICE FOR THE NEXT
THING RIGHT AND THEN THE OTHER.
QUESTION I HAD WAS. TO TALK
ABOUT. AND I'M SURE WE'LL DELVE
INTO MUCH MORE DETAIL LATER
TERMS OF THE SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION THAT DIDN'T PROPOSED
AND IT'S GOING TO REGIONAL
MINISTERS I KNOW THERE'S SOME
BACK AND FORTH ABOUT THAT. BUT
I GUESS ONE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS IS THAT. HOWEVER WHOEVER
DOES IT TO ME YES SOMEONE. HOW
MUCH TIME YOU SPEND ON QUOTE
PLANNING IN IDENTIFYING WHAT
THE PRIORITIES ARE FOR EACH
REGION AND HOW MUCH AND
WONDERING IF I HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING. RIGHT SO A CELL AT A
REAL WE WANT TO SPEND MONEY ON
WISELY SO WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT THIS BUT I'M ALSO
CONCERNED. WE'RE AT. DOING A
LOT OF PLANNING PLANET. THE ARE
SAYING WHEN WE GOT TO SOMETHING.
PROBLEMS CAN WE CAN YOU SPEAK
TO PRESS A LITTLE BIT THAT TIME
LINE THEIR MUSIC REGIONAL
MINISTERS ARE THEY EXPECTED TO
NOW DO A PLANNING DOCUMENT
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE SIX. NINE
MONTHS A YEAR THAT THAT OR THE
MONEY. OUT OF BLOOD. HE PLAN IS
OUT. TO ADDRESS THEIR- OF ISSUE
SO WE ARE PROPOSING TO ACTUALLY
RELEASE THE REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS OUT TO REGIONAL
MINISTRY THERE'S WITHIN THE
COMING MONTHS COMING WEEKS EVEN
AT THIS POINT. I GIVING AT SOME
TIME FOR RESPONSE I MEAN THE
IDEA IS THAT THESE THIS IS
BUILDING UPON EXISTING PLANETS
HAVE AS A CLASS THAT. HEARD
REALLY WANTING THAT LEVERAGE
POINT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
PLANNING EFFORTS TO THE KURDS
HOW WE ARE PROPOSED. HE WOULD
HAVE AS THE ENTIRE PROCESS WITH
A REVIEW OF THOSE PROPOSALS. I
HAD DONE IN TIME SO THAT
ANSWERS THE BUDGET WAS ENACTED
THIS SUMMER WE COULD RELEASE
DOLLARS. WHY AND MY BE BLOOM
DELTA A NASCENT DISCUSS OF
ABOUT EXACTLY IS IN APPROPRIATE
ENTITY TO. WHO HAS INFORMATION
ABOUT THE- WHAT'S THE BEST WAY
TOO MANY MISTAKES STAFF AND
MOST MAKE EFFECTIVE USE THOSE
FUNDS SO ARTS OKAY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR BAIT. THANK YOU I KNOW
TIME IS ON PRESSING AND I'M
GOING TO SEE. SOMEONE AT THAT
TABLE AT ANOTHER TABLE AND YOU
KNOW ABOUT AN HOUR MAKE VERY
BRIEF- ACTUALLY MORE OF A STATE
AND- LEAD TO OUR CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE. ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDARDS- YOU MENTIONED THAT
THAT THE HOUSING FIRST PROGRAM
STARTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND
WE'RE AT TWENTY TWENTY. AND WE
HAVE NOT GOTTEN HE NEED IT
OTHER THAN IT'S GROWING THE
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM IS
GROWING. AND I THINK WE NEED
POUNDS SOME ACCOUNTING LYDIA IS
GROWING WHY ARE HOUSING FIRST.
HASN'T DOWN THE RIGHT MAYBE WE
CAN DO THAT IS. FUTURE HERE
BECAUSE YOU ARE SIT STANDARDS
ACCOUNT ANY STANDARDS PERFECT
MATCH AS YOU. TO BE. YEAH NOT
ANYTHING BACK EXCEPT FOR MARK.
IT'S GETTING THERE SOME YOU
DOING ABOUT IT SO BECAUSE IS
SHORT JUST GOING TO ASK ARE YOU
TO A FULL ON THAT AND MAYBE
THAT IN TO US INTO INC I THINK
OUR OUR CITIZENS OUR STATE YOU
AND SAW EVERYONE NEEDS TO KNOW
THAT WE ARE MAKING A- IN THIS
PROBLEM AND I WILL SHARE ALLOW.
I WILL WHAT BERMAN. YEAH BEING
AND AT THAT LOS WE DO WE TOOK
THE A TO THIS PRO OUT AND PUT
IT WITH SSI WE HAD A TO THE
DISABLED THE TRACK THOSE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE HAD GO
PUBLISHED ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE. DENOMINATOR THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM. TODAY SO
MAYBE IT WOULD BE A GOOD THING
TO BRING SOME OF THAT BACK INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WE HAVE CASE WORKERS.
DIRECTLY A FINE TO THOSE
PROBLEM AREAS AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND SUFFERING CLUE
OUR STUDENTS ARE YOU POPULATION
A NUMBER OF THOSE COMING AND
WHEN I WAS A SOCIAL BECAUSE
THINK ABOUT IT THE- TO THE- OF
CHOICE THE- FAMILY. DELIC SO
THOSE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
THE BILL WOULD BE ON TO ALL OF
THE- SECOND. WITH ONE TIME ALL
THE MANY YOU. BUT FACT OF THEM
ANY IS THE MINIMUS FROM WE-
THANK YOU. SO IN IN THE
INTEREST TIME I WILL WHOLE MY
QUESTION FOR THE SPA BUT I'VE
WANTED YOU BYE FOR BEING A PART
OF THIS HEARING TODAY AND I
WILL GO AND GIVE THE GAL
COLLEAGUES. GRAY I'VE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR- SO WHEN
THE CAR NEXT PANEL WHICH IS
THAT YOU ONE PERSON. SO A LOT
OF PRESSURE- THIS- PANEL IS
LOOKING AT HOW OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES HAVE. SUCCESS HE
ADDRESSED HOMES- AND OUR
WITNESSES CYNTHIA. DROUGHT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE UCSF
BUT BENNY HOME OPPOSE AND
HOUSING INITIATIVES SO WELCOME-
TO THE US AND OUR JOINT HEARING
AND OTHER FLOOR IS YOURS NO
WILL TAKE SOME ACTIONS. WHEN I
PUT THE CLOTHES LITTLE TO CLOSE.
TO PERFECT GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU FOR WELCOMING HERE AT MY
NAME ISN'T AN AGENDA OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE UCSF
BENIOFF HOMES AND HOUSING
INITIATIVE IT'S A NEW RESEARCH
AND POLICY CENTER AT UCSF. THE
COMMITTEES HERE FOR INVITING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT. WHICH ARE THE MOST
URGENT. IS WE HAVE OF UCSF I'M
REALLY HONORED TO BE HERE WITH
YOU. THE WHAT IS ACTUALLY
WORKING TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS
AND WHAT STRATEGIES CALIFORNIA
SHOULD DOUBLE DOWN ON- WHILE
THE UCSF INITIATIVE IS NEW I
HAVE WORKED IN THIS FIELD FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS- MOST
RECENTLY AT THE NATIONAL LINES
TEN HOMELESSNESS AND AS A
FIELD. WE DO KNOW A LOT ABOUT
WHAT WORKS- AND THAT'S
HAPPENING OUTSIDE. OF
CALIFORNIA ANOTHER COUNTRIES
BUT REALLY IT'S THERE'S PLENTY
OF THINGS THAT ARE WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M GONNA SPEND
SOMETIME HIGHLIGHTING THAT AS
WELL. IN THE NATION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY STATES HAD
INCREASES IN HOMELESSNESS BUT
ABOUT THIRTY STATES SHOWED YEAR
OVER YEAR DECREASES. AND ALMOST
AS AN ALMOST EVERY
SUBPOPULATION FAMILIES VETERANS
PEOPLE ARE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
YOUTH- AND IN VERY EXPENSIVE
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY SO NOT
JUST- PLACES THAT ARE NOT
COMPARABLE. TO US TO CALIFORNIA
PLACES LIKE DC. AND OUTSIDE OF
BRIDE REALLY EXPENSIVE PARTS OF
VIRGINIA. AND IT'S ABOUT HAVING
THE POLITICAL WILL THAT'S
WHAT'S REALLY WORKING THE
ONGOING. SIZEABLE THANKS FOR A
MEDIA. CENTER TALK ABOUT JOSH.
I'M RESPONSE THE EVIDENCE BASED
EMERGENCY AND LONG TERM
PERMANENT HOUSING. IF FUND
INTERMENT VISITED BUT WORK
THAT'S REALLY MORTENSEN JUST
LET GOOD ON TOP OF BAD. I'M
REALLY OUT. CREATING ACCOUNT
IN BETWEEN AT AND REALLY
PERFORMANCE OUTCOME MEASURES
THAT YOU'RE REALLY TRACKING AND
LOOKING AT WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
STARTING TO DO HERE AND SEVERAL
PROGRAMS. AND CREATE EARLY
ACCESS TO AND COORDINATION
BETWEEN SYSTEMS OF CARE SO IT
CAN'T JUST PHAM HOMELESS SYSTEM
AS WE HAVE I THINK TALKED ABOUT
TODAY. AND REALLY THE DOESN'T
ALLOW. OF PROVIDERS TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN AT SCALE- TO MATCH THE
GROWING. IN A LOT FUNDING INTO
UNITIES WAS THAT A LOT THE
VETERANS INITIATIVE TO END
VETERAN HOMELESSNESS PRINT OUT
OF FUNDING COMMUNITIES IS OFTEN
NOT ENOUGH IT'S COORDINATION
BETWEEN SYSTEMS. IT'S BUILDING
THE CAPACITY TO DO IT IT'S
POLITICAL WELL THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT REALLY- BECAUSE
SIGNIFICANT DECREASES. YES THE
DESPITE THE TROUBLING TREND
LINES RECENTLY GOING THE WRONG
DIRECTION WITH HOMES IS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW A GREAT
DEAL ABOUT HOW TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
EMPLOYING MANY OF. THEIR
WORKING ELSE. AND IT'S A- STATE
HERE WILL ALSO. THE NATION IT.
DURATION PROVED TO BE. AND VERY
EXPENSIVE PARTS OF THIS. ONLY A
MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE. HARD WORK
AND STRATEGIC THINKING THAT HAS
BEEN GOING ON HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND IN MANY LOOK.
US REALLY WE SEE A BABY
MOVEMENT THE LAST FEW YEARS. SO
WE WANNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- THE THINGS THAT THE
STATE'S EFFORTS AND MANY
COMMUTERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
LEADING THE COUNTRY IN VARIOUS
INNOVATIONS INTERVENTIONS ARE
SUCH AS MAKING HOUSE. FIRST
STATUTORY CRIME FOR MANY
PROGRAMS THAT HAS MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE. OF INFLEXIBLE
HOUSING SUBSIDY POOLS IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE AND
SORT. ABOUT USING THE SEVEN
MILLION TO DO OF THAT I CAN
TALK TO. ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT
WHOLE PERSON CARE TO BRING IN
THE SYSTEMS OF CARE TOGETHER-
AND USING SOCIAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS LIKE HOW IT WORKS IN
THE ONE AND HOME SAFE THE ONES
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT. PROVIDING
PEOPLE ARE COMING THAT'S RIGHT
SIDES. HALL OF. IT BEING A
ALREADY INCOMES. AND SERVICES
TO HOUSE STEAKHOUSE. MORE WE
INCREASES. AS THAT MAKE.
FIFTEEN PEOPLE SO NOT TO SERVE
AN EMERGENCY ROOM EMERGENCY
RESPONSE BUT LINKING HOMELESS
TO HOUSING- THE MORE WE CAN
MEET YOUR HOMES IS. WHERE IF.
THIS HOUSE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THE STATE- AND WE THANK THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR A REAL
INVESTMENT COMMITTEE BEHIND
THIS. AS I AM AND NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN HOMES AND CAL HAS.
FROM HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND ON
FIFTY THAT PAST DECADE I AT ON
THE BEACH POURTANT CETTE 2% ARE
ON FOSTER. CORD UNACCEPTABLE I
AND WHAT IT IS A SEEMINGLY OF
SEVEN TO THE PUBLIC IN A- CA
PEOPLE TO SAY WILL DON'T KNOW
WRONG BUT WE'RE SEEING. COMPORT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT WHAT
WE SEE IS NOT REALLY A LINE
WHAT WE WILL WE KNOW AND SO THE
VISIBILITY OF THE ISSUE ALSO
CAUSES A LOT OF TENSION- BUT
HOWEVER EVEN WITH THESE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT DECREASES IN FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS AND FEDERAL
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S THANKS
TO INVESTMENT IN PROVING
HOUSING FIRST PROGRAMS LIKE
RAPIDLY HOUSING AND PERMITS
PART OF HOUSING THAT HAVE COME
THROUGH CAL WORKS. AND OTHER
AND THE AND THE VA AND OTHER-
FUNDING PROGRAMS FEDERAL AND
STATE AND LOCAL THAT ARE BEING
ASKED TO DELIVER OUTCOMES AND
REALLY USE EVIDENCE.
INTERVENTIONS REALLY DECREASED-%
HOME ASSISTANCE CERTAIN
POPULATIONS HERE AND DECREASED
OVERALL SYSTEM COMMUNITIES ARE
KIND. AT. WE'RE INVESTING WHAT
WE KNOW WORKS. HOUSING FIRST.
NOT JUST PUTTING HER PART OF
HOUSE WHICH IS NEED BUT IT'S A
VERY INTENSIVE AND- IS NEEDED
FOR I'VE- THE SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE POPULATION- AND
EXPANDING HEALTH HOUSING IN
INCOME SUPPORTS. NONE OF THIS I
THINK IS- IS NEW BUT HAVING
HOMELESS SYSTEM LEADERS AND
PROVIDERS THAT ARE. SMARTLY
NAVIGATING THE ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO MARKET THAT YOU
HAVE HERE- YES HOUSING FIRST IS
THAT IS A MARKET BASED SOLUTION
AND SO WE HAVE PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE AND THAT ARE FIGURING
OUT HOW TO NAVIGATE THAT
MARKET. THAT IS CURRENTLY
EXISTING AND HOW THOUSAND OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE EVERY
DAY. I THAT'S- FOR POLICY
DECISIONS AT LOCAL AND LEVEL.
IN EVIDENCE BASED BRANCHES BUT
REALLY ALSO WORKING AT. ACROSS
I IS AND- SO. THE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
RE MAKING DENSE ARE THE PAY
THAT ARE A TO WORK OUTSIDE IS
VERY SO. FIND SYSTEM OTHER
COMMUNITIES SEVEN HISTORY
PLEASE UP. AND IT'S JUST A FEW
COMMITTEES IS FOR COMMUNITY
SEVEN RECOGNIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AS ENDING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS FUNCTIONALLY AND
THREE STATES AND SEVENTY EIGHT
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE ENDED
VETERAN HOMELESSNESS AGAIN
REALLY PIECING THE SAME TYPES
INTERPLAY I IN- EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS- BETTER SORT OF
THINKING SHORT TERM TREE ARE
STRATEGIES AS WELL AS LONG I'M
HOUSING STRATEGIES. I WOULD
REVISIT WHY PEOPLE. MUST
BECAUSE THIS IS. AN IMPORTANT.
BY THE THINGS IMPORTANT DATA TO
INFORM THE- WE HAVE. WELL THERE
PEOPLE I'M HOME IF YOU WAS THIS
LAW THERE HOUSING DUE TO
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS NO THAT
THROUGH A OF THE DATA SO WYRM
PEOPLE FALL TO HOMES AND CAL
MORE SO THAN OTHER STAY.
ANSWERS BUT OBVIOUS BECAUSE
EVERY DAY MORE IN PEOPLE CANNOT
AFFORD HOW AND HOME SYSTEM CAN
HOUSE AT THE SAME RATE THAT
PEOPLE ARE BECOMING HOMELESS
AND THAT'S WHY THE NUMBERS ARE
GOING UP HERE AT THE CAUSES OF
HOMELESS YES NOT ALL TO. US
THIS PRICES CAUSED BY GATES OF
IT IS LOCALS FOR WHICH IS IN A
HOUSING SEVERE BRADFORD
INSTITUTIONALIZE THAT INSTEAD
SYSTEM RACISM THE ME AND HOMES
AS AS THE IN MISMATCH COST
HOUSING PEOPLE. RENTS ARE
RISING. PUTTING WHENEVER WE CAN
THE REPORT INJURY BEST SAID THE
REAL ESTATE PRICES OF RESIDENTS
TIMES FOR THAN HOW AND- AT MORE
THAN HALF. OF STATE'S HOUSE HOW
OF THE STATE JUST ACROSS THE
STATE AFFORD THE HOUSE THE COST
OF HOUSING. TO THE PAYING MORE
THAN THIRTY PER OF THEIR IN
MANY OVER FIFTY THE 7% THESE
RICH DIMENSION TO THIS THE CHOI
CENTER FOR HOUSING SO AT HEART
POINTS THAT NATIONALLY BLACK
PRINTER. AT AND HAVE HIGHEST
RUN BURDEN IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WITH 55% OF PEOPLE PAY MORE
THAN 30% OF THEIR INCOME FOR
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA BLACK
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE INCOMES ARE
FAR OF REPRESENTED AS WE HEARD
EARLIER. MAKING UP ONLY 7%
STAYS IN OUR POPULATION 229% OF
THE STATE'S HOMES POPULATION.
OUR RESEARCH PAPER VERY TO
SHALL AT UCSF ON THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DISCRIMINATION
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
EXPOSURE TO VIOLENCE PREMATURE.
WITH A FAMILY OF ALL FACTORS
STRUCTURE RACES THAT IF.
PEOPLE'S TO THE COW AND IT'S A
ALSO THE MOST ARE WORKING
BEFORE THE BECAME HOME. BOB AND
MANY ARE WORKING WHILE THEY ARE
HOMELESS THE CALIFORNIA POLICY
LET FOUND THAT A MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE 74% OF PEOPLE LOS
ANGELES. WHO WROTE TO RECEIVE
HOME SERVICES BETWEEN TWENTY
TEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN HAD
WORKED IN CALIFORNIA. AND
SOMEONE THAT THANK HAD. MEANT
THE THIS ABOUT PEOPLE FALLING
TO HOME IS FOR THE FIRST TIME
OVER AGE OF FIFTY AND AS- THE
FOR FIRST TIME AND MANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE FELL IN BECAUSE OF
HEALTH OR- A- THAT HAD ALWAYS
BEEN TASK. LABOR MARKET BUT NOW
ARE JUST ABLE TO THEIR HOUSING
FOR PRESS REASONS. ADDITIONAL
CALLS FACTORS RB IN FOR.
PROBLEMS AND DIFFICULTY WRITTEN
FOR THEM SO OF COURSE HOW
PROBLEMS ARE THE BECAUSE
NUMBERS. BUT THE LESS SAFETY
THE LESS A SAFE NET A PERSON
HAS THE MORE THESE IN. BONE OF
THE REALLY CONTRIBUTE TO
HOMELESSNESS. THE BILL PLAY IN
THE WORLD RATES OF HOMELESS.
HAVE A BIGGER AND BROADER
SAFETY AS MANY P. STRUCK TO
MAKE. THERE'S ABLE. TO THAT.
NOT WAITING TO FALL INTO. YOUR
LOOK AT HOW YOU'RE MONEY. TO
RENT MAYBE IT'S ONE TIME IS A-
MAYBE IT'S ONGOING. BUT THE
ASSISTANCE IS THERE. ON THE
SITUATION IS MORE DIE HERE BY
THE CALL OF LIVING. LACK OF
EXTREMELY LOAN HOUSING. AND THE
LACK OF US THAT OVER A REAL
SORT OF A ROBUST SAFETY NET
AND- I ALWAYS LIKE TO SORT OF
REMEMBER THAT PRIOR TO THE
EIGHTIES WE DIDN'T HAVE. SPUR
HOME AS WE HAD. WE DID HAVE
LOWER. DORIS WE HAD OF. THING
IN HAD NO YET STARTED TO. SHRUG
THE SAY THAT. OUGHT TO AND WE
BUILDING. AND REALLY WHERE THE
X. OF HOW HAPPEN. SO HOME
HAPPENED. THOUGH THE DEATH
PICTURES DIRE THE ARE. NOW IS
SIX. AS WEAK CHANGE THE COURSE
OF THE STATE. FREE WITH THE
RIGHT POLICIES SYSTEM AND
COURTNEY VISION ACROSS EACH. WE
UNDO THESE A FAX BUT IT DOES
TAKE A LONG TERM ANSWER
POLITICAL COMMITMENT. ALWAYS OF
SYSTEMS AND HOW POWER IS AN ON
GOING FUNDING AND LOOKING NOW
AT WE'RE DOING ABOUT HOME AS
WELL IS WORKING WHAT ISN'T. WE
NEED TO SHOW TERM FOR. AT A
LONG TERM HOUSING STRATEGY AS
WE HAVE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT
TODAY WE KNOW THAT AN EFFECTIVE
RESPONSE INCLUDES THESE
COMPONENTS THAT USE A HOUSING.
APPROACH AND ARE PART OF A
COORDINATED SYSTEMIC VISION AND
RESPONSE RATHER THAN A
COLLECTION OF SILENT FUNDING-
AND WE SEE A LOT OF THESE CONS
REFLECTED IN THE PARTY'S OF THE
NEW SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. SO THE THREE PARTS WE
REALLY TALK ABOUT ME WE ARE AN
EMERGENCY CRISIS RESPONSE
ADEQUATE PEOPLE ABOUT TO FALL
INTO ALMOST NYSSA TRYING TO
FOR. THAT WE TO GET THESE
PEOPLE THEY ARE WE HAVE TO GET
TO FOLKS FASTER WE CAN'T AT
STREET FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE ABOUT
TO FALL NECKLACES AND FOR
PEOPLE WERE LIVING ON THE
STREET. AND SOMETIMES YES IT'S
JUST A FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
KEEP PEOPLE OFF THE STREET FOR
KEEP GETS PEOPLE RIGHT BACK IN
THE HOUSING- AND SO IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE LAW VERY INTENSIVE
INTERVENTIONS- WE NEED ADEQUATE
AND REFLECT. ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND- TO GET PEOPLE HOUSE
THREE HOUSES QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IN THE CURRENT HOUSING
MARKETS NAVIGATING THAT CURRENT
HOUSING MARKET. DATE HOUSE
AGAIN THIS CAN RANGE FROM WHITE
LET'S DISTANCE. MORE INTENSIVE
IN A LIKE PROM PART OF HOUSING
AND ALL HELPING AS- CARE
FACILITIES FOR. OR THOSE OF
SUCH THIS. MAYBE EVEN FOR. OF
COURSE MANY SERIOUS FIVE
EXTREME ON HOUSING AND REAL
HOUSING AT ALL FOR WITH THE
MORE RESEARCH PUSHING ON THE
RUN MARKET THE MORE AT THE LESS
AVAILABLE THERE FOR PEOPLE IN
THE BY. OTHERS COMMUNITY OF
CALIFORNIA I'M YOU KNOW WE'RE
HOUSING FOR JUST YOU A
DIFFICULT HOUSING WORSE THAT
HAPPEN YOU AND PLACES ALSO WHO
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE LAW
TWO YEARS THERE'S MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE FOR IN HOUSING BUT HOW
FIRST IS WORKING WE JUST OF
HAPPENS UP AND GET PEOPLE. I
WANTED TO SPEAK HOUSE FIRST IS
NOT ONLY THIS SORT OF NUMBER OF.
THE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
PROMISE IN ON RECENT. BUT
CHARACTERIZES HOUSING. AND THAT
IS NOT AND THEN INCREASE ON
CHILDREN. THOSE HAVE TO BE
AVAILABLE IN THOSE HAVE TO BE
ACCESSIBLE BUT THOSE ARE PART
OF THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL-
NEWER STRATEGIES THAT ARE
SHOWING GREAT PROMISE ELSEWHERE
ARE. VERY COST EFFECTIVE ARE
STARTING TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS SO WE CALL THEM
DIVERSION HERE PROBLEM SOLVING
IN CALIFORNIA. IN TRYING TO GET
TO PEOPLE BEFORE THEY FALL IN
THIS ORDER. WORK WITH NEWLY
HOMELESS PEOPLE TO GET THEM OUT
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- AND IN
THE SHORT RUN WE SHOULD KEEP
TRYING TO IMPROVE THE UNDER
FUNDED EMERGENCY HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. SO THAT
INCLUDES EMERGENCY SHELTER
SWITCHER GENERALLY KIND OF
UNDER FUNDED AND NOT DESIGNED-
TO REALLY HOUSE PEOPLE BUT BY
FUNDING THEM TO HAVE MORE
CAPACITY CAPACITY AND MAKE THEM
PART OF THE HOUSING SYSTEM
RATHER THAN A FINAL DESTINATION
SO WE OFTEN THINK. THERE'S A
BUNCH OF ONE SOLDIER PEOPLE IF
WE JUST BUILD SOME SHELTERS AND
HENCE WE CAN GET THEM OFF THE
STREET BUT WITHOUT ANY HOUSING
AT THE STRATEGY. WE DON'T HAVE
EVERY TEMPORARY BED ATTACHED TO
HOUSING OR SOME HOUSING
RESOURCE- YOU'RE JUST GONNA
SORT OF END UP BUILDING MORE
SHELTERS. PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
FILLING THOSE UP AND IT WILL
SORT OF REALLY- JUST AS A
COMPOUND THE ISSUE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A WAY TO GET. OUT SO YOU
WERE IN.COMMUNITY YES THE
LOCAL TO SHOW IMPACT AND GET
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS BUT FEEL
LIKE. SALT WHILE WE DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT IS OUR OF
HOLDING AT THE CENTER. OF EVERY
THAT HOUSING SOLVE ALMOST AS-
IN A RELEASE THE NOT MATCH.
ENDED UP. I PEOPLE TO PEOPLE
PASSED SPECIAL POOR JOB OF THAT
AS A SAID WITH ON FOR AND WE
HOUSING PEOPLE MUCH MORE AND OF
SO THAT INCLUDES LIKE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES SHALLOW
SUBSIDIES TRYING NEW STRATEGIES
LIKE ADDING RENTAL ASSISTANCE
EXISTING INCOME SUPPORTS LIKE
CAL WORKS HAS DONE THIS CAN BE
DONE FOR PEOPLE EXTREMELY HIGH
RENT BURNS ASSET BY ITSELF- AND
EXPERIMENTING WITH THOSE TIME
THE SHELLS SUBSIDIES SO STOP
THERE AND- TRIP QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- BECAUSE OF
THEIR ANY QUESTIONS YES CENTER
JACKSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION- OF COULD YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU YOU FEEL
THAT WE NEED TO. WORK OUTSIDE
CURRENT FUNDING SOURCES- WHICH
I THINK IS CRITICAL AND TO
CUTTING INTEGRATED FROM PROGRAM
SO LAST ONE PARTICULARLY STRUCK
ME YOU HAVE YOUR- LOW INCOME
FOLKS WHO ARE ALREADY ON CAL
WORKS A PROGRAMS THE FACT WE
HAVE BEEN ADDED- HOUSING
ASSISTANCE TO. TO THEIR YOU
KNOW TO THE QUESTIONERS IF YOU
WILLOR OR THEIR NEED
SETTLEMENTS OR ASSISTANCE IS
KIND OF MIND BOGGLING BUT THAT
BRINGS ME TO THE QUESTION. WE
HAVE A BUREAUCRACY. AND IT
SEEMS TO ME LISTEN TO EVERYONE
IS TALKED OUR DEBRIS ARE THE
BUREAUCRACY AND ITS LIMITATIONS
AND EVERYONE IS IN THEIR SILO
HAS MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
ADDRESS WHAT IS A MUCH MORE
HOLISTIC ISSUE. DO YOU HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW WE COULD-
PERHAPS. CREATE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY OR CHANGE THE-
AFTER OF THESE BUREAUCRACY SO
THAT THEY ARE MORE WE'RE- TO
THE COMPLEX AND SOMETIMES
INTEGRATED ISSUES THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION. YES THERE IS A VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE AND IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE DIFFERENT
LOCALITIES AND AGENCIES BUT THE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY POEM
ON LOS ANGELES WHICH I THINK
PEOPLE PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT THE
REASON IT'S QUITE EFFECTIVE IS
BECAUSE WHILE IT IS RUN THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES THERE. IT REALLY
STREAMLINES DIFFERENT TYPES
FUNDS TAKING FUNDING FROM THE
HOUSING BUT AS FOR THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY FROM JUST IN THE
OFFICE THE VERSION REENTRY FROM.
CARE FROM HELPS. FOR ME AND
IT'SPUTTING. A LOT OF FUNDING
SOURCES TOGETHER INTO ONE POT
AND KIND OF STREAMLINE THE
CONTRACTING TO ONE OR TWO
OPERATORS WHO THEN FIND HOUSING
AND WORK WITH SEVERAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS. BUT BY STREAMLINING
THAT CONTRACTING ELIGIBILITY
PROCESS AND HAVING JUST A FEW
ENTITIES SORT OF REALLY-
CONTROL SORT OF DELIVERING THE
SERVICES AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
PEOPLE NEED THEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING TO THAT.
IN ORDER TO COMEY THAT OPERATOR
AND SAY. THESE ARE MY- NEED AND
NOT OPERATED SAY WELL SIGNING
UP FOR THE PROGRAM SIGNING UP
FOR THAT PROGRAM AND YOU HAVE
TO GO OVER HERE FOR YOUR
SERVICES. INSTEAD KIND OF
PACKAGING THE SERVICES
INDIVIDUALLY FOR THE HOUSING
AND SERVICE BUT THE HEALTH
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE IN A WAY
THAT MAKES THERE. ABILITY
NAVIGATE ALL THESE THINGS MUCH
MORE. MUCH MORE MUCH MORE
VASSELIN ALSO ABLE TO GET THEIR
NEEDS BUT MUCH MORE QUICKLY
RIGHT TO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
TWENTY DIFFERENT PLACES ARE NOT
TRYING TO CHECK OUT. BOXES
PLEASE STREAMLINING ELIGIBILITY
IN A WAY BETWEEN SEVERAL
FUNDING STREAM. THAT WOULD HELP
CORD. WHAT NEEDS TO A SORT OF
READ OR AT LEAST STAND UP
HOMELESSNESS SO THAT'S ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE STATE WE HAVE
ALL THESE DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES THEY'VE GOT KIND OF
THEIR OWN WAY OF DOING THINGS-
IT IT TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE IS
THERE SOMETHING AS SOME KIND OF
PROGRAM OR OR FUNCTION SHOULD
SAY OR NEW AGENCY OR EFFORT
THAT'S BEING MADE ON THE STATE
LEVEL TO SORT OF. MOVE THOSE
WAS. IF SO WHAT ARE THEY IN IT
NOT WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND IT
DOES SOUND IN THE LAST- IN THE
LAST YEAR TOO ESPECIALLY THAT
THE VARIOUS AGENCIES
ESPECIALLY- AND HELPING HIM
SERVICES. AND DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES AT T. ARE SORT OF
WORKING TOGETHER IN A MUCH MORE
COORDINATED WAY TO THINK ABOUT
HOW THEY'RE FUNDING IN BE
BRAIDED AND BLENDED. LOCALLY
AND I THINK THE NEW SEVEN OR
FIFTY DOLLARS AS A MATTER OF
TWO MILLION- DOLLAR FUND IS
REALLY TRYING TO THINK ABOUT
HOW TO DO THAT HAD. HAVE
LOCALITIES HELP READ AND BLOOM
THAT FUNDING. OF THIS COMING
FROM IS DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES- THERE ARE YOU KNOW
OTHER STATES HAVE. THE THINGS
LIKE. INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
HOMELESS. I'VE NEVER BEEN
THEY'RE NOT REALLY ALWAYS THAT.
USEFUL UNLESS THE AGES
THEMSELVES ARE WILLING TO
REALLY KIND OF. TAKE DOWN SOME
OF THEIR- ELIGIBILITY ISSUES
AND REALLY WORK TOGETHER SO
THEY'RE ALL SEATED ON A COUNCIL
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
ANYTHING UNLESS THERE REALLY
WEREN'T WILLING TO SORT OF
FIGURE OUT. HOW TO STREAM LINE
ELIGIBILITY IN FUNDING SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN PORT MEET THEM MORE
EASILY- AND THOUGH IT CROSS THE
STATE I THINK. THE SORT OF
STRATEGIC VISION THAT YOU'RE
STARTING TO COME UP WITH- AT
THAT YOU'RE SORT OF COME UP
WITH THE STATE PLAN THAT'S VERY
ACTION ORIENTED AND OUTCOMES
ORIENTED. THAT'S REALLY TRYING
TO PIECE ALL OF THESE THINGS
TOGETHER SEEMS LIKE THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- AND I WOULD SAY THAT
YOU KNOW IN RATHER THAN HAVING
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT POGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING FOUGHT. FIGURING
OUT HOW TO THESE TOGETHER IN A
SYSTEMIC VERY JUST DO THE LOW
THE SHORT TERM. MEDIUM TERM
HELLO TERM FOR. ALL THESE
PIECES. THERE AND- FIGURE. THE
DIFFERENT. ISSUES WERE TO THE
PATCH THE TOGETHER. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THE VERY HELPFUL PRESENTATION
WE APPRECIATE A THANKS I THANK
YOU FOR LINKING IT TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION AS WELL. AS. OKAY
WELL- OUR NEXT- PANEL. HI IS-
HEARING FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO WILL SHARE-
RESULTS EXPERIENCES AND
BARRIERS TO COMBATING
HOMELESSNESS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES- SO WE HAVE FIVE
PANELISTS. FIVE ONE OKAY- FIVE
I WANT TO WELCOME CONNIE BACK
TO THE DIRECTOR OF THE HUMBLE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
SERVICES I JERRY RAMIREZ WHO IS
THE MANAGER OF HOMELESS
INITIATIVE- FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CHIEF EXECUTIVE'S OFFICE
HI JODY CATCH SIDE WHO IS THE-
DEPUTY REACHED. FOR CENTRAL.
OUR CEO OF INTER COUNTY AND
MATTHEW. IT'S CHOI STIR WHO IS
THE DEPUTY CITY MY FOR MOVED ON
I O I THINK WE'VE IN THE
MAXIMO MAX MAX AND BY MINUTES
EACH OF SO WE CAN YOU KNOW TOP
OF THE LINE IF YOU AND YOU'RE
ABLE TO DO IT A LITTLE LESS
THAN THAT THAT'S GREAT- I KNOW
THAT THERE WILL BE QUESTIONS SO
THERE WILL BE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
TO ELABORATE OKAY SO- MIST IS
BACK ARE YOU YES. THANK YOU YOU
FOR. THANK YOU SET ASIDE CONNIE
BACK HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DIRECTOR FOR HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
AND LIKE ALL COUNTIES ARE REAL
COMMUNITIES ARE STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS ALL START WITH
WHAT'S WORKING WELL FOR OUR
COUNTY IN OUR COMMUNITY. THE
FLEXIBILITY OF HE FUNDING
HELPED BRING MOBILE SHOWERS
STARK COUNTY EXPAND OUT REGION
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING AND
IMPORTANTLY HELP STARK COUNTY
BUILD STRONG STRONGER
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR CITIES.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING ALLOWED US TO LAUNCH
ARE HOMELESS MOBILE OUTREACH
TEAM AND OUR LAND LORD SUPPORT
PROGRAMS. THE SMALL COUNTY POOL
FOR THE MHSAA NOPE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM MADE OUR
APPLICATION MORE COMPETITIVE
AND RESULTED IN TWENTY FIVE NEW
UNITS FOR PERSONS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. COUNTIES APPRECIATE
THE TARGETED HOUSING SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS THE LEGISLATOR LET
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE AND CAL
WORKS ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
CHILD WELFARE AND SCOTT AND THE
SMALL COUNTY WHOLE PERSON CARE
PROGRAMS. THESE INVESTMENTS
LEVERAGE WHAT COUNTIES DO WELL
AND ARE HELPING US TO MEET A
PORTION OF THE NEED. BY EACH OF
THESE NEW FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
REQUIRES ITS OWN APPLICATION
AND COMES WITH ITS OWN UNIQUE
TARGET POPULATION RESTRICTIONS
AN END DATE FOR GRANTS MAKING
IT HARD TO PLAN FOR
SUSTAINABILITY. ALIGNING
APPLICATIONS AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS NEW
PROGRAMS WOULD REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND ALLOW
MORE SMALL AND RURAL COUNTIES
TO PARTICIPATE. WHEN AN
APPLICATION IS NOT NECESSARY
SETTING MINIMUM DEDICATED
ALLOCATIONS FOR SMALL COUNTIES
IS VERY HELPFUL. WE MAY NOT BE
SERVING THE SAME LARGE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE AS OUR URBAN
COUNTERPARTS BUT IT TAKES MORE
STAFF TIME AND LONGER TRAVEL TO
REACH OUR REMOTE LOCATIONS. ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST GAPS IN HOUSING
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IS OLDER
ADULTS WITH PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES. WE'VE SEEN A
GROWING NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
WHEELCHAIRS LIVING HOMELESS ON
OUR STREETS. HUMBLE IS
PARTICIPATING IN THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES HOME SAFE
GRANT AND IT HAS BEEN HELPFUL
IN PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS FOR
OUR APS CLIENTS. EXPANDING AND
SUSTAINING HOME SAFE WOULD BE A
GOOD INVESTMENT. WE FOUND THAT
MANY OF OUR ELDERS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WILL REQUIRE LONG
TERM CASE MANAGEMENT.
ADDITIONAL STATE INVESTMENT IN
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM WOULD HELP US MEET THIS
GROWING NEED. WE PLAN TO USE
TAP FUNDING TO HELP FILL THE
HOUSE IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES
GAP BUT THAT IS ONE TIME
FUNDING BUILDING HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND TENNESSEE
SUPPORT AND TO THE MEDI CAL
BENEFITS AS THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED IN THE STATE MEDICAID
WAIVER AND JANUARY BUDGET. WILL
BE A MORE SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION.
ROLL COUNTIES HAVE FEW LOCAL
PLACEMENT OPTIONS FOR CONSERVE
CLIENTS. OUR COUNTY PUBLIC
GUARDIAN WORKS CLOSELY ALONG
SIDE WITH OUR APS AND MENTAL
HEALTH TEAMS IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AS THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS CHANGING OR EXPANDING
CONSERVATORSHIP NEW ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN THE PUBLIC
GUARDIAN WILL BE NECESSARY TO
SERVE THIS VERY VULNERABLE
POPULATION. BUILDING NEW
HOUSING UNITS TAKES TIME ROLL
COUNTIES HAD VERY FEW
DEVELOPERS WITH THE EXPERTISE
AND WILLINGNESS TO CONSTRUCT
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
EMPOWER IN AND HUMBLE WE HAD
ONLY ONE DEVELOPER APPLY FOR NO
PLACE IKE HOME. WHILE WE WERE
TO BUILD THE HOUSING STOCK
STATE INVESTMENT AND BOARDING
CARE HOMES WOULD HELP SHORE UP
EXISTING HOUSE THE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR OUR SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. WHO
ARE AT HIGH RISK FOR CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS OR MORE EXPENSIVE
INSTITUTIONAL CARE. WE'VE ALSO
FOUND THAT ONCE UNITS ARE BUILT
LONG TERM RENTAL SUBSIDIES ARE
SIGNIFICANT GAPS. FOR THOSE NOT
YET RECEIVING A SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER COUNTIES MUST FIND THE
GAP BETWEEN THE RENT AND TENANT
CONRIBUTION. IN HUMBLE FOR
USING A COMBINATION OF ONE TIME
FUNDS SUCH AS HE AND LOCAL
STATE SALES TAX REVENUE A LONG
TERM STATE FUNDED RENTAL
SUBSIDY PROGRAM COULD HELP FILL
THE SECTION EIGHT GAP IN A
SUSTAINABLE WAY. LASTLY RURAL
COUNTIES HAVE LONG USED
REGIONAL APPROACHES TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. INCENTIVES TO
COLLABORATE REGIONALLY WHERE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WILL
PRODUCE BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
SMALL AND RURAL COUNTIES THAN A
SIGNING REGIONAL BOUNDARIES
BASED ON GEOGRAPHY. MOST RURAL
COUNTIES WILL ACT REGIONALLY
BUT WE NEED THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE WHICH JURISDICTIONS
AND HOW BEST TO COLLABORATE.
HUMBOLDT COUNTY HAS WORKED ON
HE PROJECTS WITH TWO OF OUR
CITIES AND WE ARE NOW EMBARKING
ON THE CHALLENGE OF CONVENING
ALL OF OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
SETTING COUNTY WIDE GOALS AND
EXPLORING DATA AND MEASUREMENTS
TO ENSURE COUNTY WIDE SUCCESS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT
OUR ROLE HOUSING CHALLENGES WE
LOOK FORWARD TO COLLABORATING
WITH OUR STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS TO IMPROVE THE LIVES.
OF THE WORLD FULL OF ARE
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME'S JERRY
REMEMBERS FROM THE LA COUNTY
HOMES INITIATIVE- THANK YOU FOR
THE UPDATE SERVICE SOME- WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IN OUR THERE
ARE NO LA COUNTY- BRIEFLY GO
OVER SOME BACKGROUND ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND ALSO SOME
RESULTS BUT I ALSO WANT TO
FOCUS ON A REGIONAL EFFORTS IN
HIGHLIGHT WHAT WE THINK IS ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES. SO
AS THE OTHER COUNTY- OF. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A SISTER TO COME
INTO CONTACT WITH HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. FOR
MANY MANY YEARS. BUT IT WAS
NEVER DONE IN A COORDINATED
FASHION. SO YOU KNOW THE COUNTY
DOESN'T HAVE THE LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA. BUT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OR BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS FELT THEY HAD
THE MORAL OBLIGATION TO DO IT.
SO TO THE FIFTEEN DAY INITIATED
THE HOMELESS INITIATIVE IS WHAT
WE CALL OUR EFFORTS. AND STILL
THIS EFFORT THE GOAL WAS TO. A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF STRATEGIES
TO PREVENT COMBAT HOMELESSNESS.
SO THE COUNTY THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICE- EMBARKED ON
AN INCLUSIVE AND COLLABORATIVE
SIX MONTH PROCESS TO DEVELOP
THESE STRATEGIES WHICH WITH THE
PARTICIPATION OF TWENTY FIVE
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS. OVER THIRTY
CITIES HUNDRED THE COMMUNITY-%
SERVICE PROVIDERS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THAT INCLUDED EIGHTEEN
THREE OUR POLICY SUMMIT THAT WE
DID- FOR FOCUS GROUPS WITH
PEOPLE LIVED EXPERIENCE- TOO
LARGE COMMUNITY MEETINGS AND WE
RECEIVED OVER TWO HUNDRED
PUBLIC COMMENTS- BASED ON THIS
WHOLE PROCESS WE DEVELOPED OF
FORTY SEVEN STRATEGIES-
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIES- THAT
WAS A APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND- FEBRUARY.
SEVENTEENTH IN ADDITION TO
APPROVING THOSE ARE STRATEGIES
THE ALL ON THAT ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND MY- UP TO START.
WE WILL OFF OF MONEY TO GET A
YOU KNOW OF A OUR PROBLEM BUT
IT WAS A START IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FROM YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD THE RESIDENTS OF LA
COUNTY APPROVED MEASURE RATES
WHICH IS A QUARTER CENT SALES
TAX- THAT WOULD GENERATE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARSA YEAR- TO.
INPUT PRODUCTS THIS WOULD BE
FOR TEN YEARS AND THESE FUNDS
WOULD BE- EXCLUSIVELY FOR- TO
BE SPENT ON HOMELESSNESS.
SPECIFIC TO THE IMPACT OF
MEASURE RATES FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS SINCE JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- OUT AS
MENTIONED EARLIER WORK. ON
CLOSE TO TWENTY THOUSAND FAMILY
MEMBERS AND INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN PERSONALLY HOUSE BECAUSE
OF MEASURE RATES. AND ANOTHER
FORTY THOUSAND PHONE NUMBERS
INDIVIDUALS WERE HAVE ENTERED
AN- ENTRY INTO THE HOUSING-
BECAUSE OR- KIND OF OUR- OUR
EFFORTS IN WORKING WITH THE
EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES THAT WE
HAVE IN LA COUNTY WITH DALY
CITY BEING ONE. THE BIGGEST ONE
IN A REALLY CLOSE PARTNER- BUT
THERE'S ALSO. EIGHTY SEVEN
OTHER CITIES IN THE COUNTY. AND
SO THIS IS A REGIONAL PROBLEM
AND WE UP WE START ALL ALWAYS-
THINKING THAT IT'S THERE NEEDS
TO BE A REGIONAL SOLUTION. SO
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OF
THE COUNTY PROVIDED TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO CITIES
TO DEVELOP HOMELESS PLANS. AND
SO OUR OFFICE THE PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- AND TO
SYSTEM TO DO THAT FOR YOU WHEN
CITIES IN OUR- IN OUR COUNTY-
DEVELOP THESE PLANS. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO MILLION DOLLAR MEASURE
RATE FUNDS. FOR THE CITY'S
IMPLEMENTOR PLAN. THIRTY ONE
CITIES ACTUALLY- TOOK US ON UP
ON THAT DEAL IN SOME OF THESE
TO THESE INCLUDED LAND USE AND
HOUSING ORDINANCES- PROPERTY
ACQUISITION FOR INTERMENT
PERMANENT HOUSING- SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS YOU KNOW-
GETTING HEALTHY NAVIGATORS
MOTEL VOUCHERS. SO SOLD
EXAMPLES OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW. IN
ADDITION TO FUNDING THE CITIES
WE ALSO FUNDED THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS WHICH IS YOU KNOW-
ASSOCIATION REGIONAL CITY
GOVERNMENT TO GET TOGETHER
EVERY SO OFTEN AND DISCUSS
ISSUES. SO WE PROVIDED SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN MEASURE IT'S
FUNDS TUBES THE SEVEN COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS IN LA COUNTY- IN
MAINLY WE'D LIKE THEM TO TAKE
MORE OF A REGIONAL APPROACH AND
WORKING WITH CITIES. CHRIS LIFE
SUPPORT HOUSING AND HEALTHY AND
ALSO WITH ENHANCE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR HOMELESS
DELIVERY SYSTEM AS WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE AND I THINK
IT'S- YOU MENTIONED AGAIN IS
YOU KNOW THE FAIRS AND
CHALLENGES OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING IS THAT IT'S
BASICALLY ECONOMIC DISPARITIES-
AND COMBINE FORCES. OF SKY
ROCKY RANTS ON JUST DEPICTIONS-
AND SEVERE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHICH HAVE RESULTED IN
LA COUNTY SEVEN WITH A TO IT
HAVE RESULTED IN SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND SEVERELY
RED BIRD AND- TENANTS IN LA
COUNTY WHICH IS DRIVING MORE
PEOPLE INTO HOMELESSNESS- IT'S
IMPORTANT NOT THAT I'M NOT ALL
THE- ALL THE PEOPLE HAVE
REMAINED ON THE STREET ALL
YEAR. WE SEE A DYNAMIC INFLOW
AND OUTFLOW THE HOME OF
DELIVERY SYSTEM HAS HELPED
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE EXIT
HOMELESSNESS BUT THE ECONOMIC
PRESSURES PUTS THOUSANDS MORE
TO HOMELESSNESS- ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE HOUSE MORE PEOPLE THAN
EVER IN THE LAST FEW YARS OUR
AFFORDABILITY. IS OVER NOW I IS
IN HOMELESSNESS ARE YOU
PROBABLY HEARD THAT BEFORE I
KNOW. TIMES NOW LIKE HAPPY. THE
STATE ON DAY INTO THE EIGHTEEN.
A HUNDRED THIRTY HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE P. ESCAPE HOMELESSNESS IN
LA COUNTY BUT A HUNDRED FIFTY.
PEOPLE PER DAY BECAME HOMELESS.
SO WE ARE COLLECTIVELY WORKING
HARDER FASTER AND MORE
EFFECTIVELY THAN EVER BEFORE TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS BUT THE
RATE OF INFLOW THE HOMES IS
THREATENING TO OVERWHELM US. SO
WHAT WE NEED AS WE MENTIONED
BEFORE INVESTMENTS IN HOUSING.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING- WE NEED
FINANCING INCENTIVES TO CREATE
AND PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN ALL OUR EIGHT EIGHT CITIES
AND UNINCORPORATED AREAS IN LA
COUNTY. WE NEED RENTAL AND
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR THOSE AT
RISK OF HOUSING STABILITY THIS
INCLUDES TEN IN EDUCATION AND
OUT REACH LEGAL REPRESENTATION-
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO HELP
TENANTS BETWEEN HOUSING
STABILITY ALL THOSE THINGS. SO
I KNOW ONLY HAVE FIVE MINUTES-
CLOSING NOW LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT OUR PARTNERS IN THE LAST
FOUR FIVE YEARS WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS WORK- IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT INCLUDES MOST OF
THE EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES. IN LA
COUNTY- THE VETO OF THE
CONVENIENCE OF CARE IN LA
COUNTY SERVICE PROVIDERS FAITH
LEADERS BUSINESS LEADERS
PHILANTHROPY- THOSE WOULD LIVED
EXPERIENCE WHO WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH.AND OF COURSE THE
STATE SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND IN IN
TRYING TO SOLVE. THIS THIS
HUMAN CRISIS THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH. ADAM WE'RE GOING ON ORDER
YOU KNOW WHATEVER OR DO PREFER
NOT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THE
ORDER I CALLED IN AND SO. AND
ANYONE AND EVERYONE. GOOD
MORNING I'M JOE TO CATCH A SIDE
DISABILITY YOU COULD SEE IT ON
THE AGENDA- SO I WANTED TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE AND WHERE THEY GOT STARTED
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES WE TALK
ABOUT CONTINUUM OF CARE AND THE
BACKGROUND INFORMATION IS
MISSING SO- THE FROM THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE WERE MANDATED
TO BE ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE. THE POINT IN TIME
HE FOUND WAS MANDATED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE FROM NINETEEN
NINE THERE WERE MINIMAL MEN
MINIMAL REGULATIONS AROUND
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND HOW
THEY OPERATED- IT WAS BASICALLY
A PUT OUT THERE THAT EACH
COMMUNITY NEEDED TO ESTABLISH A
CONTINUUM OF CARE IF THEY WERE
GOING TO BE RECEIVING HAD
FUNDING. AND THEIR WORK
COMMUNITIES THAT CAME TOGETHER
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE A LOT OF
CONTINUUM'S THAT ARE FRESNO
MADERA OR KINGS TULARE MEANS
AND THEY'VE JOINED JOIN
TOGETHER AND TO DO THE ACTIVE.
SEVENTY LIKE TO PLAY. IN TWO.
NINE THE HARD FACT WAS SIGNED
AND IT KIND OF CHANGE
EVERYTHING. EIGHT THAT THERE IS
A LOCAL COMPETITION THAT TAKES
PLACE WHEN THE HUD COMPETITION
OPENS EVERY YEAR- THAT REQUIRES
THAT THAT LOCAL COMPETITION
RESULT IN WHAT'S CALLED A
PRIORITY LISTING AND WHICH IS
THE RATING AND RANKING OF EACH
APPLICATION. AND THAT THAT'S
VOTED ONBY THE LARGER
CONTINUING GROUP BY THE
MEMBERSHIP ON THE BOARD OF
ACTORS DEPENDING ON HOW EACH
CONTINUE I'M IS STRUCTURED. IT
ALSO MANDATED THAT WE IMPLEMENT
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEMS-
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY AN A AND A
FACT A MORE EFFECTIVE WAY OF
PRIORITIZING FOLKS FOR HOUSING
AND ASSESSING WHICH HOUSING
INTERVENTION IS GONNA BE MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR PEOPLE. AND
THEN IT ALSO GAVE GUIDANCE ON
THE MAKE UP OF CONTINUUM OF
CARE BOARDS SO WHAT TYPES OF
PEOPLE SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
THE DECISION MAKING. AND IN A
LOT OF THE RECOMMENDATION WAS
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE HOSPITALS
AT THE TABLE YOU SHOULD HAVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT THE TABLE.
SO THERE WAS A LIST OF FOLKS
THAT CONTINUE ARMS NEEDED TO
AIMS AT BRING BRING TO THE
TABLE FOR THOSE DISCUSSIONS. IT
ALSO WILL GO THE HOMELESS
DEFINITION A LITTLE BIT SO OUR
CURRENT DEFINITIONS WE HAVE
CAN'T WAIT FOUR CATEGORY IS.
THE CATEGORY ONE WHICH IS A
PLACE NOT MEANT FOR HUMAN
HABITATION LIVING AT. THE
SHELTER- HOMELESS PRIOR TO
ENTERING AN INSTITUTION AND
STAYING NINETY DAYS OR LESS AND
RETURNING. TO HOMELESSNESS SO.
THAT FIRST I MEAN THAT THAT YOU
NEED A INSTITUTION REQUIREMENT.
LIMIT SIGNS FROM WHO WE CAN
SERVE THAT IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM SO SOMEONE EXITING
PRESIDENT. IS ALREADY YOUR
THEY'VE BEEN THERE LONGER THAN
NINETY DAYS. PRETTY MUCH A 100%
OF THE TIME AND- THEY WOULDN'T
BE ELIGIBLE FOR SERVICES THAT
ARE HARD FUNDED. CATEGORY TWO
IS AN EMINENT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS FOURTEEN
DAYS TO THEIR AFFECTION.
CATEGORY THREE IS HOMELESS
BATES ARE A AS DEFINED BY OTHER
STATUTES. EACH CONTINUE ON
WOULD HAVE TO APPLY TO BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THAT DEFINITION
ABOUT DEFINITION WOULD INCLUDE
YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS- HOMELESS
COUNT SWITCHES FAMILIES THAT
ARE RESIDING AND MOTELS THAT
ARE DOUBLE DOT. COUCH SURFING
THOSE SITUATIONS THE PROBLEM
THE REASON THAT ALL AND FOR.
OUR UTILIZING LACKEY ARE YOU TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE FOLKS WITH HAD
FUNDS IS BECAUSE IT'S THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR A MUCH
BROADER POPULATION SO AS MUCH
AS WE'RE SEEING OUR NUMBERS
GROW AND TRYING TO STRUCTURE
FUNDS. AS FAR AS WE CAN ADDING
IN THAT MISSION ALL MUCH LARGER
GROUP OF PEOPLE BUT STRETCH THE
FUNDS EVEN FURTHER. I THEN
CATEGORY FOR FLEEING TO MASS BY.
IT ALSO CHANGED ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS DEFINITION A LITTLE
BIT. CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS USED
TO BE A CONSECUTIVE YOU KNOW TO
BE ABLE TO CHAU CONSECUTIVE ONE
YEAR ON THE STREETS AND A
DISABLING CONDITION- IT IS NOW
AND HAS BEEN FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. ON THE STREETS
FOR A CONSECUTIVE YEAR OR BE
ABLE TO SHOW THREE FOUR
EPISODES OF HOMELESSNESS AND
THREE YEARS THAT ADD UP TO
TWELVE MONTHS. AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT THE DOCUMENTATION
NIGHTMARE. SO THAT'S JUST KIND
OF A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF WHAT YOU
KNOW WORK CONTINUUM'S CAME FROM
WHAT WERE CHARGED WITH DOING
AND- MOST CONTINUUM'S DO SERVE
ALSO AS AS LIKE A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BODY FOR THE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE DOING THE
WORK SUMMER MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NOT
INCORPORATED NONPROFIT. THAT
DESIGNATED ADMINISTRATIVE
ENTITY AND TO ADMINISTER THEIR
FUNDS THAT ARE. ARE ALLOCATED
TO CEO SEES SO THAT THE
STRUCTURE IS REALLY DIFFERENT
ACROSS THE STREET FOR THE CROSS
THE STATE FOR EACH CONTINUE ON-
AS FAR AS WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
FRESNO. SO WITH THE NEW FUNDS
THE HEAP AND THAT CASH FUNDS
THAT CAME OUT. FRESNO HAD WE
HAD NO SHELTERS BASICALLY WE
HAD ONE RESCUE MISSION SHELTER
SO- WE WERE ABLE TO ESTABLISH
FOR TRIAGE SHELTERS WHICH ARE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS THAT ARE
HYPER FOCUSED ON HELPING FOLKS
AND THEIR HOMELESSNESS WITHIN
THE NINETY DAYS THAT WOULD. WE
ARE THAT WE DETERMINED WAS THE
MAX DAY FOR OUR TRIAGE SHELTERS.
SO IS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN BEDS WERE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT IN FOUR DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS IN THE COMMUNITY SO
FAR WE'VE SERVED OVER THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THOSE
SHELTERS SINCE JULY FIRST 66%
OF FOLKS THE ENTERED THOSE
SHELTERS WENT INTO- LEFT TO A
SAFE EXIT WHICH CAN INCLUDE
BRIDGE HOUSING OR- PERMANENT
HOUSING. WE ESTABLISHED FORTY
FIVE NEW BED OF BRIDGE HOUSING
WHICH IS A SIX MONTH MAX STAY
WITH SIR SIXTY FOUR PEOPLE IN
THOSE BANDS. AND 86% OF THOSE
WERE SAFE ACCENTS. WE
ESTABLISHED FORTY FIVE NEW
RAPID RE HOUSING BEDS THAT ARE
JUST NOW COMING ONLINE CENTER
HAVE DATA FOR THOSE. AND THEN
WE IMPLEMENTED A DIVERSION
PROGRAM AND NOT STARTED IN
OCTOBER AND WE HAVE SERVE
SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE
WITH 91% OF THEM ACCIDENT
DEPARTMENT HOUSING. WHICH IS.
REALLY JUST A TESTAMENT TO.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T NEED A
LOT IN ORDER TO NOT FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS PERMANENTLY. SO IN
TOTAL WE HAVE WITH THE NEW
FUNDS WE'VE ALREADY SERVE SINCE
JULY FIRST FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE
AND VARIOUS INTERVENTIONS AND
THIS WAS HUGE FOR OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE WE HAVE A REAL
POLITICAL PUSH ON- WE HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT SAY.
PUBLICLY THAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT
HELP AND THAT- PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS DON'T
WANT SHELTER- ALL OF OUR
SHELTERS WERE FULL WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF OPENING SO
I'M HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN BEDS
FILLED LIKE IMMEDIATELY WHICH
IS REALLY AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THE NARRATIVE ABOUT PEOPLE
REALLY NEEDING AND WANTING
HELP. SELL I APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING ME HERE AND- THANK YOU.
YOU. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
CHAIRS COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER
ON SENATOR JACKSON'S- MY POWERS
THE- CEO FOR THE COUNTY OF
INTERNET ALSO JOINED BY THE
CHAIR OF THE BOARD SUPERVISOR
LONG AND THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
COMMITTEE PROVIDERS UP. BERMAN
FOCUS HERE WE'LL HAVE OUR
CHALLENGES I'M GONNA FOCUS A
LITTLE BIT TODAY- WHAT'S
WORKING A TO GIVE YOUR PROFILE
OF INTERCONTINENTAL LITTLE BIT
OF PHILLIP. URBAN SUBURBAN AND
RURAL SO GOOD PROFILE ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
POPULATION. AND TEN CITIES SO.
YOU KNOW SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN
WE WERE LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
FORMING OUR CONTINUE WITH CARE.
WE NEED TO DO IT FOR HER OF
COURSE BUT WE WANTED TO BE MORE
THAN THAT BECAUSE WE KNEW WE
HAD A LOT OF GOOD GROUPS IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT NOT ENOUGH MONEY
AND WE WANT TO TARGET THE
FUNDS. PRACTICES THAT WE KNEW
WOULD BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE SO
FORMED AND COMPOSITIONS
IMPORTANT ACCOUNT ON THERE FOR
THE TEN CITIES AREA HOUSING
AUTHORITIES- COMMITTEE BASED
POSITIONS IN A WOMAN WITH A-
LOOKS. AND UP IT. KING
EXTREMELY WELL JUST YOU A SENSE.
WHEN OTHER HEAT MONEY CAME OUT
WE HEADED UP THAT CRISIS
RESOLUTION WE ALL DID IT JUST
LIKE THAT- THERE WAS ABOUT FOUR
HAVE MILLION ON THE TABLE
EIGHTEEN MILLION REQUESTS. BUT
IT ALL WENT SURPRISINGLY
SMOOTHLY AS I TELL THE GROUP
WERE EMBARRASSINGLY FUNCTIONAL.
ENOUGH BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T SEE A
BIG FOOD FIGHT OVER IT- NOBODY
CAME TO THE COUNTY NOBODY CAME
TO THE CITY COUNCILS- THE-
COMMUNITY GROUPS GOT ON BOARD
AND EVERYBODY UNDERSTOOD. AND
IT'S REALLY WORKING AND SO.
WITH THAT HE FUNDING THE OUR
COUNTY BOARD ALSO IN LEADERSHIP
STEPPED UP AND SAYS WE WILL
MATCH THE START UP COSTS. AND
THE ONGOING COSTS OF ANY
PERMANENT YEAR ROUND SHELTER IN
THE COUNTY. BECAUSE WE NEVER
HAD ONE BEFORE. AND WE HAD TO
CITIES TAKE US. THAT THE CITY
OF INTERIM FACTION WEEK- TO GET
OLD- COUNTY BUILDING
ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDING AND WE-
LET. AND ABOUT SIX WEEKS AGO WE
OPENED IN OUR FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY YEAR HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTY WE OPENED OUR FIRST
PERMANENT. RUN FILTER- AND IT'S
UP AND GOING IS WORKING VERY
WELL WE HAD IN OUR OF P. OUT
THERE. IMMERSE HOUSING
EXPERIENCE PROVIDER. AND FIFTY
FIVE BEDS. AND TO LOW BARRIER
AND SO THAT'S- IT'S WORKING.
VERY WELL IT'S CITY BLOCKS ARE
ALSO HAS A YEAR ROUND SHELTER
IT'S TEMPORARY THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR A- PERMANENT. HOME BUT-
KEEP MONEY IS ALSO BEING USED
FOR THAT AS WELL AND IT HELPS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK. AT THAT
FIRST CHALLENGES AGO HOW WE
GONNA DO THIS BY OURSELVES BUT
IF THE STATE. PUTS MONEY IN THE
COUNTY PUT MONEY IN THE CITY IN
THE COMMUNITY. NEXT THING YOU
KNOW THAT INSURMOUNTABLE
PROBLEM IS ACTUALLY ACHIEVABLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED. THERE ARE WHETHER
YOU'RE RUN SHELTER. THE KEEP
FUNDS OR HAVE ALSO BEEN USED
FOR H. P. R. P. THE HOMES
VENTURE EVER HOUSING.
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE EFFECTIVE.
YOU KNOW 80% OF THESE FOLKS TO
HOUSE TO A ONE YEAR LATER. WE
THOUGHT IT WAS A NICE BANDAID
BUT IT'S WAY MORE THAN THAT AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM OUR- FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE- WE'VE USED TO.
THE H. P. RPM ISSUE THE HE
FUNDS- YOU KNOW. ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED TEN EMERGENCY SHELTERS
SEVENTY FOUR PERMANENTLY HOUSE-
FIFTY PREVENTED HOMELESSNESS
AND FORTY FIVE RE HOUSE. AND
SO- THE PARTNERS ARE REALLY
WORKING EXTREMELY WELL TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. I WOULD ALSO JUST
NOTE THAT. WE THINK A PERMANENT
ONGOING FUNDING IT IS GOING TO
BE SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT IT
TOOK DECADES TO GET TO THIS
POINT. IS NOT GONNA BE SOLVED
IN ONE MINUTE ONE YEAR
INCREMENTS. AND THE THING WHAT
I WOULD SAY IS THAT THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE IS ARE
WORKING. AND JUST CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THAT THE OUTCOME
MEASURES. THERE'S MEANINGFUL
GOOD MEASURES OUT THERE WE'RE
MEASURING TO THEM WE USE THEM
TO EVALUATE PROGRAMS IN
PARTICULAR FOR EXAMPLE IF
THERE'S A PROGRAM THAT'S NOT
LOW BARRIER. YOU KNOW WE'VE
JUST CONTINUE FUNDING THAT
FORTUNE. FOR US MOST OF OUR
PROVIDERS A GUN ABOARD SAYS WE
WANT TO BE LOW BARRIER. BUT
WERE USING THOSE MEASURES AND
WE WANT TO BE ACCOUNTABLE. TO
WE URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO.
DRAW UP A NETWORK AND ABOUT THE
REGIONAL. PEACE WITH RESPECT WE
APPRECIATE. THIS BUT GOVERNOR
PASSION. TO BE PULLED IN BIG
CHANGES WE GET THAT. BUT WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT ADDS A LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY THAT'S NOT REALLY
GOING TO HELP OUR OUR PROCESS
OUR PROCESS IN VENTURA COUNTY.
AT LEAST IS WORKING VERY WELL
IN TERMS OF LOCAL PLANNING AND
PARTNERING WITH OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO DO THAT.
WE ALSO HAVE. A PERSON QUE.
PROGRAMMER ONE OF TWENTY FIVE.
THAT IMPLEMENTED THAT IS
WORKING TO GREAT EFFECT WE HAVE
ABOUT. ELEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
SIGNED UP IN IT. I THOUGHT. I
WOULD I KNEW IT A HIGH UTILIZED
OR WAS IT USED TO WORK IN
HEALTHCARE. THESE ARE FOLKS WHO
USE THE E. R. SOME OF THEM.
EVERY OTHER DAY OR SOMETIMES.
EVERY DAY. OF A BECAUSE OF THIS
PROGRAM CASE MANAGEMENT WE HAVE
A- A REALLY OF BROAD
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. WE HAVE THE CASE
MANAGEMENT PRIMARY CARE. WE
HAVE A- COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER. AND THAT'S- BUT SOFT AS
HELPING US. PEOPLE TO THE
SERVICE MAKE SURE. GET THE
MEDICATIONS THEY- COME THEY GET
TO THE DOCTOR TO GET THE TEST.
ALL THAT. WE SEE. YOUR IT'S-
TO. WITH THE- RAM AND SAVE.
MILLIONS AROUND. SEE WE ARE
SERVICE PROGRAM WE ALSO STE OF
BOB YES WE TAKE OUR EGGS STAFF
AND IN ONE SAME TIME EVERY SAME
OKAY OF THAT WOULD REALLY
STAFFORD JUST IN ONE CORE TO
LOCATE TO CONNECT TO SERVE
COMMUNITY BASED ON GOVERNMENT
PROVIDERS AND SO FORTH IT'S
REALLY WORKING AND NOW WE HAVE
SEVEN SITES AND THE WHOLE
PERSON CARE PROGRAM DOVETAILS
WITH THAT AGAIN NICE BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE SHOWER POTS AND SO
FORTH BUT WE'RE ALSO CONNECTING
INTO HOMES PREVENTION RAPIDLY
HOUSING AND VETERANS BENEFITS
AND SO FORTH THERE SO- AGAIN-
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INTEREST IN OUR- IN OU- WHAT'S
HAPPENING LOCALLY IN AND- WE
REALLY THINK THAT THAT THE
MODEL THAT WE HAVE A FUNDING-
THE CFCS. IS A VERY SUCCESSFUL
ONE I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND SENATORS MY NAME IS
MATTHEW CHESTER I'M THE DEPUTY
CITY MANAGER IN THE CITY OF
HALF MOON BY- CITY POPPING BAY
IS A SMALL COASTAL COMMUNITY
AND CEMETERY COUNTY SENATOR
COUNTY IS. AN AFFLUENT
COMMUNITY NESTLED BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SILICON VALLEY.
AND I THINK IT'S A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF COLLABORATION BUT
ALSO- THE WEALTH DISPARITY IS
VERY VERY EVIDENT IN CEMETERY
COUNTY- TO START- I REALLY HAVE
TO START WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. MUCH LIKE
THE GENTLEMAN FROM LOS ANGELES
MENTIONED- THE COUNTY
RECOGNIZED ITS RESOURCES AND
ABILITY TO LEAD IN THIS AREA.
AND SO THEY'VE REALLY TAKEN THE
MANTLE OF LEADERSHIP IN
COORDINATING WITH- TWENTY
CITIES WITHIN CEMETERY COUNTY-
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE ALL IN A
ORDINATED EFFORT WORKING
TOGETHER. SHARING BEST
PRACTICES IN COMMUNICATE THE
TOP OF THE- AS WE WORK WITH
THIS POPULATION- THEY DON'T GET
LOST IN THE SHUFFLE- THEY DON'T
GET LOST AS- FOR FROM CITY.
THROUGH PROGRAMS. YOU'RE THE
STOCKS INTO PERMANENT. SOME OF
THINGS COUNTIES DOING THEY READ
THE HOPE IN OUR AGENCY CAL
WHICH IS LED BY COUNTY
SUPERVISOR STAFF BY HUMAN
SERVICES STAFF. AND IT'S A
COMBINATION OF CITIES COUNTY
STAFF AND- NONPROFIT SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND WE MEET QUARTERLY
AND TALK ABOUT ISSUES RECEIVE
DATE AND PRESENTATIONS AND IT'S
REALLY EFFECTIVE WAY TO
NETWORK. AND TALK ABOUT THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE WORKING
WITH THE COUNTY ALSO PROVIDES-
CASE MANAGEMENT FOR HOMELESS
OUT REACH TEAMS WHICH ARE BASED
GENERALLY. AND THIS IS A- KEY
IN MAKING SURE THAT AS WE TRACK
THESE INDIVIDUALS THROUGH THE
SYSTEM THAT AGAIN THEY DON'T
GET LOST WE KNOW THAT AS
INDIVIDUALS WE KNOW THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND THEIR NEEDS
ARE PROVIDED FOR AS THEY
NAVIGATE THE DETAILS ON THAT
RAN. TO ACTUALLY RECEIVE
HOUSING. WE ARE LUCKY TO HAVE
SEVERAL REGION SHELTERS UNDER
FUNDED BY THE COUNTY THEY'RE
AVAILABLE TO OUR RESIDENTS AND
IT'S VERY HELPFUL ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE STERLING.
OPTIONS WERE GREAT THERE WE.
TALK HAPPEN WE ARE CAN OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE TO. AS
SENATOR COUNTIES A VERY URBAN-
COUNTY- EXCEPT FOR HALF MOON
BAY AND THE CO SIDE- WERE QUITE
WILLING- ISOLATED FROM THE REST
THE COUNTY- TO THE NORTH OF US
IS APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN
THOUSAND MORE UNINCORPORATED
RESIDENTS WHO RECEIVE SERVICES
MY COUNTY BUT- WORK AND I GO TO
SCHOOL. AND SHOP INHALF MOON
BAY AND SO AS A CITY WE LOOK AT
THE REGION- WE CANNOT JUST
FOCUS ON THE CITY ITSELF. SO IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- ARE
HOMELESS CRISIS REALLY CAME TO
A HEAD- SMALLING KIM AND BEHIND
A SHOPPING CENTER ALONG- A CITY
ON CREEK- KIND OF WENT
UNCHECKED. AND IT GREW TO OVER
FORTY INDIVIDUALS WHICH FOR
SOME OF THE FOLKS IN THE ROOM I
KNOW THAT'S A SMALL NUMBER BUT
FOR CITY LIKE CAPTAIN MAY THAT
IS A SERIOUS SERIOUS ISSUE-
WERE COMPASSIONATE COMMUNITY
BUT AS THE FIRE STARTED TO
RACE. CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
BECAME CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE LIVING IN
THE ENCAMPMENTS AS WELL AS
THEIR OWN SAFETY- THE END
OBVIOUSLY CRIME HEALTH AND
SANITATION ISSUES. REALLY MET
THE CITY AND COUNTY HAD TO STEP
IN AND DO SOMETHING. OVER EIGHT
MONTH PERIOD WE EMPLOYED- WE
BELIEVE FOR ITS PRACTICES MANY
OF WHICH ARE NOW. OF THE NEW
POLL COMING OUT OF THE BOISE
DECISION. AND WE MADE SURE THAT
WE PROVIDED A LOT OF OUTREACH
TO THE INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN
THESE ENCAMPMENTS WE WORKED
DIRECTLY WITH THEM IN OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS. TO
TRANSITION THEM OUT OF AN
ENCAMPMENT AS OPPOSED TO
PUSHING THEM OUT- I THINK THE
MOST EFFECTIVE THING WE DID IS
WHAT WE CALLED INTENSIVE
SERVICE STAYS WE ACTUALLY
BROUGHT- ON THREE OCCASIONS
DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS
PERIOD. WE BROUGHT THE SERVICES
RIGHT INTO THE IN CAMERA WE SET
UP TENTS WE BROUGHT IN FOOD.
ALL THE SERVICES PROVIDE
SERVICE PROVIDERS CAME FROM
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY AND MET
THESE PEOPLE EXACTLY WHERE THEY
WERE. IN EACH OF THOSE WE FOUND
TO BE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
ACTUALLY TRANSITION IN MANY OF
THESE INTO SHELTER ON THE SAME
DAY- OTHERS INTO OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT PRO. COMES AND AT THE
TIME WE ACTUALLY CLOSE THE A
CHEMICAL PLANT I'M AT THE ONLY
IF PEOPLE. HUNTER LAUGHED AS WE
SEE OUR CLEAN UP. SO TO SAY WE
KNOW THE- POLICIES GONNA OUT OF
THE BOYS YOU TO SEE CAN QUITE.
TO INDIVIDUAL- JURISDICTIONS I
CAN TESTIFY THAT- IT IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO APPROACH THIS AND
MAKING SURE THAT YOU HAVE
PLENTY OF SHELTER SPACE OUR
COUNTY EXPANDED SHELTER SPACE
BE ADDED ANIMAL- IT PLACES FOR
ANIMALS AND STORAGE OF PEOPLE'S
GOODS. AND IT REALLY MADE THE
TRANSITION EASIER FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED. ANOTHER AREA THAT'S
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE IS WE HAVE
A SMALL LOCAL NONPROFIT- THAT
OPERATES IN HALF MOON BAY UP ON
AGREES CO SITE WORKER THEY
STARTED TO- BY OPERATING WHAT
WE CALL FULL SERVICE FULL
CIRCLE FOOD PROGRAM. THEY HAVE
A DONATED PORTION OF A FARM
THAT SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK THEY
TAKE- ANYBODY THAT'S ALMOST OR
NOT- BUT WILLING TO WORK UP TO
THE FARM IN THE- THE TELL THE
GROUND AT THE PLANT THE CROPS
THE HARVEST THE CROPS. THEN
THEY TAKE THOSE CROPS TO
DISTRIBUTE THEM- TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE WORKING
AND ALSO ADD ON MULTIPLE
BREAKFASTS ARE AVAILABLE TO.
LISTEN LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
AND HALF MOON BAY. BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE PAID FOR THE WORK THAT THEY
DO SO THEY'RE STARTING TO
RECEIVE- SUBSIDIZED WORK
EXPERIENCE THAT- ULTIMATELY
HELP SOME TO TRANSITION INTO-
UNSUBSIDIZED WORK- TWO YEARS
AGO THE CITY IMPLEMENTED A
PILOT PROGRAM CALLED THE COAST
CLEANUP TEAM- ROB BONTA GRACE
IS. MINISTRY THAT PROGRAM BUT
WE DID AND HE THEY WORK WITH-
THE SIMILAR POPULATION TO GO
OUT AND CLEAN OUR BEACHES AND
CLEAN PARKS IN OUR STREETS. AND
NOT ONLY DOES THIS ITEM OF OUR
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE THE WAY IT
LOOKS AND FEELS FOR EVERYBODY
IN THE COMMUNITY AS PRIDE
DIGNITY AND CHANGE OF
PERCEPTION. THE PEOPLE ARE
DOING THIS WORK AND ANOTHER
SOURCE OF INCOME FOR THESE
FOLKS AND A PLEASED TO SAY THAT
MANY OF THESE FOLKS TRANSITION
INTO PERMANENT POSITIONS WITHIN
BUSINESSES AND HAVE BEEN ALONG
THE. THERE ARE POLICE
SUBSTATION AND A COUNTY HEALTH
CLINIC AND IT'S GOING TO BE
USED AS A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
CENTER WHERE ABOUT A GRACE CAN
EXPAND ITS PROGRAMS WILL BRING
CASE MANAGEMENT INTO THEIR I
JUST GOT A TEXT FROM THE
DIRECTOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
BEFORE I CAME UP. IN THE
COUNTIES COMMITTING- MOBILE
HEALTH SERVICES THERE ONE DAY A
WEEK AS WELL SO THAT THESE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WILL
RECEIVE HEALTH SERVICES ON SITE
THIS IS A PLACE THEY CAN GO ANY
TIME THAT THEY NEED TO.TO
RECEIVE SERVICES AND IT'S BEEN
REALLY REALLY GREAT TO WORK
WITH THIS- GREAT NONPROFIT AND
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE THIS MOVE
FORWARD WANT TO END BY TALKING
ABOUT A COUPLE OF INDIVIDUALS-
THE FIRST IS NAMED TEA. AND SHE
WAS A RESIDENT OF THE COAST
SIDE OF HALF MOON BAY FOR MANY
DECADES GAINFULLY EMPLOYED.
MARRIED AT HOME. AND IN HER
FORTIES SHE FACED A FAMILY
CRISIS- SLIPPED INTO SOME
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
ADDICTION ISSUES. AND END UP
BECOMING BECOMING HOMELESS-
LIVED ON OUR STREETS FOR OVER A
DECADE- SHE RECEIVE VOUCHERS
AND WAS HOUSE SEVERAL TIMES
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
FORTUNATELY THE ISSUES DEALING
WITH ME VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR
BRITISH COMFORTABLE INDOORS AND
THAT'S A PHENOMENON WE'VE
OBSERVED WITH MANY OF THE
HOMELESS WE'VE WORKED WITH. IS
THE TRANSITION FROM THE STREETS
TO AND- CAN ACTUALLY BE. QUITE
DRAMATIC IN REQUIRE A LOT OF
EXTRA HELP. I THINK THAT. I
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES REALLY
IMPORTANT. CHEN WE ARE A WE
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED. FORCE TO
REALLY ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY
TEASE NEEDS- I'M FOR. WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO HELP HER IN AND
HOUSING AND SHE- AWAY SOME. WAS
WRONG WE I FOR A STATE. YOU CAN.
PUT A RESOURCE INDIVIDUAL
RESOURCE TO SOME. BUT
ULTIMATELY THEY THEY TO MAKE
THE CHOICE ON HOW THEY RECEIVE
THOSE THOSE RESEARCH. IS AND
SOMETIME. THE AND. THIS IS JAY
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL LIVED ON THE
STREETS OF HALF THE FIRST
DECADES HE WAS A HOMELESS
IMPALA. FOR SEVERAL YEARS IN
MAY HIS WAY TO THE COAST.
CALLED AT HOME WE ONE OF OUR
CREE IN A PRETTY I SETTING
CREEKSIDE CAMPSITE FOR MANY
YEARS I GOT TO KNOW HIM REALLY
WELL THROUGH OUR SITE VISITS
AND- VERY VERY. NICE MAN AN
ARTIST LOVE TO DO ARTWORK CAN
SHARE WITH THE COMMUNITY WELL
KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY-
WOULD CLAIM HE WAS QUITE HAPPY
LIVING ON THE ALL YOU KNOW ON
THE LAND AND BY THE CREEK. BUT
AS THE ENCAMPMENTS GREW- HE
FELT THE PRESSURES AND THE
STRESSES THAT COME FROM AND
CAN'T MINCE AND- GRATEFULLY HE
RECEIVED. VOUCHER AND WAS
HOUSED- THIS PAST YEAR IN LOW
INCOME SENIOR HOUSING AND HALF
MOON BAY WE HAVE A LARGE
COMPLEX WITH A LONG WAITING
LIST. BUT HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
ARE PRIORITIZED- HE MOVED INTO
HIS APARTMENT YOU CAN SEE THERE
ON THE RIGHT AND BROUGHT ALL
HIS ARTWORK AND REALLY EXCITED-
ABOUT A MONTH AFTER HE WAS
HOUSE THOUGH I FOUND. ON OUR
MAIN STREET IN AS WE- DON'T.
AND WHAT BOB AND I CHATTED.
KEEP THE BUS BACK TO THE PART
SO I STARTED PUSH HIM DOWN THE
STREET INTO TO ABOUT HOW THINGS
WERE HE BURST INTO TEARS. HE
WAS- EXPERIENCING PSYCHOSIS
AGAIN THE TRANSITION FROM THE
STREETS THE HOUSING WAS
ACTUALLY QUITE TRAUMATIC FOR
HIM AND- HE WANTED TO MOVE BACK
OUT OF THIS HOUSING AND ON TO
THE STREET GRATEFULLY-
INTERVENTION HAPPENED- HE GOT
THE SERVICES HE NEEDS. AND TO I
SEE HIM EVERY DAY HANGING OUT
IN THE PLAZA ACROSS FROM CITY
HALL AND HE'S HAPPY. BEING IN
THE COMMUNITY AND I THINK HE'S
OVERCOME THOSE CHALLENGES AND
HE IS NOW PERMANENTLY HOUSED I
SPOKE TO HIM ABOUT THIS HEARING
TODAY AND ASKED HIM YESTERDAY
IF YOU COULD GO WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY. TO THE SENATOR STAR
LEADERS IN THE STATE. THE LIKE
HIM. THEY WANT THREE THINGS
THEY WANT A PLACE THAT THEY CAN
CALL HOME AND FEEL DIGNIFIED
ABOUT. THEY WANTED TO BE SAFE
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY'D NEVER FEEL
ONE ON THE STREETS SAFE. THIRD
IS THEY WANT TO FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF
SOCIETY. AND SO- I'M GRATEFUL
THAT YOU FOR THE HELP THE
SESSION TODAY AND I'M GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S THAT'S
HAPPENING HERE. AND I HOPE THAT
WE CAN LEARN FROM EVERYTHING
WE'VE HEARD TODAY TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS LIKE T. M. J.
MOVING TO A BETTER PLACE IN OUR
LIVES. THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH US IS REALLY-
HELPFUL AND I KNOW- YOU KNOW AS
WE HAVE THIS STATEWIDE
CHALLENGE RUN HOME SINCE OF
COURSE OF FALLS ON. LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO BE ON THE FRONT
LINES AND ONE THING I HAVE-
OBSERVE ESPECIALLY THE LAST FEW
YEARS IS- ALTHOUGH WE SAW
ALWAYS HAVE. YOU KNOW LEVELS
RESISTANCE TO PUTTING SHOT IS
AN APPLICATION CENTERS ARE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING INTO
COMMUNITIES- IN MY PERCEPTION
IS THAT CITIES AROUND THE
STATE. ARE BECOMING MUCH MUCH
MORE EMBRACING. OF THESE
SOLUTIONS- OR TRIAGE OR OR
WHATEVER THE WHATEVER THE- AND
MORE MORE PEOPLE ARE PUTTING
TWO AND TWO TOGETHER SEC. I
UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
BE FRUSTRATED. ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS ARE STREETS ARE
ABOUT. ATTENDING CABINET. FIVE
WE- HAVE TO BE SOLUTIONS. AND
THE CANCERS WERE WHY THAT HAVE.
BOISE WHAT ONE. ABOUT THAT.
DECISION I THINK WHAT IT WHAT
IT. I WAS HOPING TO ACCOMPLISH
IS MAKING CLEAR TO CITIES- DIE-
YOU CAN'T JUST SAY GO AWAY- YOU
HOP TO PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES- UP
FOR PEOPLE BECAUSE IT AREN'T
JUST GOING TO GO AWAY PEOPLE
ARE IN A COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE
GOING TO. TO STAY THERE- SO I
WANTED TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE CITIES ARE
DOING WE'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE
MORE SUPPORT FINANCIALLY- AND
OUR BUDGET I KNOW WE NEED TO DO
EVEN MORE- TO HELP US CITIES-
BUT WE ARE WE MAKING PROGRESS
IN THE THIS GOVERNOR IS- HAS
BEEN. MUCH MORE RECEPTIVE IN
TERMS OF WORKING WITH US TO
PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES. WE'RE
ALSO TRYING TO MAKE CITIES LIFE
EASIER LAST YEAR- WE WERE ABLE
TO PASS- I INTRODUCED A BILL
AND THEN A CUTTING CORPORATION
TO THE BUDGET. TO STREAMLINE
THE APPROVAL NOT SINCE EARLY
THAT CITY ONCE BUT NOT IN
CENTER AND- GOOD. IF IT MEETS
AND IT'S IN A MIXED USE OR
COMMERCIAL AREA IT'S APPROVED-
THIS YEAR WE ASK A FOLLOW UP
LEGISLATION CAUGHT HIM MAKE IT
EVEN MORE STREAMLINED TO GET
THE SERVICES IN PLACE WE'VE
EFFECTIVELY STREAMLINED PART OF
HOUSING ALL THROUGH CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THE SENATE THE BILL
THIRTY FIVE OTHER AYE ALTON
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND ADDITIONS
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AUTHORED SPECIFIC TO
SUPPORT OF HOUSING- AND- WE- SO
THERE'S NO SEQUIN A CONDITIONAL
USE FOR SUPPORT. IN CALIFORNIA
ANY WORKS FINE TO REMOVE SOME
OF THE STATE BARRIERS SO CITIES.
AND TO PROVIDE MORE RESEARCH
SAYS AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR REALLY- STEPPING UP ITS
BEEN INSPIRING ACTUALLY TO SEE
COMMUNITY STEP. THANK YOU
CENTER FOR THAT SUPPORT
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL WANT TO
SHARE ONE INNOVATIVE THING
WE'VE DONE IN OUR COUNTIES
CITIES ARE STEPPING UP AS YOU
SAY THEY SOUGHT CHALLENGES
CITING THOSE LOCATIONS BUT BUT
THIRD THEY SEE THE NEED MORE
THAN THE COMMUNITY SEASONING.
THAT NEED MORE BUT WE ALSO
DEVELOPED A HOMELESS IMHO YOU
WITH ALL ALL THE CITIES WERE
SOMEWHAT CONCERNED WELL THEY
DON'T NEED A SPECIAL FROM THEIR
CITY BUT IF THE IF THE SOMEONE
BILLS AT THE ONES BUILDING A
SAND. GONNA GET HOMELESS FROM
THE OTHER CITIES ARE RIGHT TO
SAY LET'S. START IN A
REASONABLE. SO WHAT WE ASK THAT
ALL THE CITY'S. ON TO THE IMHO
YOU SAYING THAT. WOULD PUT.
HOMELESS SERVICES WHATEVER
LEVEL THEY NEEDED FOR THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. IN THEIR
CITIES. AND EVERYBODY WAS SORT
OF. OUR OWN EMERGENCY HOUSING
AND SHELTERS AND SO FORTH SO.
WE HAVE SEVEN OF THE TO THESE
CITIES SIGNED ON SO FAR- AND I
THINK IT IT JUST SHOWS THE
WORLD LEANING IN TO GATHER AND
THEY ALL AGREE. TO PARTICIPATE
INCORPORATED ENTRY LEVEL SINGLE
COORDINATED FREE FOR ANYONE IS
HOMELESS AND ARE COUNTY. AND
THEY ALL AGREE TO. UP IN OUR
HOMELESS. MAN TO ENSURE THAT BY
ITSELF. THAT'S GREAT AND I
THINK YOU WERE THE ONE WHO
MENTIONED THAT YOU NOW HAVE A
YEAR ROUND. THIS SHELTER
BECAUSE WE- WHEN WE SAW. THIS
WORK. YEARS SO WITH SO THAT
MANY COUNTIES. HAVE YEAR ROUND.
SHELTERS OR- HAVE A SHELTER. OR
IN. AN AIRPORT. AT THE- OUR- TO
GO. ANY BETTER. GRAPHIC EQUITY
IS IMPORTANT. BAKER SAYS ONE
QUITE- I. I I'M SOMEWHAT. I
FORGOT TO. JUST ALASKA HOMELESS
ACT. OF TWENTY TWO. WERE TO GET
A PASSAGE OF THE IN STEP ON AND
ONE OF THE WHEN WE WERE WORKING
ON THAT LEGISLATION ONE- DATA
POINT THAT WE CAME UPON WAS A
STARTLING IS A TWO THIRDS OF
COUNTIES IN THE SOUTH TWO YEARS
AGO TWO THIRDS OF COUNTIES DID
NOT HAVE YOU SPECIFIC. HOMELESS
PROGRAMS OVER THE PRIME MORE
STATE SUPPORT- OFF BY. USING
COUNTIES- CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT JUST ABOUT THE U. SPECIFIC
PROGRAMEVENT- OR HOW YOU
APPROACH THIS. HOMELESS YOUTH.
QUICKLY LA QUE DOES OF OUR
STRATEGIES ARE FOURTY SO
STRATEGIES DEALS WITH HOMELESS-
YOUTH. SO WE INVEST I FORGOT
THE NUMBER BUT I THINK IT'S
CLOSE TO. FIFTEEN TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR BASIC.
THIS IS. OUR YOUTH SO WITH DO
HAVE A PRO. FOR THE OFFICE
ALEJO'S AND THE LARGER COUNTIES
I THINK TEND TO BE MORE BUT-
AND I LA HAS SOME TERRIFIC I
KNOW SOME REALLY AMAZING
PROGRAMS ABOUT MASSEUSE. AND IN
A SMALLER COMMUNITY. THE OTHER
OKAY GET. THEY ARE SO IN COUNTY
IN FOR A LONG TIME THE ONLY
THING THAT WE HAD AND IT WAS
REALLY LIKE FROM. FRESNO TO AS
FAR SOUTH AS- LOS ANGELES THERE
WASN'T ANY OTHER HOMELESS YOUTH
SHELTER FOR RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN- THERE WERE A WE HAD
LIKE THREE TRANSITIONAL LIVING
CENTERS WE LOST WHEN I HAD. DID
IT- PULL AWAY FROM TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING AND RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT. THROUGH SOME
FEDERAL FUNDS A TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOUTH SHELTER WHICH IS- THE
ONLY ONE DEFINITELY NORTH
BETWEEN BAKERSFIELD FRESNO. AND
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FIVE BAD
SWEAR THEY'RE SERVING IN THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE
POPULATION- BUT THEN ALSO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF BRIDGE-HOUSING SO THE NEW FUNDS OF
HELPED WITH THAT BUT I THINK
THAT. LIKE IT'S NOT IN OFF. YET
I SURE I WAS IN FRESNO AND I'M
SOMEONE WHO'S INVOLVED WITH
THAT AT IN THE CHEST OPEN AT A
COUPLE YEARS AGO I'M NOT
MISTAKEN. AND HE SAID THAT IF
THEY OPEN UP WITH TWENTY FIVE
BAD LIKE THREE HUNDRED YOUNG
PEOPLE SHOWED UP FOR THOSE
TWENTY FIVE BEDS- SO I. DO HAVE
A LOT OF. CAPITAL IT'S- EXPAND
THOSE RISKS. BECAUSE IF A KID
BECOMES HOMELESS AT AGE SIXTEEN
OR SEVENTEEN OR EIGHTEEN- AND
YOU CAN RAPIDLY RE HOUSE- YOU
CAN AVOID CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS
WHEN THEY'RE ON THE STREET FOR
FIVE TEN YEARS. YOU KNOW IT'S
MUCH HARDER I THOUGHT WAS ON
THOSE IN THOSE SLIDES. MONDAY
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE CHALLENGE
IS THAT. SO WHEN. I DID IT'S
PUSHED WHERE THEY WOULDN'T THEY
WOULDN'T. DO THE LAST POINT OF
VIEW DIDN'T DEDICATE YOUR-
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. ANY NEW
PROJECTS THAT WERE AWARDED WERE
ALL DEDICATED CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS AS- WELL YOU AGE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE NOT.
NOT CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
THANKFULLY THEY DON'T MEET THAT
DEFINITION. JEFF OLDER UNIT ARE
THERE IS A LOT OF SUPPORT OF
HOW DE TO CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
POPULATIONS TO FIND HOUSING
THAT YOU QUALIFY FOR THAT IS
YOU KNOW SERVICE INTENSIVE
ENOUGH FOR THEM LIKE A LOT OF
THEM NEED NEED HIGH NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO SERVICES INSTEAD
OF LIKE A SCATTERED RAPID RE
HOUSING SITE MODEL WHERE
THEY'RE PLACED INTO AN
APARTMENT AND THEY SEE A CASE
MANAGER A COUPLE TIMES A MONTH.
SO THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE WE
NEED T DO MORE TO OFFER MORE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR THAT
AGE GROUP TO OFFSET WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN SO MANY COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE DEDICATED. TO PEOPLE.
THAT THE ARTS THOROUGHBREDS
THAT YOUTH DON'T MEET THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR. VENTURA
COUNTY WERE OUR OUR BOARDS MADE
IT CLEAR THEY DON'T WANT ANY
USE AND IN THE SHELTERS AND SO
WE'VE REALLY WE'VE BEEN.
AGGRESSIVE BUT UTILIZING HOMES
PREVENTION RAPIDLY HOPPING
FUNDS A REAL SUBSIDIES TO HELP
WITH THAT AND WE ARE ALSO
ADVOCATING. FOR TRANSIT ALLEGE
YOUTH A SHELTER IN OUR COUNTIES
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY THANK YOU. CALLING SO
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
NO YOU HAVE COVERED IT
BEAUTIFULLY DOC NUMBER
QUESTIONS. OKAY I THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING TO
THE TO THE FINAL PANEL ALL BE
FACILITATING THIS ONE. TO MY
FELLOW OF MY FELLOW COMMITTEE
CHAIRS OR DOING OTHER IMPORTANT
WORK. SO THIS IS A. A PANEL
FIBER FROM PRACTITIONERS ABOUT
PRACTITIONER PERSPECTIVES AND
STRATEGIES WE HAVE FOR- PANELS
CHRIS MARTIN WHOSE- LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE- ON HOMELESSNESS FOR
HOUSING CALIFORNIA- SHARON
REPORT WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF-
CALIFORNIA STATE POLICY AT C.
S. H. CRISTESCU WELL WHO'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE WINDS
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY- FOR USE-
SERVICES IN MY AREA IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. AT THE STOP
AND SUBDUE SO AGAIN ANY ORDER
START BUTTON PROCEED- AND AGAIN
FIVE MINUTES AND YOU'RE WELCOME
NOT TO TAKE THE FULL FIVE
MINUTES BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING- YOUR
FULL OP FIRST OF. GREAT AND I
TO PASS I'M SURE I CAN I PLUG
REAL HERE FOR IF I'M A GOOD
MORNING CHAIRS AND- THANK FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY. MY NAME
IS CHRISTOPHER MARTIN- WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA MY
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOCUSED ON
HOMELESSNESS. HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IS A NONPROFIT
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WITH THE
MISSION TO ENSURE THAT NO ONE
IS HOMELESS. AND EVERYONE ARE
THOSE OF INCOME AS A CITY
STABLE AND AFFORDABLE. PLACE TO
LIVE. THIS HEARING OF THREE
COMMITTEE THIS SHOWS YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE TO ADDRESS
VAST CROSS. NATURE OF BALANCE
TO FACE CALIFORNIA. A
CALIFORNIA IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS WITH OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
AND LIGHT AND I'D LIKE TO PAINT
A PICTURE OF WHO THESE
CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT OF
THEM ARE INDIVIDUAL ADULTS AND
OF THOSE FORTY ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS WE KNOW SOLUTION FOR
POST ACUTE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL IS THE INTER TO
KNOWN AS SUPPORT HOUSING WHICH
HAS NO ITS IT COMES WITH THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS NECESSARY
TO ALLOW TENANTS TO MAINTAIN
HOUSING STABILITY IF. MOST
SINGLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS DO NOT HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES SUFFER FROM A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER OR OTHER
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO HOUSING
STABILITY. MOST SINGLE ADULTS
AND FAMILIES SIMPLY NEED AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE TO AND
THEY'RE HOMELESSNESS. BUT YET
IN CALIFORNIA. FINDING AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE OUT OF
REACH AS WAGES DO NOT KEEP UP
WITH RENTS. THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
FOUND THAT 53% OF THEIR NEWLY
HOMELESS RESIDENTS CITED
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP. NOT MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE AS
THEIR LEADING FACTOR TO
BECOMING HOMELESS. LAST YEAR
ALONE. EVEN THOUGH FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND OF THESE. NEW
RESIDENTS WE WERE ABLE TO
ACCESS HOUSING FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND FELL NEWLY HOMELESS
THIS THIS IS A DIRECT DIRECT
RESULT OF MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS IN LOS ANGELES
PAYING MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR
RENT ON THE- ON HOUSING OR%
KNOWN AS SEVERELY RAP BURDEN.
AS YOU CAN SEE THIS IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND HOMELESSNESS. THE REPORT IN
FRONT OF YOU FROM THE NATIONAL
LOW INCOME HOUSING COALITION.
STATES THE FAIR MARKET RENT FOR
A TWO BEDROOM HOME IN
CALIFORNIA IS EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
AND FOUR DOLLARS. AND THE
HOURLY WAGE NECESSARY TO AFFORD
THAT RAN IS THIRTY FOUR DOLLARS
AND SIXTY NINE CENTS. THIS
MEANS THAT A MINIMUM WAGE
EARNER WOULD HAVE TO WORK A
THREE FULL TIME JOBS A WEEK TO
A FOR THAT RENT. TO MAKE ENDS
MEET MINIMUM WAGE EARNERS ARE
OFTEN FORCED TO ACCEPT SUB
STANDARD OR OVERCROWDED HOUSING
OR OUTRAGEOUS COMMUTES
RESULTING IN A LARGER LOWER
QUALITY OF LIFE AND CASCADING
EFFECTS ON SOCIETY AS A WHOLE.
THE SAME REPORT SHOWED
AFFORDABLE TO A HOUSEHOLD
WORKING FULL TIME MINIMUM WAGE
JOB WOULD SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS PER MONTH.
IN CALIFORNIA. I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT FINDING AN APARTMENT
FOR SIX HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
DOLLARS. I CAN SPEAK MY
PERSONAL. LIVING IN AMADOR
COUNTY EAST OF SACRAMENTO WHERE
I LIVE AND I FOUND THAT
ABSOLUTELY IMPOSSIBLE. THE
HOUSING CRISIS IS CERTAINLY
HITTING THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS IN DIFFERENT WAYS
BUT IT IS MOST ACUTE. FOR
PEOPLE EARNING AT OR BELOW 30%
OF AREA MEDIAN INCOME WHICH IS
DEFINED AS EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
FOR. THREE QUARTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS HOUSEHOLDS
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. AND MORE
THAN HALF OF THEIR INCOME ON
RENT THIS MEANS THEY HAVE
LITTLE LEFT OVER FOR OTHER
BASIC NECESSITIES LIKE FOOD
MEDICINE IN CHILDCARE AND THIS
IS PRECISELY THE POPULATION
MOST AT RISK FOR FALL AND
HOMELESSNESS. WE MUST FOCUS
THOSE PARDON ANY IMPACT I THE
NIGHT OF PEOPLE EXT OR AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS LIKE
THE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM AT AGE CITY AND THE
FEDERAL AND STATE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS
BOTH PRIORITIZE THESE
HOUSEHOLDS WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO INVEST IN THOSE PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE WE ARE SERVING
HOUSEHOLDS WITH THE GREATEST
NEED YET HOUSING PROGRAMS. TO
SERVE ILL I HOW OLD IS STILL
NOT ENOUGH BECAUSE MOST
PROGRAMS DO NOT SPECIFICALLY
TARGET HOUSEHOLDS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THE AVERAGE INCOME
FOR A PERSON EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IS 14% OF THE AREA
MEDIAN WHICH IS WELL OF COURSE
THE THIRTY TARGET ANY PROGRAMS
YES SINCE HOUSEHOLDS EARNING
BELOW 30% OF AM I OUR HONOR ON
TO AFFORD THEIR PORTION OF
SUBSIDIZED. LEAVING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR OWNERS TO ABSORB
OPERATE CASA THOSE ARE UNIT
UNABLE TO THE PARTYIN. IN
OTHER THIS GAP MEAN TO ARE AT
ELI HOUSE CANNOT PENCIL OUT
SPECIFICALLY OF THAT RENTAL
UNIT IS A HOUSING A FORMALLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY
TO BE ABLE TO HOUSE IN
INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGH A PRO LIKE AGE. MHP
PROGRAM A DEVELOP BUYERS AN
OPERATING SUBSIDIES SUFFICIENT
ENOUGH TO COVER THIS GAP AND
MOST OF OUR PROGRAMS DO NOT
PROVIDE THE SUBSIDY FOR ANOTHER
WAY TO PROVIDE HOUSING TO THIS
SPECIFIC POPULATION IS THE
CLOSEST PULLED WITH LIFE
SERVICE AND THE NAVIGATION. IS
HE DOES NOT HAVE A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM LIKE THE- AS MENTIONED
EARLIER A GREAT MODEL FOR THIS
IS A FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
POOL IN LOS ANGELES WHICH
COUPLES RENTAL ASSISTANCE WITH
CASE MANAGEMENT HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND TENDENCY
SUPPORTS TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS IMMEDIATELY AND KEEP
THEM HOUSE. WELL IT'S BEEN
PROVEN SUCCESS WITH MORE THAN
90% HOUSING RETENTION RATE IN
ITS SIX YEAR OF OPERATION. IN
RECENT YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS LOOKED AT A VARIETY OF
TOOLS TO LOWER THE COST AND
TIME TO BUILD HOUSING.
INCLUDING WITH AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY TWO FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH
MADE SUPPORTING HER SUPPORT OF
HOUSING A USED BY RIGHT AND AS
SENATOR WIENER MENTION TO THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND SB
FORTY EIGHT WHICH HE HAD LAST
YEAR. LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE BY ROAD- WILL OF AN
EVIDENCE BASED MODEL FOR
SHELTERING INDIVIDUALS AND
CONNECTING THEM TO SERVICES
KNOWN AS LOW BEAR NAVIGATION
CENTERS. THE LEGISLATURE CAN
CONTINUE TO DRIVE DOWN COSTS BY
REMOVING BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND ALSO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO. SURE THAT HOUSING SIR
DOUBLE TO THE LOWEST INCOMES. I
HAVE THREE RECOMMENDATIONS
TODAY ONE CONCERN VESTMENTS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ARE DEEPLY
TARGETED AND FOCUSED ON THOSE
MOST OF REALLY RAMPART AD BY
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA TO REQUIRE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
TO SET ASIDE A PERCENTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE RENTAL UNITS
SPECIFICALLY FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHO
DO NOT NEED SUPPORT OF HOUSING
AND GIVE DEVELOPERS THE
RESOURCE TO DO. WITH SOMETHING
LIKE OPERATE SUBSIDY OR PROJECT
BASED RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
THREE CONTINUE TO INVEST IN A
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. FOR
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. WHAT WE FACE THIS
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGE WE MUST
COME AT IT WITH ALL THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO PRODUCING HOMES IN
ENSURING THOSE MOST AFFECTED BY
THE COSTS OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA ARE PRIORITIZED.
THAT IS HOW WE WILL SEE REAL
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND DEDICATION TO
THIS ISSUE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'M. HOPEFULLY MY
PRESENTATION BE UPLOADED IN
JUST A SECOND- GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M SURE AND REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING  WORK ON STATE POLICY-
AND- JUST TO GIVE YOU A TWO
SECOND OVERVIEW OF MY
ORGANIZATION WE'RE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION ARE BURYING CALL IS
TO MAKE SURE THOSE WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS OF A PLACE THE
CALL HOME AND SERVICE AND
SUPPORT THRIVE. I'M JUST TOO
QUICKLY ECHO THE POINTS THAT
CHRIS MARTIN RAISED I DO THINK
IN ORDER FOR THE STATE TO MOVE
FORWARD AROUND HOMELESSNESS WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO MAKE A MAKE
UP THE GAP AND STOCK OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS WITH EXTREMELY LOW
INCOMES CAN AFFORD. HELP PEOPLE
AFFORD HOUSING BY SUBSIDIZING
OPERATING AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE
AND ALLOW PEOPLE ACCESS TO
HOUSING OF SERVICE HOUSING
SERVICES. IN INNOVATING TO
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS WE SHOULD
NEVER OFFER A TINY HOME WITHOUT
PLUMBING AS A SOLUTION OR FUND
OTHERWISE SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS ARE UNSAFE
CONDITIONS AS A WAY TO GET
PEOPLE AND HOUSING QUICKLY. AS
UNSAFE AND OVERCROWDED HOUSING
ARE A RISK FACTOR FOR PEOPLE
RETURNING TO HOMELESSNESS. THE
STATE SHOULD INNOVATE AN ACCORD
MATING RESOURCES AND
STREAMLINING MORE QUICKLY- TO
BUILD MORE QUICKLY IN FUNDING
INCENTIVES FOR PRIVATE MARKET
LANDLORDS TO ACCEPT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND IN PROVIDING
SERVICES TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
ACCESS HOUSING AND STAYS DEEPLY
HOUSE. ON THAT LAST POINT ON
SPENDING SERVICES- WE ARE
ADVOCATING FOR CALIFORNIA TO
FUND TO CREATE AND FIND A MEDI
CAL BENEFIT THAT WOULD FUND
HOUSING BASED SERVICES- THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS PRESERVE PROPOSED
A REDESIGN. EVER MEDI CAL
PROGRAM THAT REDESIGN IS- KNOWN
AS CAL AIM BUT CAL AIM DOES NOT
OFFER ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND IN FACT LET IT'S FUNDING.
HOUSING BASED SERVICES. THE
STATE AND OUR COUNTY IS
CURRENTLY SPEND HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR- I
MOSTLY GENERAL FUND DOLLARS ON
HOUSING BASED SERVICES WE COULD
INSTEAD FOLLOW OTHER STATES
LEAD. AND ESTABLISHING
STATEWIDE MEDICAID BENEFIT
FUNDED 95290% BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. I BENEFIT WOULD
IMPROVE THE AVAILABILITY OF
THESE SERVICES OFFER MORE
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA
AND PREVENT PEOPLE NOW HOUSE
FROM RETURNING TO HOMELESSNESS.
IN OTHER WAYS AS WELL
CALIFORNIA COULD BE USING OUR
EXISTING RESOURCES MORE
EFFECTIVELY RATHER THAN
ALLOCATING RESOURCES WITHOUT A
COMPASS THE STATE COULD FOLLOW
THE LEAD OF OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND- DOES AND
ANALYZING THE GAPS IN OUR
RESPONSE. SIMILARLY IF THE
STATE HAD A SINGLE CABINET
LEVEL POSITION ON HOMELESSNESS
DIRECTLY REPORTING TO THE
GOVERNOR AS RECOMMENDED BY BOTH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE OUR STATE COULD
STANDARDIZE OUR HOUSING AND
SERVICES PROGRAMS LOW AT.
APPROACHES TAKEN ORALLY AND A
AND TING. US AS YOU'VE HEARD
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
HOUSING MORE PEOPLE THAN EVER
BEFORE BUT THERE ARE MORE
PEOPLE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS THAN EVER BEFORE
IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES CANNOT
KEEP PACE. AS ONE EXAMPLE OF
THAT AND A LOS ANGELES- LA HAS
BEEN HOUSING A HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE PEOPLE THAT DAY BUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY ARE FONG THE
HOMELESSNESS WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR
THE TWELVE. HE'S CLEAN TWENTY
AT NINE. SHOW THAT THE THAT IN
INEQUALITY WHICH PURCHASE RENTS
BEYOND WITH HOUSEHOLDS AND
PROPERTY CAN AFFORD AN
INSTITUTIONAL SYSTEMS FEET
HOMELESSNESS THESE DATA
INDICATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IF
TARGETED TO HOUSEHOLDS WITH
EXTREMELY LOW INCOMES OR EVEN
WELL BELOW EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
LEVEL. HOWEVER EVEN CREATING
MORE HOUSING AFFORDABLE TO
HOUSING WITH EXTREMELY
HOUSEHOLDS WITH EXTREMELY LOW
INCOMES WAS SEVERE RANT BURDENS
IS OVER BROAD AS A PREVENTION
RESPONSE. A FEW OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS WILL BECOME HOMELESS
ABOUT LESS THAN A THIRD
ACTUALLY AND MOST HOMELESS
PREVENTION PROGRAMS BROUGHT HER
GETTING FAILS TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AMONG PEOPLE WHO
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BECOME
HOMELESS WITHOUT THESE PROGRAM.
FOR THESE REASONS THESE
PROGRAMS ARE NOT EFFICIENT AS
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND- THE
THIS PROGRAM THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY FROM CHICAGO-
PROVIDES SHORT TERM CASH
ASSISTANCE TO HOUSEHOLDS
FEARING HOMELESSNESS. BUT A
RECENT STUDY THAT CAME OUT SO
THAT ONLY- LESS THAN 2% ABOUT
ONE AND A HALF PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE HELP BY THAT PROGRAM
WOULD HAVE BECOME HOMELESS
WITHOUT THE PROGRAM. AT THE
PROGRAM OBVIOUSLY HAS BY YOU IS
VERY EFFECTIVE IN GIVING PEOPLE
SHORT TERM FIX BUT WAS NOT
REALLY PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM
BECAUSE HOME YES. IN FACT THE
VAST THE PEOPLE WHO ARE FIXING
AFFECTION OR REPORT DURING
BUSINESS WILL NEVER BE HOMELESS.
TURN ANY PENSION RAM IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN CREATING
AN EFFICIENT STRATEGY BUT IT'S
EXTREMELY TRICKY. A RECENT UCLA
POLICY LAB AND UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO POVERTY LAB TO STUDY
pINCLUDE PREVIOUS EPISODES OF
HOMELESSNESS AND SHARP SURPRISE
BIKES AND- COUNTY SERVICES-
USAGE SIX MONTHS PRIOR. THE
PERSON'S REPORTING THAT THE- TO
STAY. FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FOR THE FIRST
TIME. THE STATE SHOULD ENSURE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS ARE
TARGETED TO THOSE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS DOES AND THAT WOULD BE
BASED. ON PREDICT- ALGORITHM
OUR PANEL TAKES DATA. AND
PREVENTING RETURNS TO
HOMELESSNESS IS ALSO CRITICAL
STRATEGY A NUMBER OF- OF
HOUSEHOLDS WITH PREVIOUS
EPISODES OF HOMELESSNESS WHO
HAD RECEIVED TEMPORARY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. SUCH AS RAPID RE
HOUSING ONLY- FACE HOMELESSNESS
ONCE THEIR SUBSIDY ENDED AND
ONE CRITICAL STRATEGY AS CHRIS
MARTIN MENTIONED COULD BE TO
TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
OUR STATE FUNDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAMS. HAVE A SET
ASIDE FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SO THAT THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS ONCE THEIR RENTAL
THEIR RAPID RE HOUSING ENDS
THERE'S RENTAL ASSISTANCE
SUBSIDY ENDS THEY DON'T FALL
BACK AND THOMAS SAYS THAT WOULD
BE A CRITICAL. PREVENTION
STRATEGY. ONE WAY BERKSHIRE
PREVENT WOULD BE TO STATE FOR
OF HOUSING AS I MENTION
SERVICES HOMELESS BENEFICIARIES
AND ANOTHER WOULD BE TO DEVELOP
PROGRAM- PROTOCOLS TO PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM DISCHARGING FROM
STATE FUNDED INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS AND A HOMELESSNESS.
FROM HOSPITALS AND NURSING
HOMES FROM SUBSTANCE USE
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES FROM PRISONS AND
JAILS AND FROM FOSTER CARE.
DISCHARGED INNING SHOULD TAKE
HOUSING INTO ACCOUNT. AND
INCLUDE HOUSING NAVIGATION AND
SUBSIDIES FOR PEOPLE HAVE WHO
HAVE NOWHERE TO GO UPON
DISCHARGE. FINALLY I WOULD URGE
THAT ANY FUNDING SPENT ON
PREVENTION SEPARATE AND APART
FROM ANY PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
RESOLVE PEOPLE'S HOMELESSNESS
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT IS A LOT
EASIER TO SERVE SOMEBODY WHO'S
STILL HOUSE THAN IT IS TO SERVE
SOMEBODY WHO'S ON THE STREETS.
AND SO I WENT ON A CD- THE
LATTER. TRANING THE STORE OF
THE FORMER STRATEGY TO GET
PEOPLE OFF OF THE STREETS AND
INTO HOMES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR ATTENTION I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. HI GOOD MORNING- OR
GOOD AFTERNOON I THINK WE
VENTURED INTO THE AFTERNOON BY
NOW YEAH- MY NAME'S CHRIS TO
ASK ABOUT I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY SERVICES BRANCH AT THE
YMCA OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY I'M
ALSO THE VICE CHAIR AND A BOARD
MEMBER AT FIVE PUBLIC POLICY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH A STATEWIDE ADVOCACY
GROUP THAT'S BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
SAY I'VE I'VE BEEN IN SOCIAL
WORK AND I'VE BEEN A SOCIAL
WORK PRACTITIONER FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS. AND THIS IS THE
MOST ATTENTION I'VE EVER SEEN
TO THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS IN
GENERAL- BUT SPECIFICALLY YOU
HOMELESSNESS. AND I'M JUST
REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE HERE-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT THIS AND APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION. BUT
PARTICULARLY TO THE ISSUE OF
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS
WHAT ALL ALL TALK ABOUT TODAY.
ALL ALL SHARE A COUPLE OF
COMPELLING REASONS WHY A FOCUS
ON HOMELESS YOUNG PEOPLE IS
EXTREMELY CRITICAL. AND BRIFLY
DISCUSS WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND FOR US- AS PRACTITIONERS
IN THE FIELD. THE FIRST OUR
FIRST VERY COMPELLING REASON.
IS THAT- MANY CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS ADULTS HAD THEIR FIRST
HOMELESS EXPERIENCE BETWEEN THE
AGES OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR.
AND WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
HOMELESSNESS DURING AN
ADULTHOOD. LEADS TO FUTURE
HOMELESSNESS LATER IN LIFE. I
THE RECENT STUDIES HAVE TOLD US
THAT ANYWHERE FROM A QUARTER
250% OF CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
ADULTS REPORTED THEIR FIRST
HOMELESS EXPERIENCE DURING THE
TRANSITION AG TEARS. THAT'S
REALLY SIGNIFICANT- IF SOMEBODY
BROUGHT YOU A- A SORT OF AT AT
INTERVENTION RIGHT NOW THAT
COULD CUT CHRONICALLY
HOMELESSNESS. BY 25250% TODAY-
I THINK WE ALL JUMP ON THAT
RIGHT AND YOUNG PEOPLE FOCUSING
ON YOUNG PEOPLE WILL ABSOLUTELY
DO THAT. AND OUR OUR OUR
INVESTMENT DURING THIS TIME
ALSO IN TRANSITION AG OF ITS X.
SURE ROUTINELY CRITICAL AND IT
CAN BE. AIRY LASTING FOR THIS
POPULATION ADOLESCENCE IS
ACTUALLY THE SECOND MOST
PROFOUND PERIOD OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT SECOND ONLY TO THE
ZERO FIVE YEARS. THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO US WE THINK ABOUT
INVESTMENTS BECAUSE WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH YOUNG PEOPLE CAN GO
VERY FAR TO CREATING BEHAVIOR
CHANGE AMONG THIS GROUP-
INTERVENTIONS THAT FOCUS ON
SELF REGULATION- THAT IS
EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONING WHICH IS
REALLY THE FOUNDATION FOR
LIFELONG FUNCTIONING. OUR
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
THESE CRITICAL UC'S SKILLS ARE
EXTREMELY RESPONSIVE TO
INTERVENTION. ADDITIONALLY
INTERVENTIONS THAT HELP AT
YOUNG PEOPLE FOCUS ON
DEVELOPING AND MOANED AND
MAINTAINING ROBUST. SOCIAL
SUPPORT HELP THEM INCREASE
THEIR OWN SOCIAL CAPITAL. THAT
CAPITAL PERSISTS LONG AFTER OUR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES ARE GONE.
AND WE'VE HEARD FOLKS TODAY
TALK ABOUT THE SAFETY NET- WHEN
WE THINK THEIR RELATIONSHIPS
AND SOCIAL CAPITAL HUMANS ARE
NATURAL SAFETY NETS AND WE
THINK ABOUT FOLKS WHO ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHO
ARE NOT EXPERIENCING SYSTEMS
WHO HAVE NOT HAD. THAT
TRAUMATIC OR ADVERSE LIFE
EXPERIENCES AND THEY'RE STILL
RELIANT ON THEIR PARENTS OR
OTHER FAMILY UNTIL THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX AT LEAST. THAT'S THE
NEW AVERAGE SO WHEN WE EXPECT
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD THESE
VERY SIGNIFICANT EXPERIENCES TO
OPERATE WITHOUT SERVICES THAT
FOCUS ON THEIR ABILITY TO SET
GOALS. REDUCE BASS MANAGE. AT
WORK WE'RE NOT GONNA MAKE IT IN
AND SERVING THIS GROUP OF YOUNG
PEOPLE SO FOCUSING SUPPORT FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE ON THESE CRITICAL
SKILL DEVELOPMENT AREAS IS
ESSENTIAL. I WE ALSO KNOW WHEN
I AND I THINK RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME TO REITERATE THAT- HOUSING
FIRST AS DOES NOT MEAN HOUSING
ONLY. AND THAT IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THIS POPULATION I
AND- HOW PROVIDING HOUSING
ACCESS TO BASIC NEEDS CERTAINLY
REDUCES STRESS SO THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE CAN BEGAN TO USE THEIR
BRAINS. I'M MOR EFFECTIVELY
AND EFFICIENTLY TO SET GOALS
AND ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS I AM
BUT THEY ALSO NEED HUMANS THAT
HELP THEM DO THAT. AND SO IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE STRATEGICALLY.
FOCUSED ON INTERVENTIONS THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH MENTAL HEALTH-
THAT HAVE TO DO WITH- HIGHER
LEVELS OF CASE MANAGEMENT- SO
THIS MEANS THAT PROVIDERS NEED
TO PAY QUALIFIED STAFF MEMBERS
TRAIN NO STAFF MEMBERS AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND- BETTER OFF MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND BRAIN PAINTS.
UNDERSTAND HE'S EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS. I'M AND LAST I
THINK. I THINK IT MAKES SENSE
TO SAY THAT INVESTING IN YOUNG
PEOPLE WILL SAVE US MONEY IN
THE LONG RUN- LA'S ECONOMIC
ROUND TABLE- TOLD US IN A
RECENT REPORT THAT THAT COST OF
THESE INTERVENTIONS-
PARTICULARLY ONES THAT ARE
ADEQUATELY TARGETED TO THE
RIGHT INDIVIDUALS. RESULTS AND
AVOIDED PUBLIC COSTS THAT WILL
MORE THAN OFFSET THE COST OF
THOSE INTERVENTIONS. I HOMELESS
YOUTH GO ON TO USE PUBLIC
RESOURCES SUCH AS MEDICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BECOME
INCARCERATED- THEY HAVE A
CONTINUED NEED FOR HOUSING IN
SUPPORT OF SERVICE SAYS. AT THE
USE CASH EIGHT MORE FREQUENTLY
CHILD CARE FOOD STAMPS ON THOSE
THINGS ARE ALL VERY EXPENSIVE.
IF WE DIVERT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
FROM A LIFE OF CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS INTO THRIVING
TRAJECTORIES NOT ONLY DO YOU
SAVE MONEY ON POTENTIAL
INTERVENTIONS. BUT WE REALIZED
THAT. TO ALL AND ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTIONS THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE.
NUMBER THREE THROUGH THEIR LAST
CREATE OPTIMAL. FOR THE FUTURE.
AND THIS IS. BREAKING THE CYCLE.
FURTHER THERE'S BEEN A HISTORIC
UNDER INVESTMENT IN THIS
POPULATION AND WE KNOW SO MUCH
MORE NOW ABOUT WHAT WORKS ON
AND MANY REGIONS ARE PREPARED
TODAY TO DEPLOY APPROPRIATE
SERVICE SAYS- THROUGH
COORDINATED SYSTEMS LEVELS
APPROACHES NOW- SO ON THE
GROUND AND YEAH WE AT THE YMCA
IN SAN DIEGO SERVE. ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YOUNG PEOPLE
AND HOUSING ANNUALLY AND THOSE
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE.
ACTED IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
OR EVEN PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO
SYSTEMS INVOLVEMENT SO WE ARE
INTIMATELY I'M AWARE OF THE
BARRIERS THAT THEY FACE AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE BELIEVE IS
WORKING THUS FAR. IS THAT
PARTICULARLY EVIDENCED AND KEEP
AND HAPPY AND THAT IS AT THE
COORDINATED APPROACH THAT'S
REQUIRED AT A REGIONAL LEVEL SO
THAT FLEXIBILITY I THINK IS A
FOURTEEN COMMUNITIES. TO
IDENTIFY THE GAPS IN SERVICES
THE POPULATIONS OF FOCUS ON AND
OBVIOUSLY- AND AT THE CAPACITY
BUILDING THAT IT THAT THAT'S
POSSIBLE WITH WITHOUT FUNDING.
I'M AND I THINK ON THE GROUND
RIGHT NOW ALL WE ARE BUILDING A
AN EFFECTIVE COORDINATED
APPROACH TO AND HOMELESSNESS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND- WITH TEN
FUNDING. AND FURTHER EVALUATION
I THINK WE HEARD THAT AMONG A
LOT OF FOLKS TODAY WE NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WORKS AND
STOP DOING THE THINGS THAT
DON'T. AND THE- DAY FOCUS ON
THIS GROUP MUST. MASS BE A
PRIOR AND CONTINUE TO BE A
PRIORITY SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME REALLY APPRECIATE
IT. GOOD MORNING SENATOR IS MY
NAME IS MAGGIE MERIT AND I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. THE SAME
BURKE INSTITUTE IS A NON PROFIT
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE. THAT
WAS FOUNDED BY A FORMER SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM DARRELL
STEINBERG. SACRAMENTO'S CURRENT
MAYOR AND WE ARE DEDICATED TO
ADVANCING SOUND PUBLIC POLICY
AN INSPIRING LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUES OF BRAIN HEALTH. IT IS
AN HONOR TO. BE INVITED TO COME
AND TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL ILLNESS
NOT ONLY AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE BUT ALSO AS SOMEONE
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE. I HAVE
EXPERIENCED ABUSE I AM A MEMBER
OF THE NEED TO COMMUNITY. WITH
MY TWO YOUNG SONS MANY YEARS
AGO I DID ESCAPE OF VIOLENT
ENVIRONMENT I HEALED FROM A
DRUG ADDICTION I. FAILED
SUICIDE ATTEMPT AND I LIVE WITH
GENERALIZED ANXIETY DISORDER
WHICH YOU MIGHT SEE SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS OF TODAY THIS IS ONE
OF MY FAVORITE. EXPERIENCES IN
LIFE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LETTING ME PRACTICE OF BEING
HERE AS MYSELF- AS I SHOW UP.
SO YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT BEFORE
I START THOUGH I DO WANNA ALSO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND FOR
YOUR COLLABORATION I REALLY
THINK THAT THIS IS THE DAY THIS
IS THE TIME- FOR US TO
COLLABORATE MY HURRIED SO MANY
FOLKS SAY THAT WE NEED TO. KIND
OF AND THIS PIECEMEAL. KIND OF
APPLICATION OF KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER
AND I THINK YOU ARE A MODEL OF
THAT COLLABORATION SO I REALLY
HONOR YOU FOR THIS THIS WORK.
ON YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS ITSELF ALL ELSE
GET THOSE NOTES I. THOUGHT I
EXIT TEN MINUTES SO I'M GONNA.
EDIT WHILE I TALK- OF FOUR
YEARS WE BELIEVE THAT ABOUT A
QUARTER TO A THIRD. OF THE
HOMELESS COMMUNITY WAS MADE UP
OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE. THE WITH
THE MENTAL AND A MENTAL ILLNESS
AND- THANKS TO THAT COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO DID A VERY GOOD JOB
OF CREATING A REPORT FOR YOU-
AND THEY POINTED OUT THAT THE-
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB AT UCLA
ACTUALLY DID A TWO YEAR STUDY
OF ABOUT SIXTY FOURTH HOUSE AND
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN FIFTEEN
STATES WHERE THEY FELT WITH IT
FOUND THAT IS A HUGE
DIFFERENCE. BETWEEN AND
SHELTERED PEOPLE. WELL DONE AS
HAVING A MENTAL ILLNESS THOUGH
THEY DIDN'T BREAK OUT FROM YOU
KNOW STATE TO STATE THEY FOUND
THAT THERE WAS REALLY NO
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN-
BETWEEN STATES SO SOME EXAMPLES
ARE AMONG THE AND SHELTERED.
84% REPORTED HAVING A PHYSICAL
HEALTH CONDITION 78% HAD A
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION AND 75%
HOW TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE
CONDITION. 50% OF THE AND
SHELTERED PAUL OUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY I HAD ALL THREE PHYSICAL
MENTAL AND SUBSTANCE USE-
CHALLENGES SO EVEN AMONG THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE
SHELTERED LIVING IN SHELTERS
ARE ON A FRIEND'S COUCH EXCEPT
TRES FIFTY PRIESTS ON 50%
REPORTED HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION. SELL AMONG AND
SHELTERED 50% SAID THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS CONTRIBUTED
TO THEIR- BEING AND HOW IS IT
COMPARED 217% OF- SHELTERED
FOLKS. 51% OF THE AND SHE SAID
THE SUBSTANCE USE THAT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
CONTRIBUTED TO HOMELESSNESS
COMPARED 26% OF SHELTERED. FELT
BY THE WAY IN MANY PLACES BOTH
MEN AND WOMEN SAY THEY USE MATH
TO STAY AWAKE AT NIGHT- TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES SO WHICH
FURTHER EXACERBATES THE RATE OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER ON THE
STREETS. A HUGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE SAID THAT- TRAUMA OR
ABUSE CONTRIBUTED TO THEIR
HOMELESSNESS. 38% OF ON
SHELTERED MEN HAD EXPERIENCED
TRAUMA AND 80% OF AND SHELTERED
WOMEN HAD EXPERIENCED TRAUMA.
AS LA COUNTY IS THAT DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTOR DR
JONATHAN SHARE AND SOMETIMES
POINTS OUT THE CLOSING OF OUR
MENTAL HEALTH ASYLUMS BACK IN
THE REAGAN ERA. WITH THE
CORRESPONDING FAILURE TO OPEN
THE AND INTENDED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS GAVE RISE TO TWO
NEW TYPES OF A SILENCE. THE
INDOOR ASYLUM WHICH IS NOW
KNOWN AS OUR IS KNOWN AS OUR
JAILS AND PRISONS. AND OUR
OUTDOOR ASYLUM WHICH IS KNOWN
AS HOMELESSNESS AND WE CAN SEE
THAT TO BE TRUE IF YOU HAVE NOT
YET VISITED THE LA COUNTY JAIL.
IT'S SOMETHING I WOULD
RECOMMEND- IT'S IT WOULD NEVER
LEAVE YOUR MEMORY AND IT WILL
FUEL THE FIRE YOU ALREADY HAVE
AND PASSION YOU HAVE AROUND
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES. MENTAL
ILLNESS DOES NOT NEED TO BE A
LIFE SENTENCE OF DYSFUNCTION WE
MUST REMOVE BARRIERS THAT MAKE
ACCESSING CARE POSSIBLE WE NEED
A WIDE VARIETY OF SOLUTIONS TO
COME ONLINE NOW. SOME SOLUTIONS
INCLUDE TRAINING PROFESSIONALS
WHO INTERACTED WITH OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR YOUTH ABOUT
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE AND ABOUT
AND HOW TO IDENTIFY EARY SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS OF MENTAL HEALTH
OR MENTAL ILLNESS AND WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT CARE IS
ACCESSIBLE WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
EARLY PSYCHOSIS IDENTIFICATION
AND SCALE THAT PRACTICE UP
ACROSS THE STATE. WE NEED TO
GET SERIOUS ABOUT INCREASING
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE.
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE MUST
SEE TO IT THAT THERE REALLY IS
TRUE PARITY IN BOTH THE PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC SECTORS AS IT
RELATES TO PROVIDING ONGOING
CARE TO THOSE WHO LIVE WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS. AND OR IS
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER JUST AS
WE DO FOR PHYSICAL HEALTH. WE
ALSO REALLY NEED TO GET SERIOUS
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH IN THE
WORKPLACE. WE NEED TO LEARN HOW
TO ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS IN OUR
PLACES OF EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE SO
MANY FOLKS ARE UNABLE TO THRIVE
IN THEIR WORKPLACE BECAUSE WE
JUST NEED AS EMPLOYERS TO BE
EDUCATED ABOUT HOW WE A CALM.
THESE FOLKS AND IF THEY'RE NOT
A COMMON NEEDED AND THEY'RE
NOT- THRIVING THAN THEY OFTEN
LOSE THEIR JOB. LOSING THEIR
EMPLOYMENT LEAD TO HOMELESSNESS
SO LET'S REALLY START THINKING
ABOUT THAT. AND AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED ALREADY WE NEED TO
SCALE UP WHOLE PERSON CARE IT'S
THE IT WORKS AND WE KNOW IT
WORKS AND WE ALSO NEED TO SEE
HOUSING AS A VITAL COMPONENT OF
THAT CARE IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
FOR SOMEONE WITH A MENTAL
ILLNESS TO STABILIZE WHILE
LIVING. ON THE STREETS WE-
DURING HIS STATE OF THIS
GOVERNOR NEW SOME SOMEWHAT OFF
HANDEDLY- SAYING THAT HE
THOUGHT THAT DOCTORS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO WRITE A PRESCRIPTION
FOR HOUSING. AND AT THE SAME
AGAINST IF YOU WILL WE AGREE
WITH THAT. WITHOUT A STABLE
HOUSE THE CHALLENGES OF GETTING
THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION INTO
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT AND
RECOVERY ARE MONUMENTAL AND
SOMETIMES IMPOSSIBLE. I HAVE
MULTIPLE PAGES. GOING ON SO I'M
GOING TO JUST SAY THAT THE
OTHER ISSUES AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT WE NEED
TO PAY ATTENTION TO OUR
BOARDING CARE. OUT WE'RE LOSING
THEM AT AN ALARMING RATE AND
THOSE FOLKS ARE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS. WE DO THE LPS ACT
WAS MENTIONED TODAY WE HAVE THE
STATE AUDITOR DOING AN AUDIT OF
THAT APPLICATION OF LPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RIGHT NOW
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. THAT REPORT
IN APRIL. WE NEED TO LOOK AT NO
PLACE LIKE HOME OF- PROGRAMS
THAT THE SAME BURKE INSTITUTE
SPONSORED- AS AN OPTION FOR A
WIDER VARIETY OF HOUSING BEYOND
HIS PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND- WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WORKFORCE ISSUES SO AT THAT
I'LL JUST LEAVE IT WITH THAT WE
ALSO I SHOULDN'T. MISS THIS ONE.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
LOOK MORE CLOSELY AT HOW THOSE
FUNDS ARE TARGETED TOWARD TOLD.
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FEDERAL CASKEY THROUGH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO
CORRECT. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK IN AND I THANK YOU I KNOW
I WORKERS WORKING TOGETHER ON
ON- AN OFFER NOT SUPPOSED TO
MENTION CIRCLE RACIAL HEARINGS
BUT- SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE TO ENSURE THAT I-
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
ACTUALLY COVERING ALL MEDICALLY
NECESSARY. MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION CARER- AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THE HEARING- WE'VE
SET UP A SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE.
ARE GIVEN CARE WHEN THEY'RE
ALREADY IN CRISIS CENTER NOT
GIVING CARE IN ORDER TO PREVENT
A CRISIS IT'S SORT OF. LIKE
SAYING WELL WE KNOW YOU HAVE
STAGE ONE CANCER BUT WILL COVER
YOU ONCE YOU'RE AT STAGE FOR-
AND THEN THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES CAN COMPLAIN WEALTHY
FORCES TO COVER STATE ONE
CANCER. THAT'LL JUST BE MORE
EXPENSIVE AND COULD AFFECT OUR
PREMIUMS IT'S AN ABSURD
ARGUMENT- AND WE WOULD NEVER WE
WILL. BE WITH ALL LEFT THEM OUT
OF THE ROOM IF THEY MADE THAT
ARGUMENT AROUND PHYSICAL HEALTH
AND YET WE TOLERATE THAT
ARGUMENT. AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
AND ADDICTION WHICH ARE ALSO
MAJOR HEALTH CHALLENGES SO.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THAT. OKAY WELL I WE DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS- SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- TIME
TODAY AND FOR YOUR INSIGHTS SO
THAT IS- IT OUR FINAL PANEL I
WILL NOW. OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS- IF THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN MY PALM COUNTIES COME
FORWARD. COULDN'T LIBBY SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
BOTH TO THE SENATORS AND STAFF
FOR PUTTING TOGETHER SUCH AN
INFORMATIVE HEARING ON AS WAS
MADE CLEAR THERE'S NO PANACEA
THERE'S NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
FIX. BITES THERE ARE MANY
DIFFERENT SUBPOPULATIONS OF THE
HOMELESS THAT I'M VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU COVERING TODAY
NOT JUST LIMITING THE HEARING
TO THE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS IN
THOSE WITH MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES BUT
THE 75% OF THE POPULATION OF
HOMELESS WITH JORDAN COOLEY
HOMELESS FAMILIES STRUGGLING
AND FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS.
CHILDREN ADULTS OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY THAT'S WHERE WE COME IN
TO HELP WE ARE THE PUBLIC
SOCIAL SAFETY NET- IN YOUR
COUNTIES WE ARE ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS WE ARE PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES WE ARE SOCIAL WORKERS WE
ARE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES PERSON
AT ALL. BUT WE ARE STRETCHED
PAPER THAN IN OUR BRICK AND
MORTAR CAP PARTMINER PERSONAL
SERVICES OFFICES WE GET CALLS
ALL THE TIME FROM COUNTY
PARTNER SAYING PLEASE SEND
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS OUT TO OUR
FACILITY PLEASE SEND PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES AT. A SENATOR
BELL MENTIONED WE HAVE A HUGE
PROBLEM WITH FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESS ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND LOCAL STATE COLLEGES AND
THE PROBLEM IS DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO ARE ABLE TO
OUT. TO THE OLD SO. OUT OF THE
GATE THIS THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES. TO CONSIDER OUT
STATIONING. MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAMS OF COUNTY WORKERS AT
PLACES LIKE LIBRARIES SCHOOLS
JAILS COURTHOUSES HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS ANYWHERE WHERE WE
CAN HELP BECAUSE WE ARE HERE TO
DO THE WORK WE JUST NEED TO BE
OUT THERE IN THE FIELD TO DO IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TYLER IN THE
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION-
WOULD LIKE TO MENTION THAT- IN
TODAY'S POPULATION EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ABOUT A QUARTER OF
THE POPULATION HAS. A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER- WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAPSE STUDY
WHEN WE LOOK DEEPLY AT THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED IT
WAS ASKING OF WHETHER THE
PERSON HAD EVER HAD A HISTORY
OF MENTAL ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER. AND IT DID NOT
TALK ABOUT THEIR CURRENT
CONDITION- WELL I'M THAT THEY
HAD A WHETHER THEY WERE LIVING
ON THE STREETS TODAY WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT THE LONGER THAT
SOMEONE ENDS UP EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON THE STREETS THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE TO DEVELOP
CAN BUT ONE WE'VE LOOKED AT
THE- AT THE RESEARCH COMING OF.
I'M BY DOCTOR COULD. IN THE-
ABOUT 2% OF THE POT MISSION AT
SIX IN HOMELESS TODAY NEEDS I
PERMAN SUPPORT HOUSING. AND
THAT THERE'S THE OTHER A PER OF
THAT. PREVENTION WE CAN SAVE A
LOT OF DOLLARS THE ROAD FOR
THAT SO THAT THEY DO NOT
DEVELOP THIS YEAR'S MENTAL
ILLNESS AND NEED TO BE INNER
HAVE INTERVENTIONS OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. ALSO LIKE
TO MENTION THAT WE ARE LOSING
OUR BOARDING CARE FACILITIES AT
A VERY RAPID RATE TODAY- THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS LOST
OVER FORTY FIVE FACILITIES. AND
TWELVE HUNDRED BATS IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS. AND THEN ON THAT
IT'S REPLICATED ACROSS THE
STATE IN OTHER COMMUNITIES AND
THIS IS REALLY IMPACTING OUR
ABILITY TO- YOU KNOW HOW WITH
THE CRISIS- WE HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE EITHER.
AT RISK OF EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR IT IS A- THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE. TRANSITION
PRIVATE PREVIOUSLY THEY WERE
FORMERLY HOMELESS IN A STUDY
THAT SERVER DISCO HAD DONE THEY
HAD SEEN THAT- SO THEIR ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES- 94% OF
THE- FACILITIES HAD. HAD A PER
IN THERE FOR SO WHO HOW BEEN
PRE. HOME LAST SO IT'S REALLY
IMPACT IN OUR ABILITY TO ARM
YOU KNOW HELP THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION THANK YOU. CAN LUIS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOU THEN- THANK
YOU FOR THIS HEARING TODAY AND
THAT SPECIAL FOCUS PARTICULARLY
ON YOUTH- BUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S NEVER REPRESENTATION-
AB LGBTQ YOUTH AND ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION AS WELL AS YOUTH OF
COLOR- AND I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED TO THEM
ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE. AND EMBODY A
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
MODELS THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THEM THROUGH SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT KRISTA HIGHLIGHTED AROUND
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE FOR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT. AND APPROPRIATE
SERVICES AND IT IS A DIFFERENT
INTERVENTION FOR SOME OF THESE
YET THEY HAVE NO PLACE TO GO
HOME TO. AND SO I KNOW A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO HAVE CHILDREN OF
THEIR OWN YOU KNOW I STILL GO
HOME TO GO TO MY- AND STAY
THERE IF I NEEDED TO BUT MANY
OF THESE KIDS DON'T FEEL SAFE
RETURNING TO THEIR HOME
ENVIRONMENTS AND SO. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE SAFETY NET
IS AVAILABLE FOR THEM AND NOT
MUCH OF A SAFETY NET. AND SO
BUT AS I THAT HAS BEEN DONE THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS BY THIS
LEGISLATURE WAS CRITICAL TO GET
COMMUNITIES THINKING ABOUT ONE
OF THE SAFETY NET NEEDED FOR
OUR YOUTH PARTICULARLY.
CONCERNED CURRENTLY TO CONTINUE
PARTS GOING FOR THIS YEAR AND
IT. THE EDGE IF AS FOR HAVE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AND
ALSO THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING AND TO ECHO. C<c.cyan></c>
SENTIMENT IS FOR INCLUDING
DISCUSSION OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS SENATE HEARING-
I'M HERE TO- I'M- I'M SIMONE
DIRECTLY I'M-HERE FROM JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. AND
I'M HERE TO ENSURE THAT. THAT
WE ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
AS WE- PLAN AND THINK ABOUT HOW
TO ADDRESS HOMELESS IS
GENERALLY IN CALIFORNIA I HAVE
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS- THE FIRST
IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. ONE WAY
TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS AMONGST
FOSTER YOUTH IS TO CREATE A
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT TO
STRENGTHEN THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLACEMENT FOR NON MINOR
DEPENDENCE TEACH PMD PROVIDE
HOUSING AND IMPORTANT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. TO OVER
TWO THOUSAND YEARS EACH YEAR
AND RIGHT NOW THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS THREATENING THIS
PLACEMENT OPTION- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE COST OF
HOUSING. HAS INCREASED 64% BUT
THE RATE PAID FOR THIS
PLACEMENT FOR YOU PER MONTH HAS
INCREASE JUST 24% AND THIS IS A-
IT THREE HAD FORTY ONE YOUTH ON
THE WAITING LIST AS OF LAST
JUNE THIRTIETH. THAT'S A 60%
BASIC MUST BE BETTER NUMBER
HERE AND STATE OR PROP. OF NOT
OF ON THE WAY LIST AND MANY OF
THESE ON THE THAT THERE HOW.
AND SOME OF THEM ARE PARENTS
AND MEMBER- FILL TING HAS
INTRODUCED AB TO ANY EIGHT
EIGHTY WHICH WOULD CREATE A
HOUSING SUPPLEMENT AND COUNTIES
WHERE THE COST OF HOUSING HAS
OUT. BUT THE TEACHER DO YOU EAT
AND SUB DRAWDOWN TITLE FORTY.
FIVE FINDING. MY SECOND RUN. IS
ENSURE THAT THE FOR ANY FUNDING
THAT INCLUDED IN IN THE STATE
BUDGET TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDES A YOUTH SATISFIED-
THIS APPROACH WITH UTILIZED THE
LAST TWO BUDGET CYCLES AND IT'S
WORKING- WE'VE DONE SOME
RESEARCH ON IT KEEP
IMPLEMENTATION OF HEAT FUNDING
OF THE YOUTH SET ASIDE FUNDING.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THAT ACTUALLY
THE MINIMUM THE FIVE PERSON.
UNITIES AS A WHOLE STATEWIDE
ACTUALLY SPENT TEN POINT 8% AND
IT'S HELPING THEM BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. AND ALSO
ADDRESSING AT A LOCAL LEVEL
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED TODAY THAT SCENE WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO I JUST URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT INCLUDING A
SATISFIED. I IN THE BOB THIS
COMING YEAR'S BUDGET AS WELL
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CODY I'M TWENTY TWO
YEARS OLD- I'M HERE WITH JOHN
BYRNE'S ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH I
WANT TO ADDRESS THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING A YOU'VE SET ASIDE- I
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS WHEN I
TURNED EIGHTEEN- AFTER I WAS
KICKED OUT OF MY FOSTER
PLACEMENT. I TRY TO FIND USE
HOMELESS SERVICES AND WAS AN
ABLE TO RECEIVE ANY SERVICES. I
TRIED IT AT THE END TO GET INTO
ADULT SHELTERS. AND THAT TURNED
OUT TO BE EVEN MORE TRAUMATIC
FOR ME- THEY WERE NOT SENSITIVE
TO THE NEEDS OF ME COMING FROM
A DRAMATIC BACKGROUND. I WAS
EMOTIONALLY AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY
ARE. I HAD AN OUTSIDE SUPPORT
THERE WITH ME AT THE TIME THAT
I WAS TRYING TO GET INTO THE
SHELF. AND THEY HAD ACTIVELY
TìM OUT. OF WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO SETTLED IN AND LOCK THE
GATES AND BEING SURROUNDED BY
YOUR- AT EIGHTEEN AND TRYING TO
OPEN UP. EMOTIONALLY TO THE
PEOPLE PROVIDING SERVICES- IT
WAS NOT HEALTHY FOR ME I WAS
VISIBLY. TRAUMATIZED AND THEY
DIDN'T. OFFER SYMPATHY TOWARDS
THAT- SO I WANT TO SAY THAT
HAVING ASIDE- FUNDING- AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED SUPPORTING
THE AB. TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY.
FOUR FOUGHT FOR YOU WANT SURE
THAT CURRENTLY. ST HOW. TO GET
IS IT HAVE. CONTACT I DID WORK
IN FRONT LISTENING. I'M AND I
HOPE TO ADDRESS THAT ON THE
PANEL WHAT HAD WAS MENTION WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH FOR I'VE
STRUGGLED A LOT MY AND WHEN I
DID FOR SEE WITH HOUSE I
STARTED REALIZING A LOT OF
THINGS ARE COMING UP FROM MY
PASS AND I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY IT WAS STABLE I WAS DOING
WELL IN SCHOOL. AND MY MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDER HEAD IT LET ME
KNOW THAT WHEN SOMEONE BECOMES
STABLE. THERE ARE PROVIDED THE
SPACE TO ACTUALLY DEAL WITH THE
THINGS THAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH. SO HOUSING IS THE
FIRST STEP FOR US YOU TO BE
ABLE TO OVERCOME OUR PAST AND
OUR TRAUMA. WITHOUT THAT IT
BECOMES TEN TIMES ORDER FOR US
TO. OF ALL INTO FUNCTIONING
ADULT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT. SAME
NUMBER WAS PUBLIC COMMENT- AND
THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING ON
BEHALF OF. CENTER HER TODD OWN
CENTER MCGUIRE I WANT TO. THANK
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED NOT
AS A LOT OF WORK- THIS YEAR IN
THIS AREA I DON'T KNOW WE'RE
WORKING WITH A LOT OF THESE
WITNESSES I LOOK FORWARDTO IT-
SO WITH THAT. THE RESULT. IS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.